bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour cette
nouvelle saison de la pros League je
suis le grand maître international
Laurent Fossier je suis ravi d'être
rejoint à part un des meilleurs joueurs
bretons de tous les temps bon mon ami le
grand l'unique le maître international
le coach très reconnu dans les échecs
français le maître attentionnel Kevin
thérieux comment ça va mon cher Kevin
salut à toi Laurence salut à tous bah ça
va très bien Laurent belle entrée en
matière là tu nous régales d'entrer si
les gens t'avais vu à la technique avant
le live c'était pas tout à fait le même
son de cloche Laurent ouais mais alors
ce qui se trouve
alors j'ai peut-être un peu craché la
soupe mais j'avais pas que cheescom
c'était des dingues ils arrivent ils me
donnent les clés du camion il me dit
vas-y allez on fonce j'ai eu
heureusement en attente qui va bien aidé
mais je dois avouer que c'est c'est pas
la même c'est pas les mêmes dispositifs
catch 24 donc j'ai un peu de mal et tu
j'adore ça non mais j'adore mettre les
mains dans le cambouis à prendre des
choses et tout ça et tu sais quoi mon
cher Kevin c'est une grande première
mondiale c'est diffusé aujourd'hui sur
la chaîne twitch cheese come fr sur la
chaîne sur la chaîne Youtube cheesecom
fr bon jusqu'ici
et en simultané sur chaise 24 fr oh là
là d'accord là c'est c'est c'est quoi
assez ça y est ça y est c'est la c'est
c'est l'aventure qui sort est-ce qu'on
est-ce que quelqu'un peut nous faire
signe de vie là s'il vous plaît allez-y
ok est-ce que est-ce qu'il y a une
personne qui nous regarde un petit
coucou et est-ce que est-ce qu'on nous
entend bien est-ce que est-ce que tout
va bien est-ce que c'est pas trop fort
est-ce que c'est trop fort allez-y
plaignez vous pour une fois n'hésitez
pas
j'ai failli mettre un petit message
Laurent sur le chat pour dire que je
nous regardais mais bon c'était un petit
peu c'était un petit peu tout match donc
j'ai attendu et
ça y est salut à tous ceux qui arrivent
voilà et bah c'est parti attends tout va
bien enfin moi j'entends
est-ce que vous entendez ou pas est-ce
que je suis seul à entendre ou pas
j'entends rien de spécial mais il y a
peut-être un petit écho Laurent qui
vient de chez toi on entend oui
on entend on entend et sachez que
Laurent va améliorer ça petit à petit ça
va être énorme ça va être énorme ce qui
va nous faire techniquement
parlanter je suis désolé mais je pense
que j'ai je l'entends je suis dans le
call zoom pour vous expliquer
on l'entend et même fort oui on entend
en anglais c'est bon il se tait il se
tait je suis désolé alors c'est une
première pour moi de produire ici et
donc effectivement je suis pas habitué
aux coutumes de la de la famille alors
c'était très bien accueillis dans cette
nouvelle famille mais alors
c'est chaud et là je les ai pas du tout
les gens en vidéo je comprends pas ce
qui se passe mais on n'a pas la vidéo
écoute espérons qu'on est parti
et je me rappelle Laurent que la
dernière fois que j'ai dû être un petit
peu à ta place en tant que host je t'ai
fait deux faux départ avant qu'on
démarre pour s'apercevoir que c'est
quelqu'un d'autre qui est osté donc
c'était assez modeste donc t'inquiète
pas on va pas t'en tenir rigueur Laurent
aujourd'hui donc normalement là je suis
vue visite parce que alors le match
d'aujourd'hui on va le on a la première
partie la première partie qu'on fera
avec Kevin Kevin me lâchera mais la
première partie c'est toujours c'est
toujours tu vois un petit peu en
attendant un petit peu la deuxième
partie mon cher Kevin tu sais commencer
avant oui mais je suis bien désolé mais
j'étais prévenu un tout petit peu tard
par rapport à des engagements et je vais
dire la vérité mais tu le sais mais je
suis invité je suis invité en fait ce
soir je suis invité ce soir et du coup
bah je suis obligé de te lâcher en cours
sinon j'aurais fait comme demain puisque
demain on se retrouve au commentaire et
là je resterai avec toi tout le temps
parce que j'avais pas de de contraintes
tout simplement alors ouais et donc on a
un match entre les Indian yogi's comme
vous le voyez là à droite en bas en bas
de nous Indian yogi's et l'équipe une
équipe brésilienne Brésil capybaraas
avant mon cher Kevin le grand match
l'entrée de du Got champion du monde
Magnus Carlson il rentre ce soir il est
chasses bras face à une équipe
américaine emmenée par naruditski ça va
être un très très gros match
et on a très chaud et on enchaîne alors
moi je me je veux commenter donc je et
j'enchaîne sur PSG Bayern Munich au
commentaire toujours ici
que faire
on fait on fait la soirée voilà
si vous voulez me voir dépité à 23h faut
rester non je plaisante je m'arrête à
Magnus pas sur pas sûr j'espère alors
attends je cherche je cherche notre à
midi parce que là je du coup je le
trouve pas où est-ce qu'on peut voir les
parties explorer les parties ne plus
suivre des filles on va pas le défier tu
sais ça pourrait normalement il y a un
petit truc
normalement si tu me suives c'est pas
mal ouais mais je le suis et alors
comment je fais du coup maintenant
est-ce que la partie va apparaître ou
pas pour moi oui pour moi oui
automatiquement il faut que je fasse un
truc
je dirais que non mais quelqu'un dans le
chat va nous aider je pense la regarder
ce que j'ai et vous voyez les parties
pas de partie en cours donc ok pas de
partie en cours bon mais au moins les
choses sont claires pas de partir en
cours c'est marqué là écoutez on va voir
donc ça commence avec un peu de retard
les premiers jours déjà pour nous ils
sont chauds mais pour tout le monde
l'équipe de Kevin il joue quand alors
l'équipe de Kevin Blist stream il joue
quand il joue la semaine prochaine pas
cette semaine quel est le format à mon
cher mon cher Kevin je joue tu vas tout
nous mettre je sais que tu as préparé ça
sur tes tablettes et voilà on a à
l'écran Aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on a
vous voyez alors faut connaître les les
trucs mais vous voyez les écussons donc
Brésil ensuite Charlotte donc c'est une
évidemment une équipe américaine face
aux chaises bras et emmené par Magnus
Carlson qui a lâché les normes qui
jouent en domaine mon cher à Kévin on va
tu vas veut dire que c'est là d'ailleurs
en haut je suis hyper mal à chier je
suis hyper mal donc on sait pas mais en
tout cas ça sera des super joueurs et on
a en deuxième match deuxième partie de
soirée on a les normes pour lesquelles
j'ai joué à l'époque
avec Magnus qui nous engueulait après
les matchs je peux te dire que ça ça
c'était ça et pourquoi tu as pas joué
qui a été 4h je sentais pas bon fallait
des guerres pires vite fait après le
après le match donc voyez on a tous ces
matchs et l'équipe de de
Blitz Stream qui va jouer la semaine 2
en semaine 2 alors est-ce que la semaine
2 c'est la semaine prochaine ou pas ça
je suis pas le 16 février il joue pas le
jeudi
ah ça c'est blisterie à ta raison pardon
c'est quand même l'écusson que j'ai pu
reconnaître c'est jeudi 16h30 évidemment
moi je serai là je sais pas avec qui je
crois que je serai avec stouf du coup
si c'est pas toi c'est lui donc voilà
apparemment pour cette semaine en tout
cas moi c'est ce qu'il m'a dit hein
c'est ce qu'on m'a dit si c'est pas
Kevin c'est souffle donc voilà c'est
facile donc si tu es pas là c'est c'est
ouf et ça sera ça sera très sympa ça
sera une première et on aurait on
encouragera nos amis français évidemment
avec mvl Étienne macro
Mathieu cornette Libye j'ai vu qu'il y
avait démanté aussi comme il faut il
faut une joueuse donc voilà ils ont ils
ont une joueuse quand même assez assez
solide et les conditions c'est pas de
dépasser 2500 € c'est ça
mauvais deal parce qu'en fait à 2700
enfin bon j'ai pas de 1700 mais tu vois
la moyenne et l'eau fait que en fait il
faut mieux avoir cet un Magnus il ma
2700 donc manus c'est le meilleur deal
sur terre tu vois ouais je comprends
ouais donc voilà on découvrira ça alors
comment ça marche pour les illuminations
et tout ça bon la cadence c'est du 10 +
2 les conclusions d'équipes ne peuvent
pas dépasser une moyenne et l'autre de
2500 tu vois tu tu étais un peu en
avance chaque jour affronte tous les
joueurs de l'équipe adverse totale de 4
ans la première équipe a en penser 8
points et demi remporte le match en cas
d'égalité des partages détermine équipe
gagnante est-ce qu'on aura des
départages ou pas en 3 plus 2 si à 8
partout peut-être peut-être pas on sait
pas mon cher Kévin
les prix
l'équipe gagnant bascule d'un division 1
à l'affrontera une autre équipe bref on
en est pas encore là dotation totale de
la PCL 2023 150 000 dollars et bien ma
foi
ça permet de prendre des vacances en
Bretagne ça
tu sais la Bretagne ça devient de plus
en plus cher Laurent on va pas se mentir
ça dépend où ça dépend où hein j'ai pas
dit à acheter j'ai pas acheté j'ai pas
dit acheter une maison à Saint-Malo tu
vois moi
c'est le mignon qu'il faut hein c'est
c'est le titre de champion du monde il y
a que Magnus qui peut enfin qui pouvait
maintenant il va avoir de plus en plus
de mal à acheter en Bretagne
est-ce que c'est moi est-ce que est-ce
que là je comprends pas pourquoi j'ai
pas de partie très honnêtement donc
n'hésitez pas à me à me dire est-ce que
quelqu'un nous a aidé dans le chat ou
pas
à suivre le joueur non pourtant sinon je
vais aller là ce que m'a dit
alors regardez je crois que c'est ça
regardez près de Chelsea 2023
est parti
j'ai pas de partie alors
je vais aller tu sais quoi je vais aller
dans mon sac ce que je fais aussi
d'habitude dans
je peux demander si tu veux
freiner ce commentaire
ouais vas-y demande s'il te plaît star
delights OK
qu'est-ce qu'il a ah oui parce que en
fait ils étaient ah d'accord ok c'est
génial parce que je suis rentré dans le
truc je suis rentré donc petit anecdote
qui arrive dans les dans les trucs et
donc il dit en gros j'ai pas vu les
messages il a dit ah lui ta caméra
maintenant tu vois en mode bon on te
fait les poches on sait pas si tu joues
en fait on fait pas les poches c'est que
en gros ce qui se passe c'est qu'il y a
un contrôle anti triche bien évidemment
donc les parties sont légèrement
décalées je crois qu'il y a 30 secondes
quelque chose comme ça et évidemment il
y a trois caméras chez joueurs mais il
pensait que je jouais du coup tu vois ça
on sait pas habitué ça me fait plaisir
Kevin on prend toujours pour un joueur
alors je préfère regarder
on peut le dire c'est un peu
retraités
la semaine dernière et ça marche bien et
ben écoute c'est bizarrement j'avais pas
gagné une partie de matin depuis 7 ans 8
ans je suis pas neuf ans peut-être 10
ans et là j'ai gagné je sais pas il a
pas tenu tu sais il y a la règle
normalement en général alors je
t'explique comment ça marche à vous
aussi il y a une règle tu as pas le
droit de proposer nul et 20 premiers
coups donc en général si le mec s'en
tire bien les 20 premiers coups tu vois
ce que je veux dire et là il est très
bien et là il a pas il a pas tenu tout
seul bon ils ont Maël et le fils Bacro
en bas et le ouais et Maxime la garde
évidemment on les suivra et puis on les
encouragera évidemment
je sais pas en fait j'ai essayé de
chercher
qui est là pour t'aider tu vois et il
est arrivé j'avais envoyé un petit
message à Nathan mais je pense que c'est
logique du haut délai pour l'instant si
à rien tu peux pas suivre s'il y a rien
alors ouais je vois pas voyez les
parties ah oui quoi c'était une c'était
une erreur oh là là oui quoi partie proc
knockout non je l'ai pas ok
Laurent elles sont pas encore je vois
pas je vois pas dans le col on est cinq
dans le col
je comprends pas
c'est ça un petit peu c'est le premier
jour donc c'est un petit peu balbutiant
c'est normal et ça va se ça va se
réguler petit à petit
je comprends rien
je sais pas comment il faut faire je
n'ai aucune idée je n'ai je n'ai pas la
rêve de ce call zoom ou en fait il y a
plusieurs salles je sais pas où
[Musique]
ok tu vois vous avez entendu donc voilà
là il commence les parties normalement
alors je vais essayer de rejoindre ça
est-ce que j'ai le droit de rejoindre je
pense pas que j'ai le droit de rejoindre
attends je vais essayer de rejoindre
alors
je vais peut-être me faire me faire
taper sur les doigts la demande est en
cours pour
suivre les joueurs ah alors attends
attends attends attends on peut avoir ça
ou là je pense que c'est pas mal
ouh là je tends je sens que je t'ai un
truc
mais comment il faut que j'ai deux cols
je sais pas
[Musique]
je crois que je vais laisser tomber la
afficher participant permettait la vidéo
et l'écran partagé ouais c'est ça non
non c'est pas bon je sais plus comment
on fait ce truc et ouais mais ils font
pas de training franchement c'est pas
cool
c'est vrai ils font pas de training je
vois bien et non et voilà on aura pas la
vidéo pour aujourd'hui je suis vraiment
désolé mais c'est mort là en vrai
c'est mort parce que je sais pas du tout
alors je peux vous mettre
en fait grâce à ça tu vas monter en
compétence beaucoup plus rapidement
ouais mais là là en fait je peux pas le
faire en vrai je peux pas je sais pas
comment il faut faire si en plus je
savais mais il y a pas eu de training ça
fait ça fait une éternité j'ai pas fait
ça parce que moi tu sais à chass24 comme
je suis comme je suis paresseux ce qui
s'est passé c'est que en fait on a
engagé un producteur du coup j'ai dit
bien sûr j'ai dit c'est vachement
important c'est vital faut absolument
faire quelque chose et du coup voilà du
coup
qui est sympa qui t'a mis le lien
directement dans la partie entre visite
et boule Maga je l'ai voilà
c'est beau et alors attends et c'est
parfait non c'est mal cadré mais
on est on est quand même pas mal on
pourrait être mieux que ça ah ouais
parce qu'il y a des trucs à droite donc
attends je vais enlever le les variantes
et les commentaires et on a les coûts et
du coup je vais recadrer tout ça vous
m'en voulez pas est-ce qu'on met les
coups ou pas est-ce que tu mets les
coups toi
sur le
est-ce que tu mets les qui ont été joués
non non non non non non non non non on
est pas bien là franchement et non ce
qu'on aime bien c'est commenter on a
monté sans le module ouais il manque
plus que des petites cas mais ça va
venir l'orange chaud que tu as fait le
plus dur aujourd'hui aucune chance
non franchement là alors c'est boule
Maga avec les Blancs la joueuse roumaine
que tu dois connaître exactement
où là alors là il y a eu
il y a un truc voilà donc
on a un 4 je te laisse je te laisse nous
dire ce qui se passe alors on a eu 4 D6
malheureusement pour rien arranger si tu
veux je suis en léger décalage parce que
je suis obligé de suivre
sur le site chascom parce que ton
partage d'écran pour l'instant il a
Laurent d'accord encore une nouvelle de
plus tu vois c'est génial et tour géant
G6 et tour géant qui est un coup très
très agressif
clairement une joueuse d'attaque
G6 ok G4 prendre des cartes et prendre
des quatre fougères sept fois et là on a
une sorte de dragon avec le pion le pion
c'est à la place du Pione bon c'est un
peu un hybride mais en général ce genre
de choses c'est quand même très très bon
pour les je sais pas ce que tu en penses
Kevin mais je pense que
ça a l'air quand même très très bien
pour les blancs ah oui c'est très très
agréable on a envie de tout balancer
après vidite il veut absolument gagner
avec avec les Noirs bon vous voyez qu'il
y a un niveau d'écart conséquent boule
Maga à peu près mon niveau c'est-à-dire
proche 24 50 et vite si il est 27 50
donc il veut gagner avec les Noirs
évidemment pour pour sa team donc il va
prendre un max de risques des de
l'ouverture après il est peut-être pas
obligé d'en prendre autant bon après il
doit se sentir en maîtrise ça reste du
10 10 + 2 donc bon
cadence vous voyez le joue à fond la
caisse et ça peut quand même suffire au
rang ouais tout à fait tout à fait
ouais ouais non effectivement mais bon
c'est quand même pas terrible j'ai gardé
les Vals du coup sur le sur l'échiquier
mais je vais essayer de
tu vois quand même qu'on a une idée
[Musique]
assez comme on n'a pas les joueurs pour
l'instant je laisse comme ça mais c'est
vrai que c'est pas comme ça non plus
hier mais bon ok
et vous voyez donc vous avez à droite à
droite de chéquier les résultats qui
vont venir alors effectivement
maintenant c'est pas très intéressant
parce que c'est du 0-0 mais après ça
sera pas mal pour s'y retrouver et voir
si les joueurs doivent prendre des
risques qu'on va peut-être présenter les
joueurs
Kevin donc on a vite contre Irina
boulmaga donc on voit c'est un 4 donc
des parties les plus déséquilibrées
possibles au départ ensuite on a aravine
contre Alexander fear ça c'est une belle
partie a priori mes deux choix aura plus
de 26 je sais pas si en ce moment fier
il a plus de 26 mais normalement on l'a
connu à 26 50 à son max
ensuite Abdullah gadim Baili alors là je
suis vraiment désolé mais je connais pas
moi non plus
Alors c'est lequel de Martinez c'est pas
sûr c'est pas sûr j'en sais rien
oui ça doit être ça T'choupi on l'a vu
le joueur on a vu sous pied va et
Charlie au tata style donc toupie c'est
un joueur à plus de 2006 et weishai
voilà c'est ça tout à fait contre choupi
je vais voir si j'arrive à voir les
autres
parties alors attendez ah oui d'accord
on va aller voir on va aller voir
arabine par exemple c'est une belle
partie est-ce que je peux voilà regarder
et c'est vrai que ça marche
c'est vrai que ça marche ou pas ou pas
ça ne marche pas
ça ne marche pas quand je fais regarder
c'est bizarre non tu en penses quoi
ça devrait d'accord
bon et là si je fais des filles non elle
joue pas
si en plus ce site marche pas bon tu
sais quoi on va rester chez justice
ça doit être juste ils ont juste la
moyenne je pense à 2500
ou alors en général on essaie
d'optimiser évidemment et d'arriver à
quasi de 1500
ça c'est une évidence
certaines choses et Martinez qui fait je
le connais pas faudrait garder
refresh le site envoyer en dessous
d'accord
c'est notre chef technique du jour
surtout ne part pas en embryon sinon on
est mal ok
c'est quand même c'est quand même le
mieux on va regarder notamment peut-être
cette partie qui a l'air qui a l'air
sympa entre entre filles en tout cas
entre fear et aravines donc vous les
voyez là bon ben j'enlève les filles
allez les blancs contrat ravine et
avec les Blancs vraisemblablement
parce qu'on voyait que le centre était
fermé sur la position finale et qui se
commençait à se prendre une charge sur
son roi
on dit
attaque à l'aide réaction au centre et
regarder la position finale que Laurent
va nous montrer mais ouais c'est vrai le
centre est fermé tu as tout à fait
raison on voit
on a un abri assez safe avec le roi
finalement pour faire grand rock en plus
donc
salut salut
qui
me suit dans cette aventure ensuite
depuis le départ on est là
résiste
a lancé aussi une chaîne Youtube que je
vous invite à aller voir qui est qui est
super sympa il y avait un gros gros
boulot de fait au moment au moment de la
triche avait passé des heures à tout
éplucher et du coup avait fait des
vidéos qui avaient à la fois très bien
marché je peux vous dire que moi je les
avais regardé avec avec grand plaisir
c'était vraiment bien bien monté tout
simplement
normalement je croyais qu'on n'avait pas
lost moi je suis juste le guest donc je
suis pas censé être au courant ouais
mais Kevin moi je pense que tu devrais
pas t'aventurer vu comment tu parles
anglais je pense que dans la dans la
convocation et le big boss je devrais
m'en sortir mieux quoi je devrais je
devrais m'en sortir mieux que toi tu
vois mais sans vouloir être
désobligeants mais bon moi de toute
façon je dirais que je comprends que
dalle du coup je serai obligé de refiler
le bébé à nos responsables fr donc
ouais donc la rumeur dit que je
commencerai sur twitch lundi prochain et
bien bon lancement en tout cas
Jean-Michel pigeon
c'est mignon Jean-Michel bien joué bien
Jean-Michel Jean-Michel enfin des
Jean-Michel moi je suis très fan des
Jean-Michel
Jean-Michel Jean-Michel à peu près c'est
mon préféré voilà
il rigole pas ravine
le prodige est-ce que je tente une vous
savez quoi à la pause je tenterai de de
choper les caméras mais là bien sûr bien
sûr c'est ce qu'il faut faire c'est ce
qu'il faut faire en faire on fait un
petit lancement et après tu envoies du
lourd
mais du coup vous avez vu ce G4 en tout
cas ouais alors vas-y et il donne le
pion quand même mine de rien c'est un
pion bon on s'en fout on donne les pions
dans ces positions là donc opposées pour
ouvrir les lignes donc la tour D8 va
passer en G8 il faut pas avoir peur faut
pas avoir
tu fais comme ça genre en mode je double
ici
tu vois
je joue encore souvent des bonnes idées
tu as souvent des bonnes idées en
technique tes moyens mais enfin pas
échiquen qu'on s'entend bien je me
permettrai pas mais en technique Obs
j'ai déjà vu des gens qui expliquent
mieux j'ai déjà vu des gens qui
expliquent
pas d'accord bon ben déjà de voir les
progrès de demain mais en tout cas pour
G8 c'est c'est le coup logique pourquoi
c'est pas ça
a été joué tour chez huit je j'aurais
bien les yeux fermés pour G8 5 27 contre
6,16 comme tu l'as dit hein c'est quand
même alors c'est pas du Blitz c'est pas
du rapide non plus c'est une tendance
hybride que tu conserves
écoute
tu penses
il faut jouer les coups à la main il
faut vraiment
alors je me fais avoir des fois je joue
en 10 + 0 pour faire des parties
pédagogiques en commentant et tout ça et
honnêtement je trouve que c'est hyper
dur 10 + 2 c'est un peu mieux mais
franchement c'est des cadences
véritablement dangereuses dès qu'on
prend deux fois deux minutes on se
retrouve déjà il y a eu quelques coups
de jouets on peut l'imaginer on se
retrouve déjà sous la zone des trois
minutes et après petit à petit ben ça
dégringole après c'est la zone
dangereuse
tout à fait
c'est vraiment du Blitz je vais m'en
jouer un leur truc là alors leur truc
alors super tournoi pardon de tu sais ce
champion de chastour là le play in tu
sais pour essayer de se qualifier c'est
du 10 + 2 on peut pas trop flaguer quoi
que parfois il y a des gens qui sont
vraiment pas doués avec la souris donc
même avec deux secondes ils peuvent
perdre autant je je pense à faire partie
mais tu vois le fait que la cadence il y
a un incrément ça me ça me chauffe un
petit peu puis je me suis je me dis
pourquoi pas on n'a pas grand chose à
perdre au pire au pire je fais un rage
quitte au bout de quatre parties énervé
tu vois mais mais c'est vraiment c'est
le pire
normalement il y a moyen il y a moyen
dans ces cadence là de faire des parties
correctes en tout cas on le voit là la
partie elle est bien bien amenée elle
est assez pédagogique en plus pour la
gestion des rock opposés
bon maintenant on voit là gros avantage
noir mais il faut confirmer un Laurent
parce que sinon c'est le pion de moins
sur le long terme donc il va falloir
entamer quelque chose alors comment tu
continues ici alors
c'est vrai tu as complètement raison et
fire très rapide fire il est bon même en
partie classique il joue très vite alors
elle est horrible ouais ouais il est
très très bizarre en fait très très dur
à cerner quoi il met une pression en
fait ça met une pression dingue ces
joueurs qui jouent vite donc pas mal
comme on dit ouais il joue en confiance
alors le calcul est parfois approximatif
ça peut pas avoir côté que que des
avantages de faire comme ça mais
effectivement ça met quand même une
sacrée pression fouger 5 j'aime pas mal
alors ça échange une pièce mais c'est
vrai que si on échange on prend et après
on va menacer tout à 5 c'est hyper malin
et hyper malin j'aime bien ce coup-là du
jeune de l'ancien jaune prodige à ravine
est-ce qu'il sait est-ce qu'il se passe
quelque chose dans les autres parties
écouter je crois que pour l'instant on
n'a pas de pas de résultats on reste sur
celle-là elle est pas mal hein qu'est-ce
que tu en penses ouais ouais c'est cool
c'est cool c'est hyper intéressant ça
montre tout de la construction des rock
opposés et se Fuger 5 normalement vous
avez vu un doigt pas échanger et
finalement on échange un très bon
défenseur de la position blanche et du
coup derrière en plus on active notre
tour voilà et là il y a beaucoup plus de
menaces je disais une bêtise mon cher
Kevin vite a déjà gagné avec les Noirs
contre bullmaga on verra la pause on
sait pas comment il y a de pause
exactement mais on verra peut-être à la
petite pause comment on fait mais voilà
bravo bon un point attendu 2730 visite
face à aboulmaga qui a 2428 bon ça fait
ça ça fait lourd et vite j'ai joué j'ai
joué un match de Blitz contre lui au MR
de jeans Vita national l'année dernière
ça joue ça va ça joue bien c'est préparé
c'est sérieux ça m'avait pas laissé de
chance donc tous les gros tournois mais
bon tu as vu tout à l'heure pas sur
modeste il a quand même gagné très très
facilement parce que c'était une
ouverture modeste très déséquilibrée et
du coup dans les complications
il a été beaucoup plus fort alors F4
tentative
sans doute d'extraire le roi faire Wave
2 cavalier F3 trouver une construction
qui permet de tenir dans la position
et du coup bah surtout à chaque je suis
obligé de faire cavalier fin sinon j'ai
perdu c'est ça c'est exactement ça
perdu tu as perdu oui tu as tout perdu
cavalier
on va le montrer si on fait le coup
naturel qui avait l'air F3 le coup qu'on
a envie de faire on perd la dame tout de
suite on reprend on reprend terminer
c'est la fin des haricots donc ce qu'on
fait c'est qu'après
après F4 qui a été joué
parce que ça va tout ouvrir et on perd
en plus un pion
on récupère les noirs on a une
initiative complètement gratuite tout à
fait
donc il va faire tout rage 5 quasi
certainement Arabie même si il prend un
peu de temps ok c'est bizarre parce que
il y a pas vraiment candidat cavalier F1
alors comment on continue on ramène la
dame
là faut pas se tromper échec d'abord
c'est jouer OK
et maintenant
G3
voilà ça ouvrirait la possibilité de
faire tour 8 tâches 2 peut-être encore
que même pas sûr
la deuxième c'était dangereux
il est pas traumatisé par des mots
expositions
on ramène du monde à la fête c'est ça
exactement on ramène toutes les pièces
pour attaquer maintenant c'est vous
voyez toutes les pièces sont à l'attaque
avec cette dame qui arrivait là le
cavalier les deux tours
c'est l'enfer c'est l'enfer il se presse
pas tant que ça parce que c'est
difficile de trouver les coûts Laurent
avec les Blancs on vient de voir tour 3
E1 c'est pas des coûts naturels on sait
pas trop comment jouer ce genre de
position c'est là qu'on voit d'ailleurs
que certains forts peuvent être un peu
faibles parce que des mousselé par la
position
tout à fait très dur à jouer par rapport
ouais c'est ce qu'on dit c'est le dicton
dans les mauvaises positions il y a pas
de bons coups tu vois alors il y a des
coûts comme à la icarudakamura si tu
veux qui qui retarde l'échéance et à
force de retarder l'échéance mais la
plupart du temps il sauve sa partie
tellement tellement il est fort mais
c'est vrai que c'est une qualité très
rare c'est chez les même chez les très
fort grand maître c'est cette qualité de
pouvoir jouer bien dans des mauvaises
positions ça c'est
résister poser des problèmes mais c'est
extrêmement Nakamura il y en a pas tant
que ça dans le monde des mecs comme lui
alors on va voir ce qui fait on prendra
vos questions évidemment il y aura des
pauses tout le monde donc voilà grand
perso
si en plus il doit commencer à modérer
le chat on voit bien rigoler
laissez-le tranquille pour l'instant
pour l'instant je peux ban sur Chess.com
c'est un début tu vois pas encore sur le
twitch pas encore sur le twitch mais je
crois que je crois que je peux ban sur
le chaise.com
je crois qu'il va me permettre tu dis ça
mais tu crois donc ne vous inquiétez pas
trop ils m'ont dit que c'était un compte
c'est un compte admin je crois donc
après tu peux faire pas mal de choses ah
bah j'imagine mais il faut après il faut
savoir le faire quoi
normalement il y a tu sais il y a un
petit rond et un petit essor interdit
sur le type tu cliques bon d'accord
maintenant non non je suis pas admin
mais
du coup
tu crois pas moi
mais si si mais déjà j'ai de voir les
cames à la prochaine ronde déjà step by
step comme ils disent mais moi je pige
rien à leur truc honnêtement parce que
il y a deux salles de discussion comment
je peux pas être dans les deux bon mais
bref on va gérer ça t'inquiète
t'inquiète inquiète toi mais peut-être
ça sera résolu bon filière par contre il
faut qu'il s'inquiète 3 0,6 contre une
30 c'est sa seule chance affirmer
contrat ravine ces jeunes gens y jouent
vite ils jouent bien on attaque G3 oh il
est complètement fraise le pauvre
Alexander très sympa et très très archi
dominé très connu du circuit français
très présent sur les j'ai joué plein de
fois moi comme lui notamment en rapide
en rapide il est très dangereux mais là
il prend l'eau elle a fait une mauvaise
partie dès le début il s'est fait
enfoncer dès l'ouverture avec ce G5 là
très inspiré d'aravint avec le centre
fermé grosse attaque et on voit que
depuis il subit mais alors comment on
fait maintenant on aimerait bien faire
cage ça marche pas et puis on prend tout
reprend et tout reprendre donc ça va pas
m'aider qu'à toi hyper logique des
quatre on fait ces quatre normalement au
courant parce que on a envie de fermer
le jeu évidemment s'il y a pas de
problème
tour H1 cavalier 3 qui pourra arriver
quelque chose comme ça
tu as complètement raison mon cher Kevin
non mais c'est juste terminé je peux
même filer des pions peut-être un moment
ou un autre et essayer de faire cailler
des quatre et de m'infiltrer et voilà on
fuit
on fuit courageusement non
pour trouver les bons pas mal quand même
ouais donc tout a changé
en dessous de la minute à ravine
attention il faut finir c'est pas facile
de finir ce genre de position non
surtout que ça fait un petit moment qui
tourne et qui a de 30 pour fuir la vraie
avantage ce avantage au temps
attention c'est pas facile il y a pas de
cou qui gagne encore
on a la séquence tout reprend F1
cavalier 3 mais bon est-ce que c'est sa
solutionne je crois pas ça fait des
échanges on va on va essayer de faire
mieux que ça
pourrait arriver
au 3 a l'air a l'air pas mal attention à
ravine 20 20 secondes 20 secondes
cavalier 3 est-ce que ça marche ou pas
j'en sais rien car elle est propre c'est
pas surtout D8 et la jauge qui n'aime
pas du tout qui remonter quasiment égal
tu te rends compte Kevin
c'est assez logique parce qu'on n'arrive
pas à percer pour l'instant est-ce qu'on
peut jouer tourage 2 avec les Blancs
pour essayer de commencer à éliminer du
matériel ouais peut-être peut-être tour
H2 pour éliminer un attaquant évidemment
que tu auras 2 c'est un coup un coup
intéressant au minimum
ah ça il y a peut-être tout reprendre et
cavalier 3 donc c'est toujours dangereux
cette case de 3 j'aimerais bien
solutionner cela
peut-être
moins prise des quatre inspirée
prise des cartes c'est pas mal aussi
prise
quoi
ouais mais j'ai changé
évidemment regardez dames on menace la
tour si j'ai quatre tu rat damage 4
échecs donc tout va bien pour les pour
les Noirs là c'est très très dur à jouer
pour les blancs un mine de rien il a
plus de temps au pire il y a une 40
contre 12 secondes attention à ravine
c'est pas bon de se laisser avec si peu
de temps mais on va voir est-ce qu'il
est peut-être après on sait jamais que
ces jeunes Indiens ça se trouve il fait
des blistes toute la journée sur
c'est une terreur avec avec deux
secondes l'intérieur du Bullet ça serait
pas sur elle mais non c'est malin parce
que cette position elle est casse gueule
vous voyez évidemment qu'on préfère
jouer avec les Noirs mais faut trouver
là il a été obligé d'échanger un peu de
matos et faire le petit thème avec un
value E3 que je proposais tout à l'heure
dans une autre position
déjà pour commencer cette partie il
avait un peu moins le choix on va dire
la bétonation il a dégoupillé
complètement B3 c'est quand même un coup
de l'espace je trouve dans une position
il suffit de pousser les pions de la roi
il a affaibli son eldam et maintenant il
cherche une solution et ça le c'est un
inconvénient d'être stratégiquement
douteux et techniquement très mauvais
donc si tu veux c'est quand même assez
mauvais signe pour les sud de la partie
si vous voyez ce que je veux dire donc
fini fini et ben on a ce qui est bien
c'est qu'on a les résultats en temps
réel donc moi je pronostique une
victoire de aravint ouais alors il y a
alors pourquoi pourquoi on a les il y a
un petit décalage pourquoi il y a un
petit décalage parce que il y a ce truc
anti-triche de 30 secondes 20 secondes
donc on rate pas de on rate pas vous
allez voir abandonner
vous allez le voir abandonner notre ami
notre ami fear normalement c'est vrai
que c'est embêtant si on a le résultat
avant
écoute mais ça c'est pas de ma faute
c'est pas moi qui est
Robinson il dit tu faisais moins fier
Kevin quand c'était sur la technique au
tata style mais complètement mais je
m'en suis jamais caché robinside mais là
je jure aujourd'hui c'est assez je
m'appelle pas Anne Sliman moi donc voilà
Dame des cinq échecs et abandons abandon
de fille victoire victoire et on va
regarder la dernière partie en jeu il y
a un très très bon début pour nos amis
indiens oh là là et regarde la sœur de
Prague qu'est-ce qu'elle est en train de
faire à choupi T'choupi le sport la sœur
de Prague elle est en train elle a les
blancs donc et ça pourrait être trois et
demi zéro et demi pour nos amis indiens
alors attends il y a quand même un petit
problème sur le cavalier peut-être tout
simplement et tu reprends
dans ma tête ça marchait presque en plus
avec des six pas clair mais bon tu es
pas avec tes copains bretons à l'apéro
là tu peux pas jouer de quoi
je vais le voir
bon c'est ça c'est le coup je voulais
jouer c'est cette c'est le coup semble
blaguer mais il y a peut-être tout à 8
et c'est là que j'ai eu l'idée tout
recettes ouais et là tout recettes de
faire le malin comme ça
moi je te fais ça moi tu sais ce que je
te fais moi je te moi je te l'ai fait je
te fais tout en finesse le truc tu vois
je te dis tu poses tout dépend en
revanche en fait merci
ouais et je crois que tu sais quoi elle
a elle a pas besoin qu'on lui donne le
plan non plus notre ami Ray Charles je
crois qu'elle va le trouver elle est
elle est éminemment talentueuse cette
joueuse indienne eh c'est une famille
beaucoup beaucoup d'indiens très jeunes
très talentueux présenté parce que bon
faut le dire hein il y a les deux hein
il y a le talent mais sans entraînement
bah ça stagne et il bosse il bosse comme
des malades ouais c'est ça avec des des
entraîneurs maintenant qui commence à
ramènes qui est très connu mais d'autres
aussi d'autres entrées indiens qui
commencent à être reconnus maintenant
partout dans le monde qui sont invités
un petit peu partout donc voilà c'est
c'est l'école indienne qui est en train
de faire et vu bah vu le nombre qui sont
pas comment veux-tu qu'on fasse tu vois
c'est au bout d'un moment
les règles sont pas tout à fait les
mêmes c'est à dire que bon tous les
jeunes Français quasiment vont à l'école
et finissent par arrêter quand ils sont
soit au lycée soit en étude sup mais en
Inde c'est un peu différent le fait de
se faire joueur pro ça existe en France
ça existe vraiment quand on est ultra
doué sur le tard mais c'est quand même
un petit peu plus dur c'est moins c'est
moins dans les mœurs pour l'instant ah
oui pardon alors j'ai il y a eu des
coups tout à fait
Kevin
écoute
à chaque fois tu me régales en étant en
train de discuter je pensais qu'il se
passait rien et moi aussi je pensais
qu'il se passe rien alors
on est gagnant on est gagnant ne vous
inquiétez pas c'est le premier jour vous
savez comment c'est premier jour c'est
première partie ensuite on a le champion
du monde qui arrive Magnus Carson Kevin
s'en va vous voyez tout bien sérieux
à partir du deuxième match tour de
sérieux lors d'un fait la première
partie avec le type pas drôle voilà je
venais juste un petit peu en support
pour aider parce que je sais qu'il avait
falloir broder parce que technique ça
l'est un petit peu dur mais bon voilà
maintenant tout est OK et on va balancer
à je refais un petit fou à 6 mais bon
aussi c'est quoi tu as trois pions de
plus tant que tu perds pas autant cette
partie on peut on va la gagner quand
même facile et ça c'est un gros coup dur
parce que soupir choupi il a 2608
vaicherie à la 2433 s'il commence à
perdre des voilà et elle a gagné
d'ailleurs on le voit cette petite
équipe indienne quand même avec
la jeune vice shiny au dernier c'est pas
c'est pas mal quoi tu serais pas
influencé par le résultat un petit peu
et elle a gagné en plus non mais quand
je quand je vois un petit peu si tu veux
visite au premier cette jeune fille
qui est 24/50 mais sans doute qu'elle
sera beaucoup plus pour les 24 bon bref
proche 24-50
elle doit jouer vite tu vois le côté
tout ce qu'il faut à 24 50 c'est un
super échiquier visiter on sait qu'il
est ultra fort et à ravine et son pote
Abdullah que je connais pas Abdullah
mais aravint il va être à l'aise il a il
a quand même fait une belle partie
contre
C8 on sait qu'elle a gagné on a un petit
spoiler ça je sais pas comment faire
pour le coup faut que je décale le score
shift
tu pourrais nous construire un petit
bandeau bleu
un petit bandeau bleu ouais bah oui
je dis bonjour à Magnus en même temps ça
va exactement
Laurent
je sais pas comment il faut faire
je ne sais pas quand il faut faire un
fichier
en tout cas propre à Raclet là pour
ce que ça va
[Applaudissements]
il y a deux parties qui ont coincé dans
une minute donc je sais pas comment je
vais essayer d'aller les récupérer les
joueurs et mais alors vous voyez
regarde-moi ça tu vas est-ce que tu veux
être impressionné mon chien hop en
direct vite allez hop
c'est bien j'aime bien cette technique
c'est aussi la mienne Laurent
sur le papier il faut faire comme ça
il va jouer contre qui visite
on va essayer de parler enlever le temps
donc ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va
dupliquer ça
non je fais ça en direct pour vous mais
c'est super c'est bien ça montre à tout
le monde un petit peu comment ça marche
les deux sous du stream ouais surtout
que franchement honnêtement j'en ai
quand même voilà voilà
et après j'irai chercher sur
l'adversaire et du coup je vais décaler
chez
bravo Laurent direct facile ah bah ouais
ça c'est c'est du c'est le métier non
c'est pas terrible mais du coup j'ai pas
les comment je fais là parce que du coup
soit j'ai les joueurs tu vois soit j'ai
les je vais mettre en plus petit du coup
est-ce que visite elle est blanc ou les
Noirs est-ce que tu pourrais me trouver
ça à priori il aura les blancs dans
celle-là je vais mettre un petit
je vais servir à quelque chose pour une
fois
je pense qu'il a les il a les blancs
je vais dire ça je vais aller dans le
dérouler on va suivre la partie de
visite et on va voir contre qui va jouer
et puis il y a peu de pause dans ces
cas-là est-ce qu'on préfère le voir de
face ou de comme ça vite
préfère avoir de face on sait pas ouais
de face mais pas tout ça est-ce qu'il
est blanc ou pas oui j'ai tout ça
commence quand
je pense que
c'est pas à l'avance il y a pas
forcément en tout cas les appareils
non pour l'instant ils sont pas sortis
c'est nickel mais il y a pas marqué
tu veux est-ce que tu veux dire qu'il
est blanc
on dit ça
allez on dit qu'il a les blancs
de côté c'était pas mal on peut voir
leur technique de souris
bien jouer nos scènes
du monde en terme technique alors en
tout cas tu es très bonne volonté et
c'est déjà beaucoup je donne tout parce
que en fait ça me challenge à fond bon
je pense que les gens ont compris et en
fait j'ai fait j'ai tellement dû j'ai
tellement en galéré à me débrouiller
tout seul et tout ça finalement j'ai
pris goût tu vois il y a un peu le côté
le défi ouais le défi tu vois c'est ça
on est joueur
donc comment il s'appelle l'équipe en
face
ah ouais mais alors du coup OK
est-ce qu'on voit
on va essayer de voir la partie là non
je crois est-ce que les parties ont
commencé ou pas est-ce que quelqu'un
peut nous dire
comment il s'appelle nos amis il
s'appelle les c'est quoi les nombres de
l'équipe adverse non tu l'as le nom
d'équipe adverse s'il te plaît j'ai
perdu j'ai tout départ
je vais te trouver ça sans aucun souci
Brazil
c'est
confidentiels
en tout cas
je pouvais pas savoir d'habitude je
planifie tout tu vois quand je suis os
maintenant je ferai je ferai mes petites
fenêtre avant Laurent d'accord donc
c'est
on va mettre que Brasil c'est bien ouais
c'est bien
B a R a S
j'ai galéré mais j'ai fini par trouver
merci alors visite il a l'air de
quelqu'un qui joue là je sais pas ce que
vous en pensez alors est-ce qu'il y a
pas un petit délai aussi c'est ça
c'est la question c'est possible qu'on a
un petit délai
merde de jouer le gars
et il joue contre qui là
il va jouer contre le numéro 3 l'autre
équipe à mon avis
il joue
il va jouer il joue fier on a on a on
l'a sur le truc ah super on a une partie
vide fire donc tu m'as absolument servir
à rien mon cher ronde 2 c'est pas marqué
non plus ça si si
je tiens à dire que tu étais loin
d'imaginer ce petit nom sympa on a
visite fear ça va être sympa et donc on
va aller chercher notre ami fear
j'ai fait n'importe quoi
je peux pas aller chercher fille en fait
on va
non mais en vrai il faut que j'aille
dans l'autre truc je comprends pas
comment ça marche une fois que il
m'explique je sais pas bon ça me
permettra d'avoir une excuse pour
prendre que Magnus au prochain si tu
nous écoutes mon cher
mon cher
voilà j'ai décalé le truc
en tout cas vous voyez c'est quasiment
bon
elle ressemble à visite non
tu en penses quoi moyen de loin dans le
brouillard épais breton
oh là là
mais les parties on est ah ça y est les
parties arrivent tu as vu en temps réel
ça
voilà on va avoir visite je le mets vite
et puis j'abandonne pour les caméras on
va laisser tomber parce que ça va pas ça
va pas je sais pas comment il faut faire
faut qu'on respire là on a déjà on a
déjà comment on dirait je
si ça continue comme ça on va être hyper
bien alors c'est pas mal
d'accord on a écoute est-ce qu'on a des
coups
on va en faire
moi je suis je suis la position de
départ mais moi aussi
visite il a peur de faire position de
départ mais
il a l'air
d'être mort il est méga focus avant la
partie c'est toi tu te focus avoir les
parties non c'est toi ça non
ça dépend non en plus pas trop une
Anglaise ouais c'est ça c'est parti bon
c'est cool
non ça dépend vraiment ok si c'est
quelque chose d'important tu sais ça
dépend un petit peu de la logistique
maintenant quand tu es par exemple en
partie d'équipe est-ce que tu arrives un
peu avant tu arrives bien tout ça mais
ouais pas plus que ça après quand tu
joues en équipe j'estime c'est normal de
faire les efforts d'accord
mais focus avant la partie non c'est ça
serait exagéré de dire que je suis hyper
focus
alors ah mais j'ai fait n'importe quoi
encore je suis désolé je fais n'importe
quoi mais alors c'était beau de faire
n'importe quoi à ce point-là OK
peut-être il faut que je mette le truc
là-bas ok j'ai compris
mais du coup je peux plus te voir et je
sais j'ai deux écrans mais je suis en
méga galère qui a été trois C6 E4 mon
cher Kévin ok comment ça marche
c'est ça ah c'est E6
et voilà énormément de théorie c'est si
c'est plus rare et c'est vrai que ça
laisse ça laisse 4 qui est joué
évidemment par visite qui a un excellent
Théo ici c'est pas neuf peut-être à
prévoir maintenant je peux pas parce
qu'il y a E5
bon ok
D5 s'intéressant pour voir
des cas tu veux dire
c'est pour ça
le fier j'ai l'impression qu'il est en
freestyle je te raconte pas à mon avis
c'est une mauvaise version c'est la
version du pauvre de Mickey le cavalier
là
tu as pas joué aussi donc il va faire 3
à mon avis notre ami vidite qui est un
expert des ouvertures donc il va
comprendre les différences quoi que peut
prendre ces trois points F6 c'est
marrant quand même il faut des si ça
ressemble à la carrocane qui est à la
mode oui bien sûr ça a pas l'air si
clair ouais effectivement et il joue des
Français 3 et qu'est-ce que je vous dis
ce que je dis mais ok
OK
est-ce que
tu as l'air tu avais réussi à
réactualiser le partage où il s'était
réactualisé tout seul
je ne sais pas un des deux donc ok c'est
tu me fais une blague en fait pour
embrouiller non non c'est à dire que
tout à l'heure tu sais je t'en ai parlé
et puis le par mon partage est revenu
enfin en tout cas je voyais les comptes
en réel sinon je peux suivre
ça ça va être pas mal il y a une page
qui est très très bien j'oserais pas te
faire de blague ouais ça serait des
blagues quand tu seras vraiment vraiment
hyper à l'aise mais j'aimerais pas les
moments je peux est-ce que est-ce que le
partage est bien là magnifique
magnifique tu vois la partie on se voit
dans la fenêtre en haut c'est marrant
parce que qu'est-ce qui est marrant
c'est au top du coup il dit que ça c'est
le meilleur version avec les Blancs
parce que
moderne avec cavalier F6 et en double
les pions on a transposé si vous voulez
dans une carotane une variante
d'ailleurs que que je conseille qui est
simple même pour les les amateurs pour
démarrer on va la montrer ouais parce
que les gens savent pas forcément de
quoi on parle
voilà et cavalier F6 au lieu de foi F5
le coup qui était joué pendant des
lustres c'est le coup de carpov qui est
17 qui a un peu passé de mode mais quand
même c'est toujours pareil futé voilà là
on fait ces trois fous des six fouder 3
vous voyez ça ressemble un petit peu
c'est vraiment c'est le exactement c'est
vrai que après après par exemple petit
rock dams2 ici on fait H5 voilà on va
faire tout 8 et H5 H4 et en fait on s'en
moque on s'en moque c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas faible et ça empêche les
blancs d'attaquer ça crée d'attaction
fait petit rock ça crée un attaquant et
si on fait grand rock en fait ça empêche
des G4 et c'est pas mal c'est pas mal
c'est intéressant comme concept est-ce
qu'il est rigolo c'est de revenir la
position qu'on vient de voir et être
comparé à celle qu'on a maintenant il y
a la colonne B en plus qui est ouverte
pour les blancs voilà la différence
fondamentale avec cette doublette en C3
C4
il y a des décisions importantes à
prendre il y a une petite menace
s'éprendait suivi de cavalier B4 alors
est-ce que c'est vraiment une menace il
y a xhachette bon faut vérifier mais en
tout cas
le fait d'avoir la colonne B ça laisse
du jeu blanc vraisemblablement
alors qu'est-ce qu'on joue concrètement
ici
c'est génial c'est ce que j'ouvre un
message slack donc c'est là que c'est le
il y a pas de grand secret en fait quand
même si ben non mais enfin oui et en
fait j'ouvre le slack pour voir
Nathan qui me dit on voit ton slack sur
le stream
j'avais pas vu moi je l'ai pas vu et
c'est énorme c'est énorme j'adore
j'adore je suis désolé je pense qu'on a
pas vu d'infos confidentiel j'espère
et je vois qu'il a raison j'ai raté ça
j'ai raté ça c'était un des moments
j'irai voir le replay pour pour ce
mouvement
t'inquiète
là c'est bon il est mis dedans
si jamais
le charme de ce stream voilà du coup
c'est décédé il a laissé cavalier B4
c'est un petit peu la question que vous
voyez j'ai envie de gratter la paire ok
c'est jouer kb4 et là je savais pas j'ai
envie de de garder mon fou ça m'embête
de le donner mais ce que je peux jouer
fois chat c'est la question voilà et du
coup la question critique c'était G6
carrément j'avais envie d'aller voir
aussi mais tu vois le C5 en pratique ça
intéressant ce que tu montres Laurent
parce que en pratique on peut pas du
tout y aller du coup exactement c'est
exactement ça ça fait arrêter la barre
entonnoir en fait donc et ça fait
arrêter de calculer avec les Blancs
après si l'autre si votre adversaire le
joue typiquement bah là vous pouvez
reconsidérer évidemment ce qu'a dit
Kevin dame prend J6 qui est quand même
un coup candidat qui est peut-être plus
fort que l'autre mais peu importe on a
ces cinq au minimum donc on regarde
autre chose donc sur dame B1 clairement
à mon avis fier il va pas déjà Viny ne
va pas passer beaucoup de temps sur G6
et fier va pas le jouer donc clairement
clairement ça va pas aller ce que vous
explique Laurence c'est hyper
intéressant parce qu'il faut savoir
arrêter son calcul en fait des fois moi
j'aurais du bien-être du genre surtout
si c'est en blitz etc on s'intéresse on
se dit c'est un peu chaud on a envie de
tout contrôler et en fait parfois il y a
pas besoin de tout contrôler si on voit
qu'il y a vraiment une sorte de balise
qui vous permet de vous arrêter parce
que vous savez que la position
elle est passée agréable pour
l'adversaire ben vous n'avez pas besoin
de calculer comme l'a dit Laurent fou
projet 6 de manière trop intensive
tout à fait tout à fait en particulier
alors c'est vrai ce que tu dis en partie
longue mais en particulier en rapide et
Blitz voilà oui il faut vraiment faire
des décisions et jouer
à l'intuition c'est pour ça que non
c'est pour ça que j'aime beaucoup le les
rapides et c'est cadence rapide je
trouve ça ça définit encore mieux le la
force du joueur finalement il a joué G6
et l'intuition du joueur tu vois où il y
a moins de prépa et tout ça
quand même
ça paraît assez dingue là je n'aime pas
du tout
non mais ça peut-être pas quoi faire
d'autre parce qu'il était déjà assez mal
en fait et c'est 5 peut-être pas le
meilleur coup pour la jauge je mets sans
doute un coup très intéressant
j'ai pas compris
choc choc 75 est-ce que vous pouvez
expliquer ce fou des 6 dans cette
variante de la carrocane étant donné que
sur dame de échec les noirs doivent
perdre un temps j'en faut 7 les Noirs
jouent les Noirs font passer
ou des 6 alors attends on va pas faire
mon rapide rapide allez rapide allez
rapide je te l'explique c'est ma partie
contre André Sokolov d'ailleurs j'avais
tenté ça j'ai pas joué souvent ce truc
là de la karaoké mais c'est au début je
m'étais dit tiens allez je vais essayer
de battre André bon j'ai changé d'avis
après 15 coups
on peut faire dameset par exemple ouais
sur dame 2 sur dame on peut faire de la
musette mais en fait moi ce qui m'a joué
en vrai c'est ça c'est 4 ou 6 à 2 et là
ça force
allez on revient et il a joué ces cinq
visites il est pas allé pas d'aventure
elle a pas trop aimé peut-être d'un
projet si c'était plus fort tu avais
certainement raison oui après bon c'est
ça au niveau pratique ça a l'air OK quoi
on a envie de regarder d'un projet 6
mais au moins il l'a fait il a pas perdu
tant donc sachant que le temps c'est une
variable importante on est beaucoup
mieux ici avec les Blancs il y avait pas
peut-être pas besoin de d'aller dans
cette dans cette ligne
tout à fait
la finale est-ce qu'elle est meilleure
voilà final on peut dire choc choc ou
Wix c'est peut-être un petit plus pour
pour les blancs mais pas suffisamment
disons que tu as une majorité centrale
dans cette position donc tu préfères
avoir les dames sur l'échiquet tu dirais
quoi à chaque choc toi Laurent par
rapport à la position qu'on voyait tout
à l'heure dame 2 dame sage je te bouffe
les dames et je te dis que je suis un
peu mieux avec les Blancs non pas
vraiment en fait c'est un truc ouais il
y a un bon jeu de pièces pour les noirs
qui tend à compenser bizarrement mais
effectivement si on doit choisir je
dirais que les blancs sont pas vraiment
mieux mais si on doit choisir un camp je
prendrai quand même je prendrai quand
même les blancs on préfère jouer avec
les blancs mais tu estimes que
l'avantage n'est pas suffisant donc j'ai
enlevé la caméra moi ce que j'en pensais
en fait de ta question c'est
c'est que c'est que on voyait plus vite
à l'image et ça me ça me gonfle donc
j'ai changé donc ces caméras je fais
grève je mettrai les caméras quand il y
aura quand il y aura le le champion du
monde on attend le champion du monde
alors cahier des 5 parce que j'ai pas la
réforme sur comment on attend si tu peux
m'expliquer peut-être à la pause entre
les deux matchs remarque le deuxième
match commence à 19h30
[Musique]
pour une première c'est correct mais le
problème c'est que c'est pas ma première
tu vois c'est que j'ai fait plein de
plein de streams
n'hésitez pas à venir à nos amis de ce
qui nous regardent je vois que les gens
qui sont sur Youtube on vous salue sur
Youtube évidemment même si on donne un
petit légère préférence à twitch on peut
pas être partout non plus c'est
difficile de suivre deux chats en fait
si vous voulez tout simplement c'est
mais n'hésitez pas un truc premier truc
si vous êtes sur chaise 24 en français
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à cheesecom
en français parce que évidemment dans un
premier temps on essaie de faire les
choses sur les deux sur les deux
antennes mais à terme évidemment on fera
plus qu'une seule chaîne et ça sera
chelsecom en français donc n'hésitez pas
à vous abonner à la chaîne cheesecom
pour ne rater aucun show et si vous êtes
sur cheesecom et que vous n'êtes pas
abonné et bien abonnez-vous comme ça
vous vous êtes notifié dès qu'il y a un
show et c'est magnifique vous rater rien
et si vous êtes abonné sur cheesecom
Youtube qu'est-ce qu'on fait on met un
pouce on met le pouce bleu mon cher mon
cher Kévin comme ça on soutient en
soutien corpo soutien voilà corpo on met
le pouce bleu et vite il est en train de
me soutenir là regarde-moi ça
évidemment 3 il va bouffer à chaque
après peut-être il faut bouffer à chaque
tout de suite mais
bon ça a l'air dans ma Chise ok bon il
peut refaire dame juste ici s'il a envie
Esteban qui demande si on gagne des mugs
et oui les meubles collector ils sont
ici moi je vous le dis
ils sont archi collector pour ceux qui
les ont gardé les dans 30 ans ça vaut ça
vaut un Bitcoin au minimum enfin bon
gardez-les moi je les garde en tout cas
on sait jamais
allez
on va maintenant on a au moins un annule
mais alors évidemment là c'est à dire
qu'on a un peu la nul quand on veut je
sais pas ce que tu en penses Kevin mais
je trouve que là c'est quand même c'est
assez crazant normalement pour les
blancs oui parce qu'au niveau matériel
en bouffant le pion on est déjà à niveau
on est déjà à trois tours c'est dingue
après les pièces pas si facile
la paire de fou contre bien la case
d'arrivée de la tour est-ce que je
ferais pas un petit coup de parce que si
je fais ça et ça en fait
donc en fait je vois pas trop comment tu
te dépatouilles là pour être pour être
honnête et donc si cavalier G3
un petit coup de cavalier F4 j'attends
ton G8 et j'espère le tour génétique
c'est un peu naïf je menace quand même
de prendre j'ai l'impression que tu vas
être obligé de te débarrasser de mon mon
cavalier non tu en penses quoi ouais
bien sûr
je vais le faire avant mais
attention attention
tu vas pas t'en sortir
quand même c'est vrai que attention si
on essaie de défendre comme ça et bien
badaboum dame ranger 4 et terminer ado
alors on peut encore se débattre à
l'anakamura du faire du Tour Eiffel mais
alors ça va faire énormément de pions
regardez-moi toujours ouvert
malheureusement
donc il fait la MG6 il a pris la nul non
mais non
mais non non non
regardez ce qu'il fallait faire il
fallait faire soit cavalier F4 soit d'un
proche j'ai mis du coup la ligne de
l'ordi et Caval F4 était le bon coup
c'est pas une surprise mais alors est-ce
que ça serait pas Kevin tu sais quoi une
stratégie d'équipe ouais si si on peut
imaginer qu'il y a tellement d'avance
mais bon il a dû regarder les essayer
d'à côté et 3 et demi et oui et puis en
plus fier est quand même le plus
dangereux on va on va regarder tout de
suite aravine contre Bull Maga qui
semble très déséquilibré sur le papier
mais
elle a les Noirs face à ravine qui vient
de jouer à 6
minutes d'avance à la pendule 5 minutes
compte 2 minutes
[Musique]
elle a perdu on voit alors attendez je
vais vous mettre le score sur le
pour l'instant et encore que vidite
pouvait quasiment sceller le sort voilà
ça a été tactiquement très pauvre là
pour la peau
il est bon tant pis tu l'as bien pointé
hein dès que tu avais sur l'échiquier là
elle a tout donné elle a tout donné et
donc ça fait ça fait un score énorme
pour nos amis de est-ce que je peux pas
voir le scoreboard non on voit ça
d'accord donc c'est sur l'autre bon ben
écoutez demain je serai meilleur ça je
vous ça va pas être pire de toute façon
on va toucher du bois tiens
alors on a choupi qui a quand même plus
de lots donc ça peut être un
espoir peut-être alors peut-être contre
il prend l'eau aussi il prend l'eau
aussi choupi c'est pas possible bon en
même temps il est comme il lui avait
raconté à un petit
un petit mensonge peut-être avec son
attaque quoi que c'est intéressant
qu'est-ce qu'il devait jouer sur fupron
HS on a vu la jauge qui était hyper
hyper haute Laurent sur sa crise de fou
je sais pas alors je vais mettre
dame G5 il avait dû voir et il a raté
quelque chose sans doute cavalier F5 la
pointe et la tour D1 ouais ça sert à
table parce qu'en fait il faut F6 ou X6
de la dame c'est ça très très mignon
exactement avec le mat en plus sur la
première et donc il a raté ça et donc il
faut prendre cavalier F5 la même si mais
c'est encore gagnant pour les noirs très
largement et sa phrase 600 pour les
Indiens un peu chaud parce qu'il a une
30 il faut qu'il défende quand même
correctement j'ai un thème Histor G3
un peu bateau mais c'est quand même un
petit peu chaud on va faire contrôler un
petit peu les cases
on a envie de faire
tout reprend des cartes peut-être
ouais
ce que j'ai le droit de faire tourger
trop tourgé 3
cavalier projet 3 puis on prend G3 avec
l'idée de menacer prise F7
alors un petit peu chaud il y a des il y
a des petites
au ralenti donc tu fais ça et tu fais ça
et tu veux faire ça
voilà j'ai voulu tester ça et il y a
toujours G3 autrement à la place de HS
qui est intéressant aussi mais c'est
plus logique pour l'instant
c'est optimiste puis on prend
tu sais la limite j'aime bien c'est du
milieu mon adversaire moi
on va faire ça si je prends bêtement non
sur H6 j'ai ton G4 je crois ouais mais
je peux peut-être faire un petit coup
d'échec c'est ça hein
ça me fait peur bon on voit que c'est
quand même un petit peu chaud
avec peu de temps et surtout qu'il a il
a pas beaucoup de temps notre ami
il a préféré simplifier il a eu peur
vous voyez la peur aux échecs joue un
grand rôle ça chou ça joue ça joue avec
le frein à main après là c'est une perd
pas honnêtement ça va faire mal à la
team adverse
tout à fait maintenant ils ont pris une
telle valise
est-ce qu'on n'irait pas voir rapidement
Laurent la jeune la jeune pour voir
contre Martinez ce qu'elle fait tout à
fait on va voir ça et si c'est vrai que
c'est le point à se faire là avec les
avec les Blancs il est 2006 à 2004 même
si c'est une grande grande espoir du jeu
elle a pas encore le niveau 2600 hello
attention
agréable ouais mais sans plus est-ce que
c'est est-ce que c'est si grave que ça
j'ai un problème le Pione 5 et du coup
ça me gêne mon mon cavalier H5 j'ai
envie de faire G5 H5 mais je peux pas
donc du coup
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont malades
mais ok là j'ai envie de jouer pour
tourner autour des 5 j'aimerais bien
faire quelque chose comme ça
m'énerve de me prendre ça par exemple
à moins que j'ai un cavalier prend E5 de
l'espace
et oui peut-être hein
en fait il y a pas du tout à chaque
ouais attention c'est compliqué quand
même donc on va voir c'est vrai que tu
as raison sinon je joue dame c'est 5
préventive je joue au H2 ou quelque
chose comme ça
il a joué
l'autre jour et il joue bien sûr
on voit que la petite normalement elle
est censée mettre la pression
c'est la prodige indienne et quand elle
est foutue c'est la petite bon voilà
c'est il y a quand même
voilà c'est Kévin il aime les gagnants
voilà
il aime les gagnants les perdants ont
toujours toi écoute tu as raison non pas
du tout mais on va la supporter cette
jeune indienne et regarde toi 8 qui
protège aussi donc ça serait pas l'idée
de faire piéger trois et H5 allez vas-y
ma grande
allez ok j'ai 3 d'abord H5 et maintenant
il y a plus
que j'ai trois jouets évidemment les
trois fous des trois mauvais coups
d'ailleurs et oui à 5 maintenant allez
fonce et c'est jouer bien jouer 3 8 qui
contrôle elle l'avait vu elle l'avait vu
une 50 contre 3 30 ça pourrait être un
coup de massue phénoménal pour
Laurent parce que le cavalier 3 est
enfermé aussi mais j'ai pas de solution
pour pour enlever mon roi et puis
attention il continue elle joue sans
complexe là maintenant c'est beaucoup
plus chaud tout à l'heure on avait une
grosse réaction avec les tours au centre
maintenant fou des trois c'est bizarre
ce qu'il a voulu faire j'ai pas trop
ouais il a la dame en E2 donc il voulait
peut-être faire pousser quatre un jeu
simple et là il s'est fait contrer
attention parce que ça se perd cette
position avec les Blancs
tout à fait ça s'aggrave
peut-être
et pourquoi pas finalement tous les
gagnants de loto ont tenté leur chance
pourquoi pas on peut jouer aussi le plus
conventionnel tour des 8 qui est pas bon
évidemment on prend on met une tour sur
une nouvelle ouverte bon mais j'ai ça
qu'elles font ça allez je joue comme la
jeune fille il a tendance est plutôt
chez les Noirs la dynamique chez les
Noirs donc ça serait bien elle peut elle
peut même quasiment
on sent on sent qu'elle peut qu'elle
peut l'emporter tout simplement ça va
vite hein et maintenant
les deux joueurs vont être sous pression
il y a pas de rematch dans ces cas-là
c'est pas un drame personne éliminé à la
première semaine mais ça permet de
commencer quand même difficilement ou
bien et de se positionner pour
l'objectif il y a 16 équipes l'objectif
c'est de se qualifier pour les quarts de
finale les 8 premières équipes seront
qualifiées avec des éliminations en fait
alors c'est c'est assez c'est assez
amusant Kevin je crois que c'est la
première fois que tu que tu commandes
cette prochaine Ligue et moi je suis pas
moi j'ai joué il y a longtemps avant
j'ai joué en temps 2017 ou 2018 je crois
la dernière fois et en fait il faut une
désignation progressive c'est à dire que
au bout de deux semaines je dis au
hasard peut-être trois semaines il y a
trois équipes éliminées puis ensuite 2
puis ensuite 3 à la quatrième et la 5e
tu vois petit à petit et je trouve ça
pas mal comme système du coup j'espère
que celle que les équipes qui ont aucune
chance de remonter soit éliminées c'est
ce que celles qui sont dans le ventre
mou mais plutôt en termes en deuxième
partie du tableau ont une chance de
remonter mais pas en jouant contre des
derniers en jouant contre les premiers
donc c'est un bon système
un excellent système cette cette
processeig et on a hâte évidemment de
voir notamment Magnus Carson manus
Carson arrive quand Kevin part et oui
voilà c'est normal quoi
comparaison est assez bonne et et jeudi
on a hâte aussi évidemment de retrouver
nos amis de Blist stream avec notamment
le champion français mvl Maxime va chez
Lagrave toujours très très fort dans ces
cadences mais d'autres d'autres de la
alors je sais pas je crois que les
appareils sont faits je sais pas quelle
est la compo pour ce jeudi mais je
regarderai et ça va être ça va être un
bel événement
ce qu'on peut jouer dans B6 ou C5 dans
le genre de position on avait joué fou
cette précédemment j'étais très très
bien je rois je suis très fort et
maintenant il faut faire jouer le foot
de case noir
alors
ouais
elle prend F1 c'est compréhensible mais
attention si Martigny est-ce perd cette
partie c'est terminé
de son côté il a deux minutes compte 15
secondes il va réussir à gagner à cause
de cela je pense je pense aussi il est
très fort avec peu de temps en tout cas
j'ai joué audio et je sentais que je
faisais pas le poids avec 10 secondes
chacun j'étais j'étais pas pas favori
c'est c'est vraiment
un élément important des Blitz par
Internet cette phase où on a plus de
temps moi non plus Laurent
de toute façon je pense que la raté
l'histoire bon la très vue très très
rapidement elle a raté la séquence dès
qu'elle a pris en F1 la libérer un peu
la position adverse alors qu'elle avait
trouvé le très jolie faux sat dommage
là maintenant
attends attends
dans cette position là
c'est dommage on donne pas cette paire
de fou ne devez pas votre paire de fou
tant pis le pion c'est pas grave faites
ça faites ça mais gardez votre paire de
fou là là c'est trop là ça craint
maintenant
ça part si le mec donne sa dame mais
c'est vraiment ça serait là c'est une
horreur à défendre alors attention ce
qui veut dire pas tellement d'espace
bizarrement il a pas tellement de cases
pour revenir tu vois c'est pion c'est un
peu bizarre comme cavaliers il pourrait
il pourrait faire un grand tour mais ça
prend du temps et c'est pas sûr qu'on y
arrive le grand tour
je vais pouvoir vraiment m'amuser dans
cette position
et c'est 4 ok ayada mais cette
fois donc c'est vraiment une galère de
tout maintenir il doit être sérieux
évidemment en face ça c'est plutôt une
une idée malheureusement c'est pas
suffisant je pense il l'a eu à
l'expérience Martinez salcan Tara
écoute
ça doit suffire
alors F3
c'est terminé et s'être une victoire de
Martine à premier point entière pour nos
amis brésiliens ça va faire deux partout
sur ce match mais ça laisse toujours
trois points de retard et il reste
simplement deux matchs attention plus le
droit à l'erreur ça fera du 5 et demi je
vais essayer de vous retrouver le on va
faire un léger break mon cher mon cher
Kevin je suis en sueur alors ce que je
vous conseille tu t'es bien débrouillé
au niveau technique là parce que je vais
mettre je vais mettre la scène de break
alors c'est de baisser légèrement le son
parce que je suis pas complètement
de la pub donc à mon avis je vous si en
dessous si vous avez des écouteurs comme
moi je vous conseille de baisser le son
alors allez-y c'est un truc c'est un
conseil d'amis c'est après j'ai pas
envie de super déjà on a assez de sieste
pour un coup si vous faites un procès
pour chass.com vous êtes devenu sourd en
écoutant stream JETCOM en français on a
suffisamment vous voyez hein déjà on a
quelqu'un qui réclame des sommes quand
même bon pour nous c'est rien mais quand
même hein
100 millions qu'est-ce qu'on a avec 100
millions c'est pas neutre c'est pas
notre comme on dit une maison à
Saint-Malo une demi maison
même à Saint-Malo c'est vrai ouais 100
millions ça commence à être un coup pour
matiner cette campagne qui a pas vu le
matin un coup ah ça c'est pas c'est pas
le bon coup là pour vous montrer que il
a vraiment il a vraiment du temps et là
il échange les dames à la place il va
prendre un F6 tranquille ou pas
normalement il le voit le matin mais bon
après ça peut se rater mais là il a
préféré plutôt que faire prise FC il a
préféré faire dame prend ah bah oui bah
oui sur ça oui bien sûr
tout sur échec
ok donc là elle va abandonner ça à faire
de partout et tu sais quoi on va se
faire on va se faire un micro break mon
chien mon cher Kevin à Bordeaux abandon
léger break et pendant ce temps je vais
essayer de mettre le score mais en tout
cas ce que ça donne c'est du 5 et demi 2
et demi
du sac et demi pour demi on a dit
Laurent Premier ministre premier à 8 et
demi donc les Indiens sont extrêmement
bien parti et ça ça commence à jouer sur
les attention de pas jouer trop petit
bras quand même pour nos amis à dire
mais bon exactement on voit ça on
revient bientôt à tout de suite merci de
nous suivre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour pour ce premier
match de Pro Chessy comme vous le voyez
vous avez le score entre les lignes
Indian yogi et le Brésil
kaibrazak et demi mon cher Kevin 500 ça
sent le Roussillon pour nos amis
brésiliens dans ce match ils sont
dominés pour l'instant ils ont pris une
bonne on est de retour pour normalement
clôturer le match et que les Indiens
l'emportent ils ont une équipe quand
même très très complémentaire je pense
qu'elle est très très forte pour la
suite avec un vide qui va emmener
emmener ses collègues et à 27 24 il est
il est c'est aussi un bon rapport ce
joueur
et je pense que ganimbali là de bien
bien se débrouiller en partie ultra
rapide donc du coup c'est intéressant
on a vu qu'elle mettrait des points
24/50 c'est fort aussi et ouais c'est
important parce que il y a on le
rappelle une joueuse obligatoire dans
chaque équipe et donc effectivement le
niveau de la joueuse joue beaucoup et là
elle a l'air elle a l'air elle est sûre
enfin elle a l'air non elle a pas l'air
elle est elle est sur la porte
ascendante c'est-à-dire qu'elle a 2428
mais on sent que dans un an elle aura
plus de 2428 elle aura elle aura
beaucoup plus
et bonjour à tous Sur sur le YouTube là
je fais un petit tour sur Youtube chez
nos amis YouTube n'hésitez pas
évidemment à vous abonner à la chaîne à
mettre des petits pouces bleus et à ceux
qui sont sur chaise 24 en français à
basculer petit à petit les petites
habitudes faut aller sur il faut aller
sur chaise comme et salut voilà
n'hésitez pas
n'hésitez pas donc voilà on n'a pas les
parties les caméras je galère à un
attendre n'hésite pas ça va arriver ça
va arriver non les caméras moi j'ai
abandonné là pour l'instant donc
n'hésitez pas à
chez la partie des quatre cavaliers de
visite contre Martinez Martinez a joué
les quatre cavaliers H3 une voyante
marginale alors donc ça va repartir
directement
et regarder moi ça une quatre cavalier
ça ne rigole pas ah non c'est il a les
blancs Martinez pardon donc là je
vais changer en direct en direct avec
contre
je vais l'enlever en fait ça parce que
ça a pas de sens du coup
ils peuvent déjà plier le machin vous
voyez il y a 5,5
il pleut le match
voilà en attendant qu'on a les caméras
je vais mettre ça en gros on a vite avec
les Noirs donc pour les indianes yogi
face à Martinez Alcantara pour nos amis
brésiliens qui sont en train de prendre
l'eau à trois ok à 3 de jouer
pas extraordinaire tout ça
a priori
/ bracket
et donc je démarre avec force évidemment
je ne suis pas à l'origine du choix
musical que j'ai plus ou moins écouté
hier c'était pas mal non c'est pas c'est
vraiment mauvais non non pas du tout non
non histoire de histoire de rebondir sur
ton réglage champ c'est bon qui était
bon dans l'ensemble ça va c'est quoi ta
musique préférée c'est la tribu de Dana
non je me moque mais moi j'aime beaucoup
mieux sexe tu vois c'est un truc que je
veux faire je viendrai il faut que
j'aille voir en concert tu vois
c'est un truc que je veux faire donc
voilà
tu vois mais les Red Hot à la pause très
bien voilà de mais il faut il faut les
droits je pense il faut les droits
je suis pas sûr bah on va laisser un
attend et Sami gérer cela voilà alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans cette 4
cavaliers avec H3
donc H3 western un coup d'attendre qui
peut être utile pour plus tard
bon il y a trois existent aussi dans
cette position
voilà c'est toujours
aller plus loin à 4 moi même ici j'ai
joué qui est pas ok pas idiot food bref
H3 fubé 4 A3 et on prend la paire de fou
mais ça reste une position assez fermée
et là on va jouer c'est le jeu du chat
et de la souris si les blancs font petit
rock il se prennent à l'avalanche comme
tout à l'heure on l'a vu Kevin tu l'as
bien pour l'instant entrer dangereux et
si les Noirs font un petit rock et bien
ils se prennent la balance aussi ça
c'est intéressant c'est un bon rebond
par rapport à ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure Laurent donc ils vont pas ils
vont pas ok ni l'un ni l'autre donc ce
qui va se passer c'est qu'il va
certainement faire un coup de dame 7
fous d'essai tout fou 6 et on attend de
voir a priori ça se terminait ce genre
d'histoire c'est quand ça se termine
Kevin ça se termine par grand rock un
grand rock collectif chacun parce que
c'est moins facile à attaquer des deux
côtés donc tu te dis qu'ils vont
sécuriser là-bas et salut à toi c'est
tout cas merci pour le petit mot et
merci à tous ceux qui nous rejoignent
ouais merci à vous tous vos commentaires
et vos questions et à vous toutes c'est
pas on sait pas
donc ouais n'hésitez pas ouais vos
questions là parce que on papote on
papote évidemment pourquoi Kevin a
absolument pas envie de voir manuscrite
par exemple
non mais je me suis fait inviter
tu sais en plus je me suis fait inviter
avant et on m'a proposé de faire le
stream j'ai dit je peux pas du coup
faire la deuxième partie le deuxième
match voilà
qui revient oui effectivement tu sais
Kevin c'est une vieille tu sais il faut
toujours
c'est mieux de poser une question à
laquelle tu connais déjà la réponse à
éviter
bien sûr j'utilise aussi ce stratagème
alors dans certains cas comment on fait
pour avoir le rafraîner aux commentaires
dans ce socio c'est un habitué de chaise
24 il y a devient sobre
il est très très large il est très très
large sur l'eau il est très riche donc
il peut être sub il peut faire des dons
voilà et très généreux surtout tu vois
c'est bien parce que d'être riche en
fait bon c'est bien mais tu vois c'est
pas sûr que après tu tout le monde en
profites mais en l'occurrence il est il
est très généreux c'est un actionnaire
c'est un actionnaire du groupe play
Magnus d'accord qui a voilà qui a
certainement voté pour la fusion
acquisition je sais pas quoi on en parle
mais je suis généreux c'est beau
avec chase.com
salut super looping était en tout cas je
regarderai ton message sur le discord je
l'ai pas vu en plus j'ai ouvert mon
discord ce matin et c'est vrai que je
suis pas hyper assidu vous le savez
certains c'est difficile de suivre tous
les réseaux je sais pas comment tu fais
toi Laurent tu arrives à suivre tous les
réseaux ou
non
je réponds aux personnes à qui j'ai
envie de répondre sinon je réponds pas
désolé par avance c'est dur de tout
suivre en même temps franchement c'est
c'est pas évident c'est bien d'être un
peu spécialisé pour les réseaux qu'on a
un peu seul parce que sinon c'est
compliqué moi j'ai vraiment un collègue
qui me donne un gros coup de main mais
malgré tout c'est quand même difficile
de tout suivre bon les petites manœuvres
les potions fermées Johanna à manœuvre
c'est comme ça qu'on voit des coups
cavalier B1 des coups comme fou c'est 8
qui sont normaux en fait ouais mais là
c'est pas terrible alors on dit que les
cavaliers sont mieux mais là il y a pas
beaucoup d'espace pour ces cavaliers il
y a ce qui est ici 3D 5 qui est assez
inarrêtable j'aime pas du tout les noirs
et si je sais pas ce que tu en penses
c'est sûr qu'ils sont moins bien parce
qu'on n'a pas trop d'idées voilà souvent
ça se reconnaît comme ça si vous avez
des idées pour votre jeu de pièces c'est
plus facile là c'est pas le cas alors
est-ce que je peux tenter de jouer
cavalier des quatre pour changer un peu
cette structure de pion si cette
position ne me va pas faire qui était
assez logique aussi mettre le cavalier
ici c'est vrai qu'un jour il y aurait
peut-être eu C3 on pouvait on pouvait
faire cailler des quatre pour faire
toujours attention c'est logique perd
pas le pion
on aurait fait Dame des deux je suppose
que c'est trois qui est descend qu'on
aura activé c'est vrai que tu es 3 B1
c'est 3 sera arrivé à un moment il a eu
peur de ça c'est vrai qu'il a mis son
cahier C5 et finalement c'est logique
aussi pour déstabiliser ce cahiers
maintenant faut faire B4 et B4 quoi que
quoi que
pourquoi pas en fait il y a les deux
rois derrière ça se tente non et ça
reste à peu près équilibrée quand même
comme position tout à fait est-ce qu'il
y a une équipe française bien sûr quelle
équipe française il y a l'équipe de
Blitz stream avec notamment et bien le
leader de cette équipe le grand l'unique
le l'ancien le champion du monde de
Blitz
2022 Maxime va chier la grave donc voilà
une belle équipe avec les habitués de la
chaîne B stream
des meilleurs joueuses au monde tout
simplement donc
ils auront toutes leurs chances d'aller
très loin dans cette compète
et à 19h 30
19h 19h il y a le champion du monde qui
entre en piste avec des chaises bois
donc face à l'équipe de narodite ski ça
va être un bon combat il faut rester
minuscarsen dans ces trucs quand il est
en forme il peut faire 4 points
attention
alors F3 F3 jouer par Martinez Alcantara
c'est les parties moins rigolotes vous
le voyez c'est vraiment beaucoup plus
lent le combat à se mettre en place
tout à fait
faire quelque chose avec les Noirs ok ça
a été
vite jouer côté blanc ce qu'on va faire
rebondir en eux aussi
et
est-ce que Laurent on fera un petit tour
d'horizon rapide des autres échiquetés
tu vois le Breton s'ennuie dans ses
positions oh là là bah dis donc
c'est la c'est la base
on échange les deux fous direct
2433 Alexander fear 2606 et les Indiens
man donc elle a raison elle a raison de
la jouer simple raison
pour se rapprocher du Graal on le
rappelle à 8 et demi c'est terminé donc
il y a new guise je crois qu'on joue
quand même le dernier match mais
évidemment ça compte pour du beurre ou
le départage enfin bon ça ça compte
moins cher
on sait pas
il a été très bon il a dit bon je vais
acheter des fleurs pour ma femme car je
suis riche selon Laurent enfin je sais
pas s'il est riche mais il vit comme un
riche et c'est ça le plus important
finalement même si tu es pauvre
ouais ça va être assez cool ouais ouais
c'est ça moi j'aime beaucoup les Noirs
ici on va voir le dernier peut-être
entre Bull Maga et gaddy Miley
qui a pas l'air en forme aujourd'hui on
l'a vu faire des gaffes pas du tout
la représentative de son niveau KB 50 en
attaque le pion C7 3d8 F4 j'ai
l'impression qu'elle s'est trompé dans
l'ouverture ça a pas l'air terrible ce
qu'elle fait tourner
par contre ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'elle a gardé du temps donc bon il y a
une petite pression blanche mais c'est
peut-être pas grand chose et en termes
de temps 8 minutes contre 3,50 c'est
plutôt pas mal qui avait réussi à rester
dans le match à ce niveau là même plus
que ça d'ailleurs ah oui c'est vrai
qu'elle a joué vite ouais ok on va voir
il essaie de punir c'est vrai que ça
sent au feeling on sent qu'il peut y
avoir un truc à pas d'après la jauge il
y a rien donc pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
mais
les parties sont
vraiment assez assez soporifique là on
va pas vous mentir franchement on n'a
pas le droit à du beau jeu dans cette
non seulement tout à l'heure ça a été un
peu plus faille là c'est la guerre de
tranchées bon ça y est ça va s'exciter
peut-être un petit peu ça se
déséquilibre alors pourquoi on n'a pas
les raisins avec nous le reposer il y a
une question intéressante là pourquoi
c'est pas l'équipe de France et l'équipe
de communauté ou de ou de d'affinité je
dirais et voilà on voit par exemple il y
a une équipe norvégienne et il joue pas
il joue pas du tout avec cette équipe
norvégienne par exemple manus Carlsen il
joue avec il joue avec les chaises bras
donc ils sont Canadiens donc
effectivement on joue avec qui on veut
donc aller-retza il a aucune c'est pas
du tout la France là qui représentait
avec enfin si quand même c'est une
équipe française mais après il y a
gretchouk je crois qu'il y a inscrit
dans l'équipe de voilà on va dire voilà
voilà
donc on fait un peu ce qu'on veut
du coup tournoi par équipe on le
rappelle des équipes de 4 joueurs la
moyenne n’excède pas
2500 hello
premier équipe à 8 points et demi dans
ces confrontations voilà on voit en
images et
4 ondes donc on est à la troisième là et
ça peut ça peut se terminer dès
maintenant
on voit et on voit que jeudi on aura
l'équipe de Blitz stream à 16h30 tandis
que ce soir les Charlotte ça on se
croirait au basket tu sais les Charlotte
contre eux contre les chess bois avec
Magnus Carlson face à narrodite qui on
va voir des belles Paris les avatars
sont sympas mais il y a une équipe qui a
pas trop joué le jeu de l'avatar
[Musique]
il est pas mal celui de alors moi j'aime
bien celui des chaises bras
Charlotte c'est bien aussi et pas mal
aussi j'aime bien aussi c'est sympa
le fou c'est raté
qui a le bouledogue
c'est
la licorne
avec la NBA c'est pas mal ça fait
vraiment penser à cela quand on voit les
logos
ok le tigre pour tatsuka
MG6 joué par visite qui est toujours
aussi solide très très dur à battre qui
nous a d'ailleurs en parlant de d'équipe
de France il faisait partie d'équipe
indienne qui nous a éliminés aux
champignons de par équipe je jouais avec
Maxime jouer justement contre Maxime il
a fait une il a très bien tenu son il a
gagné après avec des Noirs perdu la
deuxième avec les blancs mais ensuite
fait nul en blitz contre Maxime ce qui
est pas donné à tout le monde et donc il
a participé à notre élimination donc
gros client en visite attention
peut-être moins connu travaille bien là
ce qui va pas jouer pour descendre la
prochainement Laurent et faire très très
mal il va faire des cinq clairement
du coup ben ça fait peur
tout à l'heure il y avait rien mais la
structure c'est mal passé
il est dur à bouger
la structure de pion et dans de bonnes
conditions
le pion le 4
à voler et du coup maintenant on a une
emprise centrale et il veut la valoriser
avec ce coup d'5 ouvrir les perspectives
sur le pion des trois et faire très très
mal exactement
qui est assez faible pour le coup
et comment on fait avec les Blancs et
bien bonne chance
même si un jour je mets pas un gros
avantage c'est quand même et il y a un
problème tactique c'est insistant envie
de faire des quatre en premier qui a
l'air sympa pour faire
G2 tu as raison mais il y a encore mieux
que ça je crois c'est dames et de même
pas regardé j'ai vu le pion G2 j'ai pas
mauvaise surprise qui qui est en
question
alors si terrible c'est encore pire donc
rien ne marche pour faut gérer des sacs
puis je vois tempo en plus parce que
autant les blancs non plus d'idées
autant les Noirs c'était tout tracé des
cinq menaces donc de prendre un C4 et
d'un mec de bon bah ils se débat comme
il peut
sans rien prendre
intéressant
comment on fait comment on
travaille nous
peut-être juste j'ai pris un petit peu
de temps et simplement tourner cette
voilà pour des 7 tours
prennent en dessin le pion de 3 va être
très très faible donc comme ils ne
peuvent pas trop prendre on va abuser un
peu de la situation on va améliorer tour
des 7 c'est un gros coup d'amélioration
et on dit pas si on va apprendre
évidemment les blancs peuvent faire ces
cinq mais c'est très moche
et ça va pas ça ne va pas donc même ça
ça ne marche pas bon après on peut faire
sur dam F2 si j'ai envie de faire la
même chose je fais tout recettes pour 17
et effectivement tu reprends 5 ne
marchera pas
exactement donc je sais pas je vois il a
joué tout recettes
l'ombre d'un début de contre jeu il ne
rigole pas notre ami visite
ouais il y a pas de code promo désolé
sur chaise comme je sais pas s'ils font
des codes pro ou pas je ne connais pas
encore les codes sur
je sais pas est-ce qu'il y a des codes
parfois promo ou pas ou comment ça
marche j'en sais rien ça je suis désolé
mais n'hésitez pas à l'abonnement
diamant je crois qu'il est pas il est
pas cher il est combien 50 balles comme
ça
tu sais toi tu pues non
je peux la regarder si tu veux
en nous parce que nous attends
pas besoin on vend toute façon alors que
nous on était driver pour vendre mais on
vendait pas tu vois est-ce que vous
faites rien mais vous vendez tu vois
c'est quand même la vie et la vie est
parfois injuste non oui bah c'est une
grosse machine je pense hein des fois tu
le lance le premier bon c'est toujours
pareil
125 euros sur XO c'est de donner pour
toi tu as tellement les moyens
alors dame 2
par mois
l'abonnement diamant
8 dollars pour le platine et 5 dollars
pour le or voilà n'hésitez pas à aller
voir vous avez le d'ailleurs le mot bot
le bot sur le switch qui arrête pas de
mettre des petits messages donc je pense
que pour aller voir
pour aller voir tout ça
en tout cas la partie là ça devient une
masterclass autant tout à l'heure
c'était un peu pénible parce que c'était
guerre de tranchées c'était complètement
bloqué les blancs essayer de faire
quelque chose et surtout les Noirs ont
bien fait il a doublé sur la colonne D
et maintenant il va bientôt pouvoir
percer où j'ai 8 brillantes ici moi
aussi pour venir titiller le pion des
trois à un moment avec foie achète donc
c'est vraiment très très bien construit
il a juste repéré la faiblesse
structurelle le pion des trois arriéré
sur une future colonne semi-ouverte du
coup là on va on va bien travailler la
chose tout à fait il est patient
regardez les petits coups hein
tu peux rien faire avec les Blancs voilà
ce qui lui dit et il a pris
45 secondes pour Martine ça pourrait
être le coup de massue là pour les parce
que c'est quand même probablement leur
meilleur joueur Martinez pour les
Brésiliens
plus fort joueur je pense Laurent de la
salle entre guillemets un de ce match G4
les blancs savent plus quoi faire du
coup ils font une deuxième faiblesse en
F3 donc bon
Martinez c'est un joueur brillant c'est
un grand maître à plus de 2600
malheureusement quand on le met dans une
position où il y a pas grand chose à
faire ben il va essayer de trouver du
contre-jeu mais il va les laisser
quelques plumes positionnels F3 est
faible maintenant mais pour visite
maintenant il faut faire quelque chose
donc ça pose une question le notarial
écoute c'est une bonne décision c'est
une bonne décision de la part de
Martinez il peut pas rester et surtout
en vue du du match qui est quand même
très très compromis il faut qu'il faut
qu'il se passe quelque chose là et pas
encore de résultats d'ailleurs sur les
autres résultats
est-ce que vachali elle s'en sort bien à
la jeune indienne bon là on peut dire
sans doute qu'il y aura nul on va pas
perdre ça peut-être des Noirs sont un
petit peu plus un petit peu est-ce que
Bull Maga s'en sort pour le magasin elle
sait pas sa journée voilà c'est comme ça
les dominés et au niveau du timing c'est
donc ça va faire un et demi je pense
ouais et là
notre ami indien et bien il est il est
en fait il a peut-être gaffé ici Adam
prend un sac Laurent peut-être c'est
pour ça que la jauge chez excitée
du couloir le fameux le grand l'unique
le mathématique le thématique m'a du
couloir on croit qu'on a fait oublier
vite c'est marrant alors envoyer un Vily
il avait fait une belle Master Class il
était en train de travailler le problème
c'est qu'il a plus assez de temps pour
tout sécurisé et il a visiblement oublié
quelque chose d'assez grossier
exactement est-ce qu'il va le voir
il a proposé nul il a accepté oh là là
il faut pas accepter il peut pas
accepter il y a d’apprendre ça qu'il est
gagnant il est gagnant après dans 35e
horreur d'accepter nul oh la la dame
prend 5 + 2 après l'ordinateur voilà
Martinez alors on va voir on va voir
peut-être la fin de de T'choupi contre
aravines ouh là là ravine Arabie avec
cette attitude
il est juste mal au temps mais je pense
que il peut jouer assez facilement ce
genre de position même 100 ans puisque
il a roi Sécur lutter contre roi en slip
ouais c'est ça en slip tout à fait et en
plus et voir on est sur le chemin on en
prend un deuxième
ah là ça va être il est terminé ce match
les Indiens très très impressionnant
pour l'instant tout en Contrôle
on va vous
le magazine ça s'est joué aussi
là-dessus elle est elle est beaucoup
moins dangereuse que vache à Élie et
imaginez
qui s'en sort une nouvelle fois ouais
contre fear au coeur problème ça y est
elle a tourné d'aplomb très solide bravo
à elle grosse journée bon elle a perdu
la deuxième mais quand même
on sent qu'elle joue beaucoup mieux que
que son classement ça y a pas il y a
aucun doute là-dessus
alors
on va regarder on regarde qui vas-y tu
choisis
la technique finale
A3 technique j'aime beaucoup
tranquillement on va améliorer
il y a des pions non seulement un pion
de moi il est passé éloigné il va être
passé éloigné et en plus les Noirs ont
touché à l'aile roi et ses faiblesses
tout ça bien sûr ça laisse aucune chance
de s'en sortir et est-ce que ça va être
officiel il y a 7 3 et il reste deux
parties dans ce match et les Indiens
sont gagnants dans une et dans l'autre
il doit faire nul
ça devrait être fini directement
est-ce que les petits mots écrits sur
l'écran sont trop petits ouais bon je
vais essayer d'agrandir effectivement
quelqu'un qui a envie de te faire bosser
Peter Sully qui veut faire bosser
Laurent beaucoup mieux que ça les noms
c'est les noms des joueurs tout
simplement bon l'idée c'est de voir dans
le détail un porte-pope quoi que ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'on voit les
scores à un endroit avec un aravine
performant c'est moi qui est programmé
tout ça Kevin quand même
fait le truc et le design et compagnie
et le logo le logo
le logo c'est moi aussi je te remercie
en tant que vendeur tu vas pouvoir faire
une vente Laurent il y a air se lève qui
dit ça sert à quoi de prendre
l'abonnement de chasse et du coup comme
c'est toi qui a lancé le sujet
moi j'ai la page de de ce que permettre
les abonnements hors platine et diamant
toi tu ne l'as pas mais
alors je vais mentir ah bah oui alors je
mens un petit peu on a un accès intégral
au Tactics comment s'appelle déjà un
truc là le sprint de problème les frais
de problèmes les tactiques s'il y a des
vidéos en français je sais qu'il y a des
vidéos et je pense qu'il y en aura plus
bientôt puzzle c'est mon petit doigt qui
me l'a dit qu'elle allait avoir plus
bientôt il y a un nombre limité de de
partie de Blitz et
c'est déjà pas mal et à moyen de de
voilà de faire grossir cette communauté
française aussi
voilà je sais pas je suis pas encore
bien hulé on va on va pas lui dire on
m'a dit t'inquiète pas nous on ouais
on va pas on va aller t'inquiète pas et
c'est pas devant
je te jure c'est ce qu'on m'a dit
complètement
alors roi B5 et il prend G5 avalé aussi
et on va protéger ensuite regarde droit
c'est 5 ça c'est le coup du pro donc
qui gagne
mais de lui le petit homme merci je sais
pas franchement c'est faut aller voir
sur les pages et je suis sûr qu'il y a
quelqu'un qui sera ravi de te mettre le
lien je suis nouveau ici je ne sais pas
exactement quels sont les avantages
j'aimerais tant dire autant dire plus
mais vas-y dis-nous Kevin toi qui sais
les avantages alors je vais vous mettre
le petit lien vers la page avec
tout ce qu'il faut pour vous abonner à
chascom voilà comme ça vous avez les
trois types d'abonnement globalement je
l'ai dit il y a hors platine et diamant
et diamant et voilà c'est pas les mêmes
prix bien sûr plus c'est onéreux plus ça
vous offre le droit à
différentes options voilà ce qu'on peut
dire
[Musique]
on capté on avait les on avait les on
avait le col du zoom il commence à
parler notre ami arbitre il y a un
arbitre hein donc on voit mieux nous
imposer une très bonne question est-ce
qu'on peut transférer son abonnement de
chaise 24 on abonnement de chaise.com
alors écoute
j'y tiens alors il y a une chose à
laquelle je tiens c'est que ce qui était
sauf pour en tout cas ceux qui étaient
membre Premium vu que j'avais parlé à
peu près à chaque fois que j'ai fait un
stream
déjà pour l'instant vous avez accès au
même droit sur chaise 24
et en tout cas le site chaise 24
ne fermera pas tant qu'on n'aura pas
trouvé une solution par rapport au site
jamescom et que les abonnés premium
chass 24 et quelque chose sur le site
chezcom voilà donc moi je m'y engage
personnellement voilà qui est vraiment
quelque chose un suivi et donc ça je
suis ça j'en ai déjà parlé avec avec les
gens de chasse.com voilà qui est quelque
chose et évidemment que tout le monde
est d'accord tu vois que les gens qui
ont payé leur abonnement Premium chez 24
se retrouve pas
bête voilà notre équipe travaille à ce
sujet et vous serez formé au plus vite
ne vous inquiétez pas voilà chaise comme
fr qui dit exactement la même chose que
moi ça fait plaisir ça fait plaisir
d'avoir voilà donc c'est ça l'idée c'est
que personne ne soit Lézé donc voilà moi
je suis vraiment je suis ça vraiment de
manière assidue parce que ça me gêne un
petit peu sauf pour toi là ça me gêne
plus mais bon
la dernière ou pas
du coup parce que tu nous l'a annoncé
tout à l'heure je me suis dit ah bah moi
je pensais que c'était c'était une fois
que c'était bâché c'était bâché et du
coup là tu m'apprends que ça joue
peut-être
idem pour les vidéos de chaise 24 tout à
fait Anakin 97 11 le site chaise 24 ne
disparaîtra pas tant
que il y aura pas une solution de
trouver donc ne vous inquiétez pas
voilà vous inquiétez pas vous aurez
toujours un accès limité à toutes les
vidéos de chaise 24 et peut-être à mon
avis ce qui va se passer
c'est que ça va être un bon deal pour
les premières pièces 24 à mon avis c'est
qu'ils vont avoir un truc sur chaise.com
et donc ils ont ils ont encore plus de
service que pour ceux pour ce dont ils
avaient fait ce sera assez logique et ça
sera assez logique parce que
effectivement les streams se sont
arrêtés un petit peu comme ça quoi que
maintenant vous voyez il y a les streams
de et les stream ici donc voilà ça
continue aussi
et il y a une vraie une vraie volonté de
couvrir encore plus d'événements si j'ai
bien compris ce qu'on m'a dit en
français donc voilà donc on va quasiment
être sur tous les on va être sur tous
les grands tournois clairement
ça donne plus de poids encore
on peut l'imaginer au chaise comme effet
et tant mieux tout à fait super tout à
fait
et là on est bien embêté parce que tiens
peut-être que chaise comme fr peut nous
dire ou robinside est-ce que contre un
match est terminé au bout de trois
rondes on rappelle au niveau du scoring
maintenant qu'il y a 8,5
le Brasil même en scoran et on faisait
joga en faisant de Joga Bonito ne peut
pas revenir sur les 8 et demi à qui par
l'équipe d'Inde du coup ça fait mal et
est-ce que le dernier match va avoir
lieu pour pour finalement pas grand
chose
c'est pas impossible je peux pas dire au
niveau du format
ouais c'est un peu bizarre de les jouer
c'est un peu bizarre de pas les jouer
c'est les 200 bizarres en fait dans ce
genre de situation il y a 8 et demi
trois et demi donc tu jouais pour du
beurre ça rime à rien mais de pas jouer
aussi ça fait un score tu vois bizarre
qui fait pour le départage qui est pas
terrible donc je pense que ça va jouer
qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est quoi le
bruit là encore
ça pourrait peut-être
poser un peu les choses donc tu as
raison je pense qu'ils vont jouer juste
pour le côté des partages donc juste
c'est pas du tout franchement je demande
franchement un brief pour demain pour
demain vous aurez le Brive vous aurez
tout des caméras mais
je sais pas comment faire
je sais pas et dès que je vais dans un
attends je vais aller dans la salle des
discussions
en tout cas de chaise comme fr il écrit
très proprement logiquement sur la
devrait jouer mais je ne suis pas au
courant de ce détail en particulier
merci quand même faire pour ton aide
une nouvelle plateforme de jeu non mais
attends il nous fatigue sur ne fait pas
attention à ce XO s'il te plaît
j'essaie de comprendre comment les
autres font mais je pige pas
une petite il y a pas de petites
réactualisation de de calme à faire ou
quelque chose comme ça tu sais que mes
compétences sur le sujet sont limités
non mais là franchement c'est bizarre
leur truc je sais pas j'attends que
j'attends que que Nathan s'en occupe
après tout
alors est-ce qu'il y a une il sait ou
pas je sais ce qu'on va faire
me faire un don puisque potentiellement
je peux je peux modérer mais je l'ai
jamais fait un sur xosco donc fait moins
un petit don ça me suffira voilà
mais les vrais modaux c'est cheesecom
fress donc c'est Nathan et robinside ça
c'est les vrais modaux après de temps en
temps à ceux qui stream peuvent modérer
évidemment et Laurent nous a dit que
maintenant il n'était pas assez admin
alors là et non c'est un grand moment
vous inquiétez pas pour l'instant
le temps que j'apprenne à m'en servir
c'est exactement exactement il y a un
petit délai et moi je vais regarder si
le match reprend éventuellement je suis
pas sur les pièces de dire à visite
d'aller à l'interview j'ai l'impression
est-ce qu'on est est-ce que je suis seul
chaud à pas avoir les caméras bon ça ça
m'énerve mais bon tant pis pour
aujourd'hui les caméras ça fait un petit
un côté plus provincial à ce stream
Laurent
côté un peu plus convivial
ah merci chaos comme fr
qui va mettre mon IBAN et le numéro vert
c'est de choses comme fr qui vous
répondra en plus
voilà nickel on est tous d'accord
merci de chasse comme effet voilà tous
d'accord donc en tout cas alors ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que match plier en tout
cas peut-être une petite partie pour du
beurre et là tu t'attends à un gros
match parce que ton pote Magnus numéro 1
mondial il va avoir forte à faire quand
même parce que narrodite ski en face
c'est un des spécialistes spécialistes
pardon du Bullet des parties de Bliss en
règle générale du coup ça va être comme
assez intéressant attends tu peux
répéter spécialiste s'il te plaît
je dis quoi je dis quoi spécialiste du
Bullet et du Bleach je sais plus ah non
c'est bien ah d'accord ok
super match clairement entre évidemment
il est d'ailleurs je crois sur place
hein Magnus face à ouais l'expert un des
meilleurs joueurs du monde en tout cas
online en blitz c'est en Bullet surtout
narudit qui donc certainement j'imagine
que l'équipe on va voir les compos
j'imagine que les que les l'équipe de tu
vois on voit les Campos Charlotte Cobra
donc o'parin néanmar audit ski tu vois
peut-être une équipe une équipe
peut-être plus homogène chez nos amis
américains mais bon quand on a on a
Mbappé là on a Mbappé on a Mbappé chez
les chessbra donc Mbappe il peut marquer
un triplé hein même un quadruplé là ce
soir donc voilà c'est toujours le danger
peut-être c'est qui moins équilibré chez
chaise bras mais avec ce danger
permanent de Magnus Carlsen qui peut
marquer un point à chaque partie
donc ça va être passionnant à suivre
évidemment c'est à commence normalement
à 19h alors je me vengerai sur le rang
pour ma langue qui a fourché mais il
faut dire que bon techniquement je l'ai
quand même bien embêté aujourd'hui alors
il a le droit on lui fait un petit
plaisir et voilà vous avez l'équipe de
Magnus à l'instant
très très fort joueur
ouais alors là vous avez pas toujours
ensemble on le rappelle les règles
maximum 2500 donc c'est pas si facile en
fait
va vite
ils ont encore de la réserve nos amis
nos amis avec pets et vaichalie et les
Saint-Louis arche Bishop aussi avec Fabi
Fabiano carojana le joueur star de
l'équipe une équipe américaine
une équipe d'anglais brésiliens qu'on a
vu qui ont pris l'eau bon il y a pas
d'autres mots malheureusement
avec rullia qui était ma collègue au
sein de chaise 24 et 16 bras avec la
petite blague Carson et guérit qui sont
coéquipiers il en donne van forest
Jennifer you et là on voit les Charlotte
Cobra au Paris ski Jacobson
et paikidsé ouais donc ça joue ben on
verra on verra quel quel compon on
choisit les équipes je crois qu'on l'a
en fait en vrai mais bon moi je sais pas
ouais
donc voilà est-ce que ça joue la
quatrième ou pas pour l'instant ça joue
pas bien moi je crois que ça joue pas
de dire pour l'instant il y a pas de
relance question de 75 est-ce que
Laurent va jouer les titles tu osé
maintenant à acheter c'est non moi je
préfère peut-être en temps mais c'est
pas mon truc en délire mais je pense je
vais me faire un playing un playing de
du Tour
parce qu'après tout
enfin tu vois faut finir dans les 56
premiers Kevin bien sûr
sûrement entendu ça peut passer quand
même
tu as largement le niveau pot il faut
être juste une fois j'ai vu quelques
joueurs qui se sont qualifiés on attend
on voit on attend les nouvelles pour
l'instant je vois pas de ronde on en
saura évidemment sera mieux rodé au fil
de la saison au fil des rondes mais plus
en plus simple c'est chaque semaine
chaque semaine on a on a ces matchs là
ça va aller crescendo cette cette
proXess League un bel événement par
équipe exactement
alors moi je retrouverai demain soir
pour les deux matchs d'ailleurs et après
je laisserai la place à stouf que vous
connaissez très bien le mettre fixe
Stéphane Bressac et la semaine prochaine
l'orange serait pas avec toi puisque je
suis en stage à la montagne voilà je
sais pas si je serai là la semaine
prochaine
je ne savais pas
tout le temps maintenant ah ben non ah
ben non non non non je crois pas non non
même en fait tu vois non pas tout le
temps ah tu peux pas tu peux pas tu peux
pas trop de choses à faire mais tu seras
là très le match est terminé nous dit
Nathan d'accord je sais même pas
peut-être sûrement sûrement on verra
j'en sais rien
c'est toujours et c'est ce que je dis
moi-même voilà
beaucoup de bienveillance chez chaise
comme dans l'accueil mais c'est vrai que
là il y a beaucoup de choses qui se
passent et donc je suis pas eu
honnêtement j'ai pas eu le temps de
discuter le détail avec bien sûr
mais globalement quand tout le monde tu
vois et de bonne volonté il y a toujours
quelque chose de bien qui en ressort
bien sûr donc voilà bon bah
ce match prochaine Ligue c'est pas le
tata style avec des streams de 7 heures
voilà
et
sur la tension tu vas te prendre 600
secondes ça coûte combien alors
pas alors écoute voilà
donc
je te laisse y aller c'est ça et ben oui
Laurent mais qu'est-ce que tu vas faire
là parce que le prochain match dis-moi
Laurent il a 19h30
je vais rester et je vais faire
je vais faire des réglages je sais pas
ce que je vais faire parce que après si
je si je si j'arrête tout faut je
refasse un show YouTube et compagnie ça
marche pas est-ce que Nathan voudrait
pas me rejoindre
en fait ça me dérangerait pas de rester
avec l'autre chat mais le problème c'est
que il n'y a que sur xoslo qu'il anime
donc posez-nous vos questions
et chaque ça sert à quoi de prendre la
peau dit-on sur allez-y sur Chasen 4 je
vais je vais aller je vais je vais leur
parler si tu veux
après je vais me faire un peu de pub
comme on comme on fait parce que
l'auto pub avec avec stouf et les autres
streamers tu vois et dis-moi dis-moi
Kevin qu'est-ce que tu vas faire la
semaine prochaine à la montagne
je vais faire un stage je vais faire un
stage voilà avec des amateurs du jeu
d'échec voilà un stage que je propose
tous les ans à la montagne l'hiver l'été
voilà du coup c'est hyper convivial et
on en profite pour faire d'autres choses
comme du ski pour ceux qui aiment ou
d'autres choses doit tous les infos sur
mon site web d'ailleurs je vais vous
donner plein d'infos comme ça je vais me
faire un petit peu de pub Laurent en
train de faire tes petits réglages avant
que je parte et je vais faire une petite
pause de 5 minutes je dois avouer que là
vous voyez là Kevin en fait il a pendant
les stream il a pas l'air très sympa
mais en vrai dans la vraie vie dans la
vraie vie c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
une crème toujours je t'ai vu moi en
plus avec tes élèves pendant les stages
pendant les championnats de France
moi par deux ou trois qui pleuraient
dans un coin les autres étaient ravis
était ravi d'être là et revenez chaque
année je plaisante bien évidemment les
gens sont ravis ça joue au foot ça fait
du sport ça fait des échecs bien
évidemment mais c'est un truc c'est pas
l'ambiance quoi c'est ça l'idée ah oui
ça c'est pour les colos ah non mais les
coloss attention les stages adultes vous
serez pas obligé de faire du foot
d'accord mais en tout cas oui ben je
pense que bah il faut être bienveillance
est-ce que c'est un peu l'école
française quand même au niveau des
échecs d'apprendre mais mais dans la
bienveillance c'est pas une école qui
est dure au niveau du jeu on aime
apprendre
et faire progresser les joueurs qui
aiment cela et ça se fait assez
naturellement je pense qu'on a de la
chance de faire ce métier là pour
Laurent c'est un petit peu différent il
était à proprement parler joueur
professionnel et il tend maintenant à
faire des commentaires etc mais moi de
tout temps j'ai choisi de faire faire ce
métier là bah déjà parce que j'étais pas
assez assez fort comme joueur Laurent
tout le monde n'atteint pas facilement
les 2700 enfin même pour Laurent c'est
dur les 2700 c'est pas c'est pas si
facile à atteindre c'est beaucoup de
travail mais en tout cas moi je
m'épanouis en donnant des cours et des
stages et des conseils plus généralement
au jour amateur et c'est un grand
plaisir super donc voilà pour ce sujet
et on va laisser Laurent partir minutes
et après je vais vous donner plein plein
de de bons conseils si vous voulez je
reviens je reviens merci
Laurent alors je vais vous donner pas
mal d'infos pour ceux que ça intéresse
si vous voulez progresser maintenant
j'ai mis en place une plateforme de
cours en ligne et je vais directement
vous donner le lien si ça vous intéresse
de me rejoindre il y a un petit cadeau
de bienvenue il y en a qui sont déjà
inscrits il y a quand même pas mal de
monde il y a déjà plusieurs centaines de
personnes qui sont inscrites sur la
plateforme c'est un gros gros succès
pour le lancement donc n'hésitez pas à
nous rejoindre et aller voir tout
simplement si ça vous intéresse il y a
un petit cadeau de bienvenue donc voilà
je vous mets directement
vous êtes au moins deux ce week sur Oslo
donc voilà je vous ai mis le petit lien
donc du coup c'est facile pour vous de
me rejoindre pareil j'ai un site web qui
présente vraiment toutes mes activités
donc là faites-vous plaisir hop vous
avez
tout ça directement
bah au niveau des échecs le touns alors
je trouve quand même
qu'on a plutôt une bonne école alors
dans le sens j'ai parlé de bienveillance
on est vraiment pas
alors pas que je le dise j'ai pas envie
de dénigrer les les autres écoles
d'autres pays il y en a qui qui
travaille les échecs dans d'autres pays
qui le font très bien mais je pense
qu'en tout cas on a une école basée sur
le plaisir et c'est important j'en avais
parlé par rapport aux joueurs de haut
niveau que l'on voit
j'ai vu par exemple Jules Moussard le
champion de France en titre évolué quand
il était tout jeune je pense qu'il a
beaucoup plus travaillé les échecs sur
le tard qu'il a eu un investissement
vraiment là sur sur les dernières années
qui est très fort
pour moi c'est parce qu'il a su garder
la passion du jeu il a su rythme il a
pas fait un travail de dingue en étant
forcé tout petit parce que c'était un
hyper talent et je trouve que c'est la
bonne méthode en tout cas si on veut
durer dans une discipline il faut
travailler mais il faut que ça soit
juste voilà donc faut pas faut pas
bourriner voilà le toons ma notion bah
il y a pas de souci sur X Oslo mon libre
stream libre voilà mais en tout cas ça
c'est vraiment une notion une notion
intéressante et donc je parlais de ça
donc il y a la plateforme de cours en
ligne le site internet et vous pouvez me
rejoindre sur twitch et YouTube il y a
plein de choses qui sont qui sont
gratuites donc donc c'est quand même
tranquille
je réponds en même temps aux petites au
petit mot
du coup bah voilà vous avez vous avez
déjà pas mal d'éléments et si vous avez
envie dans le chat de décrire un petit
peu votre profil et me poser des
questions en tant que coach aux échecs
je fais ça depuis 15 ans donc j'ai vu
des profils je vous dis de mille et
l'eau c'est à dire que j'ai commencé en
tant qu'entraîneur a donné des cours
dans les écoles j'avais aussi quelques
élèves en cours particuliers et derrière
j'ai petit à petit arrêté mon travail
dans les écoles pour me concentrer sur
le travail à proprement parler
d'entraîneur avec l'entraînement des
amateurs on va dire aller les élèves que
je peux avoir le niveau en règle
générale minimum c'était plutôt 1200
hello et après jusqu'à 2350 vélos en
général j'ai toujours eu des élèves un
peu plus faibles que moi même à la fin
il y a certains élèves qui auraient pu
me dépasser
souvent ça a été assez corrélé avec le
fait qu'il rentrait dans les études
supérieures et du coup ils ont mis en
pause en veilleuse les échecs et c'est
un petit peu dommage c'est pas facile il
faut un investissement de tous les
instants du coup pour à la fois
poursuivre des hautes études et en même
temps continuer l'activité échec c'est
quand même un petit peu un petit peu
compliqué et la lex ça arrive tout de
suite
en fait du coup à partir de 19h il y a
un nouveau match là le premier match en
fait il s'est fini un petit peu plus tôt
que prévu
si tu veux avec finalement une équipe
d'Inde puisque elle est à
majoritairement composé
de forts indiens à écraser l'équipe
brésilienne donc pour l'instant
difficile
difficile de continuer voilà je pensais
très honnêtement un peu comme en Coupe
Davis pour ceux qui connaissent le
format au tennis à l'époque quand il y
avait un match pour du beurre il
raccourcissait un petit peu la durée là
ils n'ont même pas fait ça je pensais
que pour le départage aussi Laurent nous
en parlait que ça avait un intérêt non
ils prennent juste les points de match
donc du coup pas pas d'intérêt
particulier de continuer et maintenant
va arriver pour ceux que ça intéresse le
très très gros match avec l'équipe de
Magnus Carlsen contre l'équipe de
narroditeci donc l'équipe de Magnus elle
est composée de joueurs comme Guy et
autres donc favorite on rappelle quand
même que si la cadence est 10 + 2 et que
ça amène donc plus de variance ben le
fait est que on peut pas dépasser en
cumul de points lots les 2500 en moyenne
il y a une féminine par équipe
obligatoire voilà tous les conditions
requises pour pouvoir participer à ce
type de match
c'est intéressant c'est comment qu'ils
ont choisi les équipes bah dites le moi
parce que c'est la première fois que
j'anime les stream project League c'est
une nouveauté et du coup je disais ça se
trouve j'aurais bien fait j'aurais bien
fait une équipe l'an prochain mais je
pense que c'est pas si facile il y a un
système de division etc ne fait pas la
pros Ligue qui veut je suis pas sûr
qu'il y a un système de calife mais
peut-être que chaise comme fr peut nous
répondre dans le chat qu'il Alex toi par
exemple tu avais envie de faire le
tournoi est-ce que c'est possible bon la
division 1 là comme on le voit ça semble
difficile mais
du coup c'est
ok bah le toune pourquoi pas
un cheescom sur dossier plus ou moins
pour 15 équipes et la 16e a gagné sa
place en qualif ok merci Robin side
et je suis à toi de retour et Laurent
alors regarde ce que tu vas faire avant
de partir mon cher je vais faire un truc
incroyable j'ai l'impression tu vas
faire un truc incroyable
ont été la vidange de Laurent mais ce X
Dosso et il vient il est intime avec toi
il a failli croire qu'il a un type avec
moi
c'est toujours plus d'intimité d'un côté
que de l'autre c'est toujours comme
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est
bon ce jour de Saint-Valentin ce que tu
nous dis
[Rires]
est-ce que tu crois
on va faire les relations sont jamais
équilibré mon cher Kévin par exemple
c'est bon
parlez-nous d'amour
je t'adore
et toi tu fais semblant de m'adorer
tu sais bien c'est toujours un plaisir
partagé et d'ailleurs ça fait longtemps
qu'on n'a pas fait un petit week-end
sympa c'est vrai parce que on fait des
week-ends
à Arcachon là
le braquage le braquage on n'était pas
malheureux on peut dire on était pas
malheureux tu t'es tu t'y es fait assez
vite on a bien rigolé on a un peu trop
chambré notre ami en commun d'ailleurs
un moment il est toujours
et dur avec ça
ouais tu parlais tu parlais des
relations déséquilibrée équilibré voilà
on n'en dira pas plus parce que sinon ça
se retournera encore contre nous on
rappelle c'est à 19h à la prochaine
match je vais tout de suite passer on va
faire une transition regarde ça hop là
et des caméras non regarde regarde
Charlotte Cobra regarde est-ce que tu
vois que il y a l'équipe des Charlotte
Cobra mais j'ai pas les kits d'énormes
Charlotte Cobra donc il y a un vendeur
Yang qui est titularisé Daniel Hardy ski
bramson Jacobson vraiment on dirait une
équipe de basketball je vous le dis hein
champion du monde il a déjà été champion
du monde jeune donc
je pense que il va être hyper chaud
et par contre j'ai pas l'autre équipe
alors ça c'est hyper bizarre je vais me
remettre en mode en mode studio si tu
m'en veux pas mon cher mon cher Kévin
mais je ne vois pas la compo la compo
des chaises bras où il y a Magnus Carsen
ça c'est une certitude
mais
on ne sait pas on ne sait pas les autres
les autres vont arriver certainement ils
vont être annoncés en tout cas ça va
être un très très beau match écoute
c'est je vais te laisser peut-être
vaquer à tes bien sûr bien sûr Laurent
moi je te souhaiter bon courage c'est un
grand plaisir d'animer ce premier match
de te lancer en fait de lancer la saison
et maintenant tu vas avoir un gros gros
match à commenter on va se retrouver
demain mon cher Laurent avec grand
plaisir et là cette fois-ci je serai là
pour les deux matchs je n'avais pas
d'invitation donc peut être avec toi
tout le temps voilà et du coup ça me
fera grand plaisir de te retrouver pour
commenter tout ça et bénéficier de ton
expertise sur toutes les positions si
j'apprends plein de trucs donc
c'est vrai que tu as bien aimé j'ai
l'impression le moment où je te disais
qu'avec le centre fermé il fallait jouer
sur les ailes ça ça t'a beaucoup servi
et du coup ça te fait progresser les
rancomposer aussi je pense que tu as
bien aimé oui oui j'ai adoré non mais
c'était intéressant c'était magnifique
merci merci
mon cher Kevin
bonne soirée tu vois tu vois l'énorme
gagner ou Magnus Carlson tu sens que
c'est le
ben je pense
que ça va être un match serré parce que
à wander nerudite ski c'est très très
fort Brandon Jacobson je peux dire je
connais pas et une accroche je connais
et du coup les deux têtes d'affiches de
l'équipe c'est hyper fort ça peut
rivaliser avec n'importe quel père sur
les deux premiers d'accord ça va être un
beau match en tout cas on va voir le
champion
son entrée en pisse je te remercie
infiniment pour tout ton expertise ta
bonne humeur et le reste mon cher Kevin
on se retrouve dès demain 16h30 pour de
nouvelles aventures des bisous à toi
salut à tout le monde bonne soirée bye
bye et moi je reste et regardez imagine
ta technique je teste je te laisse faire
le reste à la technique
ouais mono-sen regarde hop mono sc
[Musique]
bien salut il est toujours pas parti non
non je me dis que je peux t'embêter en
fait personne me demande
une petite blague en fait
génial ta blague tout le monde a entendu
salut salut
je pense que vous avez entendu je pense
que vous avez entendu
Kevin qui partait dites moi si c'est pas
le cas mais je mon expertise me dit que
vous l'avez entendu donc on voit les
chaises branches c'est pas pourquoi il y
a pas les chaises Brown en entier là je
vois pas si tu m'écoutes mon cher Nathan
n'hésite pas
ouais vous avez entendu ouais évidemment
évidemment que vous avez entendu on va
voir donc on va changer tout ça aussi on
va changer les les noms évidemment des
des équipes avec les chaises Brad d'un
côté Magnus Carson
est-ce que je le répèteerais
assez face au Charlotte Cobra et ça
c'est beau et ça c'est beau Charlotte
Cobra donc évidemment celui qu'on va
suivre
celui qu'on va suivre bien ça sera en
priorité évidemment le
le quintup champion du monde de partie
classique le triple champion du monde
actuel champion du monde de parti
classique rapide et Blitz si ce type de
champion du monde de Bleach je crois 4
de partir rapide ou alors peut-être 5 je
sais plus mais en fait tellement il
gagne tellement il est énorme évidemment
Magnus Carsen on va évidemment le suivre
en priorité parce que on attend c'est
comme c'est comme voilà c'est c'est le
meilleur joueur du monde de très loin il
a encore gagné la semaine dernière
le tournoi qui avait lieu sur cheesecom
qui est le champion de chaise tour
voilà où il y aura il y aura six tournoi
je crois tout au long de l'année avec
des divisions comme vous avez pu le
suivre un nouveau format très
intéressant il faut perdre deux fois
pour être éliminé donc voilà ça laisse
moins de chance c'est moins de place au
hasard et ça favorise quand ça laisse
moins de place au hasard et bien ça
favorise les meilleurs joueurs et donc
c'est pas une grosse surprise de voir
Magnus Carlson qui a remporté ce tournoi
sans perdre un seul de ces matchs avec
notamment cette performance d'avoir
d'avoir
15 minutes
l'Armageddon se joue en 15 minutes pour
les blancs et il y a une on fait des
enchères évidemment des enchères cachés
avec les avec les noirs ou en fait c'est
le plus petit la plus petite offre
va prendre les Noirs c'est-à-dire que
par exemple si un joueur dit 11000 écrit
11 minutes et l'autre écrit 10 et bien
c'est celui qui a écrit 10 qui va
prendre les noirs et 10 minutes et qui a
évidemment la nul comme victoire en fait
c'est à dire que la nul et qui vaut à
une un gain de match et donc manuscrite
Nakamura a mis 859 voilà en disant si
Magnus met neuf comme ça c'est moi qui
les noirs et manuscrit Arsen a mis 8-58
ce qui était assez énorme voilà donc il
est tous les deux décidé que c'était 9
minutes Magnus avait compris que c'était
9 minutes le cut voilà en fait le truc
juste ils étaient d'accord sur ça
mais en l'occurrence il s'est dit que
hikaro allait faire ce 859 pour voilà on
sait jamais pour ce 9 minutes
voilà pour faire si Magnus mette 9
minutes mettez 859 mais en fait manus
avait un coup d'avance et a fait 858
Magnus a fait nul même s'il était en
difficulté
et on va voir tout ça et je vais faire
la transition
j'arrête le mode studio et voilà on voit
Magnus car cette fois-ci non on va
mettre qui il va jouer contre qui Magnus
je pense qu'il va jouer contre
en avance vous voyez il y a plein de
trucs c'est toujours le premier jour
c'est toujours compliqué
on sait pas trop voilà on sait pas trop
comment ça se passe et donc là il y a
plein de choses qui sont à peu près
claires pour moi que je peux pas régler
vraiment en direct mais
on verra on verra
sur 75 ça j'en sais rien est-ce que
est-ce qu'on aura le plaisir de revoir
Jules
je n'en sais absolument rien
très honnêtement
donc voilà on attend les gens n'hésitez
pas à poser vos questions il reste trois
minutes et à 3 minutes avant le début je
crois j'espère
je vais te rejoindre par Nathan je crois
je l'espère
voilà qui va me
il y a peut-être me driver au niveau du
zoom
peut-être pas pour aujourd'hui en tout
cas
mais voilà
j'attends la question avec impatience
les petites caresses c'est fini non moi
j'y vais régulièrement
n'hésitez pas à évolution échec allez
voir son site je fais de la pub même
quand il est pas là
et donc
il est il est très sympa il est très
sympa avec sa team très pro qui est
interrieux donc voilà et puis bon
d'ambiance donc c'est quand même ça
l'essentiel avec ses colos notamment moi
je connais pas les stages pour adultes
mais j'ai vu les colos voilà donc
n'hésitez pas
à envoyer vos enfants s'ils aiment les
échecs ou vous-même apparemment des
stages pour des
pour des grands est-ce que je peux
rappeler le fonctionnement du tournoi oh
là c'est beau c'est beau c'est beau
merci dark people
c'est génial et oui évidemment qu'il
faut que je prépare ça c'est les équipes
ça c'est les scores 8 et demi trois et
demi et on voit voilà et Charlotte
chaise bras
et il manque il manque les chaises c'est
bien ça
attendez le truc mais j'arrive pas
j'arrive pas à être le truc
et non j'arrive pas j'arrive pas
j'arrive pas ok donc on a pas la compo
des
trucs donc le format regardez donc ça
c'est les appareils man avec Magnus
Carlsen qui arrive
qui arrive tout de suite demeure on aura
de très beaux matchs très probablement
les passeurs je crois que c'est l'équipe
de Fabiano Carana jeudi c'est le point
d'orgue avec l'équipe française qui fait
son entrée en lice dans la compète
et
ensuite
une au minimum et
ensuite comment ça marche si il y a des
tailles breaks et bien les quatrième
échiquier s'affrontent en inversant les
couleurs cadence 3 + 2 les quatrième
shaky ou les quatre échiquier ça je sais
pas en cas de nul et joueurs rejouent
couleur inversé peut-être le 4e nouvelle
nul les joueurs inversé couleur bref ça
peut durer jusqu'à pas de
donc on a ça et ensuite
la moyenne règle des compos la moyenne
ne peut pas dépasser 2550
non c'est 2500 c'est 2500 les joueurs
pour casser à plus de 2700 compte comme
2700 joueurs les joueuses classés plus
de 2350 comme 2350 compte comme des 2350
des joueurs classés moins 2002 comptent
comme 2002
et non il n'y a plus de alors est-ce que
c'est 2500 ou 2550 sachant je pense que
c'est 2500 plutôt je pense que ce truc
est faux
de
ici
ici c'est faux je pensais 2550
je pense que c'est faux je pense que
c'est 2500 mais bon après
alors et non justement Magnus c'est une
très bonne affaire parce qu'il compte
comme un 2700 donc c'est ça la bonne
affaire
c'est quoi les clubs d'échecs les plus
grands politiques historiques aux échecs
en France et dans le monde équivalent
d'un PSG - Real Madrid - Bayern Munich
alors ouais ça dépend il y a pas de il y
a Baden-Baden en Allemagne qui est un
très grand club
il y a il y a une Nao à l'époque qui a
été double champion d'Europe un club
parisien qui a été double champion
d'Europe tout le monde ne le sait pas
mais
c'était c'était au début des années 2000
c'était très
bah très bien pour les échecs français
ça nous aidait beaucoup j'en ai j'en ai
profité aussi
qui s'est trouvé de la compagnie tiens
je sens que tu es un humour similaire au
mien ouais c'est rare les gens qui ont
le même humour que toi quand même celui
que ce soit à mon avis
donc ouais est-ce qu'il y a des grands
clubs il y a moins il y a moins quand
même parce que
il y a moins de grands clubs honnêtement
c'est plus en général vu qu'il y a moins
de spectateurs aux échecs c'est plus en
général la volonté d'une personne
plutôt que d'une institution voilà c'est
un peu triste et Clichy justement et une
exception dans tout ce que je dis Clichy
avec ses 15 sites de champion de France
avec ces
nombreux salariés qui donnent
des cours dans les écoles ils ont tout
cliché ils ont le haut niveau et
la masse elle commence qu'à la rendre
normalement elle commence à 19h donc là
ça devrait pas tarder il est 19h03 mais
vous voyez
maintenant on est parti devraient pas
tarder à arriver
j'espère en tout cas au revoir Magnus
normalement
on espère voir Magnus en tout cas
je pense que ça va ça va pas tarder mais
c'est toujours un petit retard allumage
c'est normal c'est le premier jour c'est
la première ronde donc c'est pas non
plus c'est pas non plus un scandale
une longue histoire ça c'est sûr essayer
d'ailleurs le club recordman de type de
champion de France c'est pas un hasard
mais c'est vrai que c'est rare c'est
clubs là qui qui arrive à
survivre même au changement parce que
c'est un club financé par par la
municipalité même au changement de voilà
ça prouve qu'ils ont vraiment réussi
tout seul grand personnage tu as vu
l'histoire est en route du côté de
Bischwiller
histoire est en route avec quatre je
crois 4 ou 5 types de champion de France
pour bjv c'est ça commence à être pas
mal avec des équipes de jeunes
on va voir mais c'est vrai que ça a pas
le même historique que Clichy ça c'est
sûr
même si pas dans l'intérêt de dire ça
j'ai joué j'ai joué avec Youtube mais
maintenant je joue je joue pour
nos amis de biche
Bischwiller champion de France en titre
donc on va voir
on va voir non il y a pas de partie pour
l'instant
donc Magnus c'est ce qui serait pas en
retard après Manu il peut être en retard
ça c'est quand même c'est la spéciale on
le connaît on le sait que c'est dans ses
cordes d'être en retard
et j'ai pas de nouvelles de Nathan
bon pas de nouvelles bonne nouvelle
il est sur la route a priori je me
connecter sur le slack de la piscine
je sais pas
je sais pas en tout cas belle victoire
des Indiens dans le premier match
salut les potes ah ça fait plaisir
de voir donc je le répète encore une
fois
n'hésitez pas si vous êtes en train de
nous regarder sur youtube Chase 24 en
français n'hésitez pas à aller sur
cheescom en français
et
si vous êtes sur en français n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner à la chaîne Youtube
pour ne rien rater des choses à mettre
un petit pouce bleu ça fait toujours
plaisir
donc
allez-y à part les compétitions
cette année 10 choc choc 75 je ne crois
pas Laurent ne va pas jouer par de lieu
à la 3e personne et Laurent ne va pas
jouer d'autres compétitions j'ai bien
peur que je fasse trop de choses par
ailleurs je crois que 75 j'ai un peu
perdu la niaque pour aller jouer des
pour jouer des compètes très honnêtement
des Open ou ce genre de choses et comme
je suis plus invité des droits fermés et
bien je boude
peut-être des rapides des rapides et des
Blitz ça me plaît ça me plaît plus ça
c'est moins long donc c'est plus adapté
une fatigue moins vite je m'agace moins
et moins longtemps
et donc voilà
mais voilà si j'ai une belle invitation
je sais pas si j'ai une belle invitation
pourquoi pas j'ai failli aller au
championnat d'Europe individuel pour
tout vous avouer
mais je me suis dégonflé au dernier
moment
voilà le championnat d'Europe individuel
qui commence en
[Musique]
en mars Laurent va-t-il sortir un cours
sur une certaine plateforme disposant un
certain module entraînement et oui tu
parles de chelseables à l'époque je suis
en retard je suis à la bourre ça
n'avance pas tout seul c'est très dur
c'est court chez sébble il sera
magnifique mon compte chez ces vols je
vous garantis que ça va être ça va être
de la qualité
l'inconvénient c'est qu'on sait pas on
sait pas quand ça va quand ça va sortir
c'est ça c'est ça le c'est ça qui est
dommage n'hésite pas à Florent je compte
sur toi pour me dire quand elle est
partie ont commencé mais pour l'instant
moi j'ai rien je vais faire un petit
coup de refresh parce qu'on sait jamais
ça marche pas de pain mais je ne crois
pas non je suis sur la bonne page et ça
ne commence pas il y a un peu de retard
ça coince sur la lapine époque non ça
coince rien moi le problème c'est que
voilà alors qu'est-ce que c'est et bien
c'est ça fait partie du groupe les
Magnus donc ça fait maintenant partie du
groupe Chess.com donc chez sebul
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est voilà des
heures et des heures de des lives time
répertoire moi c'est ce que je suis en
train de faire celui-là schnikov et donc
en fait il faut expliquer chaque coup à
tout le monde donc l'idée c'est vraiment
de faire un cours entre
à partir de 1400 voilà jusqu'à 2000
voilà et d'expliquer bien chaque coup
voilà de regarder chaque possibilité
possible chaque possibilité possible
pour chaque possibilité adverse
et évidemment ça prend énormément de
temps et comme je fais pas mal de choses
je peux être parfois un petit peu
paresseux
surtout sur ça ça m'amuse pas ouais
c'est le la recherche de coups voyez
mais m'amuse mais après expliquer chaque
coup je trouve c'est trop alors c'est
bien pour le viewer mais pour moi c'est
très détaillé quand même ça peut trop
détailler enfin bon je
m'amuse mais voilà sans
[Musique]
ben c'est pas facile les cours c'est
pour ça qu'ils sortent il y a beaucoup
de joueurs qui qui les sortent en retard
parce que c'est c'est un boulot auquel
on n'est pas habitué parce qu'en fait
la partie de Yang a commencé ok merci
je l'ai pas
je l'ai pas je vais la voir j'espère ah
je l'ai
14 février ok je l'ai
donc on a alliant à vendeur contre
Jennifer you qui joue pour les chats
on va mettre
là
[Musique]
on va mettre Jennifer you
voilà donc c'est pas du tout on n'est
pas habitué à ça parce que normalement
on fait des notes pour nous et donc en
fait les notes pour nous elles sont
elles sont moins détaillées et tout
simplement parce que évidemment quand on
a fait le travail déjà et bien on sait
on met pas des commentaires à foison et
donc voilà ça ça crée une petite
confusion à ce niveau là
c'est comme ça c'est pas très grave mais
c'est intéressant quand même de tenter
de nouvelles choses alors qu'est-ce qui
se passe dans cette partie et bien on a
eu des quatre cavaliers F6 c'est 4 6
cavalier F3 D5 ou là j'ai le bruit fort
là vous avez le bruit de l'échiquier
fort et c'est 3
parce que ça va pas du tout
fou j'ai 5 et 6 et E3 bon on a une
structure carsbad alors qu'est-ce que
c'est la structure carsback c'est la
structure C6 des 5 contre la structure
E3 D4 c'est la structure archi classique
des grands vides alors évidemment ça
donne une légère majorité centrale au
blanc vous voyez il y a ce 4 contre 3 ou
ce 5 contre
qui a exploité donc on va essayer
peut-être éventuellement de créer une
attaque à
le roi mais on va sortir ces pièces
comme ça fout des trois ça c'est
vraiment
hyper hyper standard on va essayer
d'échanger des pièces avec les Noirs
peut-être à un moment jouer cavalier 4
rock d'abord et on peut commencer soit
par damser de soi par petit rock
damso est normalement plus normal elle
joue petit rock pour me contredire il y
a pas de problème et on a d'autres
parties qui commencent
on a un Magnus Carcen face à Irina crush
on voit Magnus Carson qui est là mais
qui n'a pas commencé sa partie Ariane
tarif face à Brandon narutzky le
streamer américain
face à prêt autour Ravez
je vais enlever je vais enlever tout ça
parce que en fait les noms ça ne va pas
ça ne va pas parce que ça change tout le
temps
et on va mettre ça du coup en plus grand
dans cette prochaine Ligue et on va voir
le début entre narrodisky donc qui
représente l'équipe américaine de
Charlots Cobra face à
préau razzane que je connais pas je dois
avouer qui vient d'être un joueur
canadien
et qui a de savoir ce qu'il fait écoutez
ça peut être dangereux ce genre de truc
avec une attaque on voit ce qui en F7
qui est quand même
en difficulté ouais ça fait chier 1
versus 4 puis voilà
inversus 3 versus 2 et inverseus 1 donc
on aura un choc
carcassienne à la troisième partie mais
bon là c'est déjà pas mal ce qu'on ce
qu'on voit et on va voir évidemment
Magnus Carson qui est noir qui joue une
instinienne face à Irina crush et il
joue la petite sous variante on voit des
quatre cavaliers F6 C4 G6 et c'est 3 fou
G7 E4 D6
et E5 on a évité le dépanne 5 novembre
d'échanges et cette petite variante avec
C6 alors intéressant il veut évidemment
jouer pour gagner il a elle a 2432 Irina
crush tandis que Magnus Carsen a 2852
soit 420 points des cas bon évidemment
évidemment qui joue la gagne Magnus et
déjà qui joue à gagne en temps normal
alors là quand il a autant autant
d'avance au niveau du hello et bien
c'est il va pas se priver
donc
[Musique]
voilà bon j'arrive pas à trouver les
noms des joueurs des chaises bras mais
on va les découvrir petit à petit
évidemment
Manu ça donc beaucoup de beaucoup de
points
je peux enlever même mes écouteurs
et on va même enlever ça
le temps
que
quelqu'un d'autre arrive peut-être que
ça va monter du coup
alors et petit rock E5 elle joue la
vente avec vous trois mais puis on prend
qu'elle prend tout revête elle s'est
fait avoir déjà il y a une accroche par
Magnus Carson F3 il y a des 5 et
maintenant le fou en le 3 est mal placé
si on est obligé de faire ça dame c'est
deux dames 7 et oui un petit on voit un
Magnus attention alors parfois il a une
mauvaise réputation dans les ouvertures
mais il est quand même il connaît les
ordres de coup il sait ce qu'il fait
malgré
S qui compte oui tout à fait fantômes à
après ça pourrait ça pourrait être les
lots rapides
mais bon
et merci
je te flagorne Ré
des 5 et maintenant c'est une très bonne
version ça pour les Noirs quoi que c'est
pas complètement sûr qui est vraiment
apprécié prank cavalier prend puis on
prend vous B5 il me semble j'ai déjà vu
une ligne comme ça mais ça ça a amené
énormément d'échanges
pourquoi le fouet mal placé et bien
parce qu'il se trouve mon cher époque il
se trouve il se trouve normalement que
normalement on veut jouer comme ça je
vais vous montrer si on veut jouer à la
ligne avec vous trois voilà une ligne
comme ça qui existe
tout 8 F3 C6 et en l'occurrence on fait
fou F2 pour empêcher pour pouvoir
prendre sur des seins et puis voilà ça
c'est la ligne c'est une ligne très très
connue et il se trouve qu'avec ces 6 en
fait elle a voulu faire pareil petit
rock 5 x 3 cette ligne avec faux 3 mais
puis on prend qu'elle prend pour 8 F3
des 5 maintenant on a un problème on
peut pas reprendre comme ça pourtant
c'est ce qu'on aimerait faire on
aimerait puis on prend il faut F2 et si
on fait fou F2 ici et puis on prend le 4
donc ça ne va pas donc elle s'est faite
un petit peu avoir dans l'ouverture mais
le truc c'est que quand on se fait avoir
dans ce genre de système mais c'est pas
très grave parce que normalement ça
reste quand même assez équilibré mais là
il y a 7 minutes contre 9,50 attention à
ne pas se mettre mal au temps contre
Magnus Carson c'est suffisamment
difficile comme ça il faut faire très
très attention et contrôler la pendule
parce que ça peut ça peut tourner ça
peut tourner au vinaigre assez vite
donc on va voir on va voir mais là Erina
crush on va voir 2432 ce qui est carré
qui est quand même reste au niveau très
très
respectable évidemment
et on voit un Magnus a déjà qui commence
à être avec 4 minutes de plus il y a
aussi Laura Magnus Carlsen
le
champion du monde c'est ça là on
travaille pour sa réputation et ensuite
ça aurait la réputation travaille pour
lui
c'est toujours un peu comme ça
donc
et c'est pour ça qu'elle prend beaucoup
de temps là vous voyez 4 minutes ça va
pas déjà en plus c'est une variante
connu je vous disais ici du coup c'est
fou des cinq je suis quasiment certain
et de mémoire voyez c'est ma mémoire me
dit c'est que c'est 6 mais ça marche pas
du tout cassis ok prends et puis on
prend faut prends ces 6 donc ça doit
être sous des 7 ici il faut prendre à me
prendre et on a toujours ce même
problème sur ce pur est-ce que ça serait
pas dame B3 moi je pense que c'est ça la
théorie et en fait l'idée de mp3 c'est
quoi c'est qu'on va on va faire pression
sur ce pion F7 avec la toux avec la dame
et donc du coup
[Musique]
je vais mettre là l'écran
et donc du coup on va
attaquer sur F7 on va contre-attaquer
sur F7 donc vous voyez si on prend ici
et puis on prend et ensuite attention
les yeux tout le monde joue il y a un
pion isolé certes mais on a beaucoup de
dynamisme pour le compenser donc on va
voir ce qu'elle fait elle fait roche ok
ça marche c'est discutable à mon avis
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe sur pion
prend quel est le plan kb5 peut-être
pour aller là pour menacer ou pardon
pour menacer à me prendre des 8 et KS et
C7 c'est bien c'est pas possible avec
cette petite fourchette qui peut arriver
c'est peut-être ça l'idée alors ce qu'on
a on a d'autres options arrivé noir on
peut jouer aussi qui est ici
tranquillement sortir ses pièces sur
cahiers français 6 on est content on a
renversé on a renforcé notre centre on
peut mais on peut prendre un cadre
ça peut être pas mal
on va voir ce que la décider Magnus
Carson qui est évidemment en train de
calculer tout ce que je vous ai expliqué
alors peut-être qu'il va sortir un coup
de son chapeau aussi ça c'est pas
complètement
impossible alors normalement je regarde
un petit peu toutes les parties époques
mais là bon quand même Magnus quand même
hein on regarde beaucoup ma nu non
j'aime bien regarder Magnus
alors roche qu'est-ce qu'il a joué
Magnus il a joué qui est ici je vous en
parler de ce coup et ouais on se casse
pas la tête
c'est pas mal j'aime bien j'aime bien
cahier C6 on ramène une belle position
alors sur foubet5 il faut voir ce qu'on
fait mais je pense qu'on peut jouer
fouder 7 tout simplement on peut
toujours pas prendre c'est toujours très
très embêtant et à ce fond 3 qui est en
prise
donc ça ne va pas
ouais elle est partie vont vite quand
même donc c'est compliqué toutes les
suivantes si la partie est quand même un
minimum intéressante on va on va on va
on va rester sur Magnus
et voir ce qui fait
et là regardez 4 37 pour Irina crush
attention multiple champion des
États-Unis attention grosse cliente il y
a une accroche
pas du tout une débutante
fout des quatre ouais je m'en doutais un
petit peu pour essayer de changer les
fous et c'est pas mal joué mais est-ce
qu'on perdrait pas un pion là
prend on va tout simplement faire dame
prend pour prendre et puis on prend et
ça devrait aller mais quoi que faut 6
c'est noir reste mieux hein tour des
deux mais les chances de nul alors
attention attention comment on va faire
Magnus ici pour garder la tension c'est
ça maintenant le l'objectif de Magnus
c'est de garder de la tension dans la
position de garder des pièces c'est
d'être un petit peu mieux si possible
pas si évident
pas si évident alors est-ce qu'on peut
faire ça ça
me semble un peu risqué on reprend on va
prendre et puis on prend et maintenant
tu reprends ok peut-être que c'est ça
mais il faut F3 vous voyez je suis quand
même assez actif je contre-attaque ici
surtout aussi je vais faire tourner 8 il
y a du jeu j'aime pas trop ça
ok donc on va voir ce qu'il va faire et
manuscritsen il a pris en décape j'en
parlais de ça dame prend des 4 ils
traînent pas en tout cas et il joue plus
on prend le 4 et sur dame prend des 8 il
va juste reprendre des 8 et sur pion
prend le 4 il va faire fout aussi je
vous donne en mille autour des deux non
tour des deux il faut aussi je vois
tempo je vous en parler il l'a fait faut
aussi évidemment tourner deux peut être
très tentant de s'infiltrer avec la tour
on attaque de pions on attaque le fou et
le pion mais il y a fou ces quatre
contre-attaques sur le pur F7 on va être
obligé d'échanger et c'est pas un bon de
c'est pas bon du d'échanger tout ça
on est content on se fout est un monstre
aussi donc c'est pour ça que faut aussi
doit être joué et fou si ça a été joué
très rapidement parmi scarsen et
attention là on est mû en monastère des
deux on peut pas trop faire tourner à
mon avis parce que tu reprends et
attention aux petits pions
on a le droit d'aller manger le petit
pion
donc faut faire très attention ici avec
pour Irina
et la crush qui habitait à Paris un
moment salut Mister pesto je crois
qu'elle étudier
je sais pas ce qu'elle faisait à Paris
mais elle étudier elle a joué pour
Clichy aussi on en parlait tout à
l'heure donc elle parle français
elle parle français invité je sais pas
un an ou deux à Paris
il y a un petit moment maintenant
donc comment on fait et bien Irina ça
peut être évident elle a joué B3
tourner est arrivé et 3 c'est 5 mais que
c'est passif tout ça maintenant à 5 à 4
va arriver à leur tour c'est un
contre-attaque ici voilà bien raison et
Tours C8 il va quand même faire son plan
avec K5 il a tout mis sur noir Magnus
Carl c'est le métier le métier du Grand
Magnus
ça va être ça va être compliqué
ouais j'ai remarqué face welo inférieur
et Manu ça aime bien simplifier jouer
sur les petites fesses des adversaires
mais là il était pas vraiment un choix
de sa part il joue une instinienne donc
c'est quand même c'est comme une
ouverture très compliqué mais la façon
dont tu as joué Irina il joue quand même
de manière correcte c'est à dire qu'il
cherche pas à compliquer
outre mesure si il pense pas que ça soit
nécessaire il essaie de jouer de manière
disons
objectivement bonne voilà de jouer des
bons coups
donc
ça va beaucoup l'aider de parler
français là oui tout à fait époque
H4 jouer alors ce que ça serait pas une
autre faiblesse parfois il y a des H5
ouais bon pourquoi pas H4 maintenant
comment on fait pour améliorer notre
position et maintenant est-ce qu'on fait
ces quatre ou pas est-ce que c'est
l'heure de ces quatre
je sais pas qui éliminera une faiblesse
et puis on laisserait voilà par exemple
C4 ça pourrait être un très très bon
deal
donc prend faut prends et c'est pas mal
et très passif pour les blancs
mais bon je sais pas
et non il joue il jouera G7 Magnus
Carlson Jean-Michel je prends mon temps
et bien raison ouh là là 5 j'aime pas
alors ça ouvre ouais elle veut faire
quelque chose d'actif mais ça a créé une
faiblesse
dans ce genre de position je crois qu'il
faut tant pis alors c'est dur c'est dur
à dire mais faut rester passif remarquer
remarquez ça se comprend le 5 parce que
il voulait faire ça bref 6 x 5 rois des
4 clairement
et ça va être dur E5 tour des 4
les noirs peuvent facilement améliorer
leur pose oui tout à fait
tout à fait pas les blancs autour des
quatre en attaque le pion et ça va être
ça va être compliqué comment on fait
j'ai trois ok clairement
[Musique]
un bon coup
ces quatre maintenant et on va
accueillir bientôt Nathan je vais
peut-être attendre que Nathan la partie
de Magnus soit terminée ensuite on va
t'accueillir je pense que c'est le mieux
que je fasse pas les manies parce qu'il
faut le discorde et le que je puisse
partager mon écran pour un autre col
bref c'est l'enfer
donc c'est qu'à tour à C1 et maintenant
est-ce qu'il y a un papillon prend V3
C8 tours C8 alors on va montrer il faut
calculer ça
et là il y a plus on prend de
et c'est quoi le coup
parce qu'il sera en prise ce fou
et c'est promet trois jouets par
manuscrit
mais ça va être fini
c'est fini déjà je pense en vrai
puis on prend V3 tours prend ces trois
tours prend ces trois
tourbé 4 il y a fout des
il va falloir faire ça c'est pas en B3
tours aussi ça prend mes trois mais ça
va revenir quasiment au même je pense
avec faut 6 peut-être que c'est le mieux
ouais effectivement
on va voir ce qu'elle va choisir et elle
a joué après en V3 et là il y a tour B8
pas mal pas mal pas mal pas mal du tout
du coup attaque B3 on attaque à 5 tourbé
5 ah protège à 5 et attaque 5 oh là là
c'est la c'est le désastre trop de
faiblesses là une deux voilà peut-être
même trois
très très dur là pour pour Irina on va
voir
on va voir si elle va s'en sortir ça va
être compliqué à mon avis
contre contre Magnus avec simplement 45
secondes contre 7 minutes
ça paraît bien compliqué cette histoire
et ça y est un pion est tombé
et on a toujours cette faiblesse
récurrente en B3
pensez-vous que Carlson gagnera en
aveugle face à 2400 oui et en fait en
tout cas il est favoré ça change pas
beaucoup ça il faut se méfier elle est
en fait le niveau en aveugle pour
certains joueurs ne
il y a pas beaucoup d'écart par exemple
moi je bizarrement ça va peut-être vous
surprendre mais je joue pas beaucoup
moins bien l'aveugle que si je regarde
un échiquier
je joue quasiment à mon niveau
donc pour maintenir je sais que c'est
pareil
à l'époque ça existait ton aveugle mais
bon
c'est un peu passé de mode
et tu auras 3 et c'est tout un max aïe
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe victoire de Magnus
Carson 1-0 pour les chaises bras
c'est ça déséquilibre je vais essayer
d'accueillir Nathan pendant ce temps
ne pas changer on va on va rechercher on
va rechercher notre ami
qui est foutu contre ras van prêt au
tout et bien ça pourrait être une
première surprise dans ce match
alors
c'est quoi
on va faire ça
alors
c'est un peu
faut que je cherche
alors je vais
dans tous des pseudos je vous raconte
pas
tout un tas de chiffres
allez je fais envoyer une demande d'amis
et après on va essayer d'accueillir la
cuillère Nathan
et donc est-ce qu'il s'en sort ou pas
et bien pas vraiment un
il est il est foutu je vais appeler
je vais appeler Nathan
comment je peux faire coucou
on fait pour appeler appelle-moi s'il te
plaît
Nathan merci
salut faut que ça Anonymous Naro en
train de perdre un arrow complètement
foutu quel est le score sinon le score
global pour l'instant est-ce qu'on a une
info là-dessus et bien pour l'instant il
y a une seule il y a une victoire de
Magnus Carson là partout avant de lire
abattu on sait pas on sait pas qui a
battu avant léger si je vais essayer de
refresh quand même cette scorshit
parce que là ça va pas du tout
ça ne va pas du tout
il va nous expliquer ce qui va pas parce
que là je comprends pas j'ai pas la ref
donc on a partout bon dans ce match avec
but but de
Jennifer you qu'est-ce qui se passe chez
Jennifer you donc elle a perdu contre
ouais
un peu plus face à Jacobson Branson
salut alors je pense qu'on t'entende
Nathan donc attention
pas de bêtises
je pense qu'on t'entend est-ce qu'on va
voir le plaisir de te voir
ou pas pas encore je vais mettre ça là
et on va voir
alors c'est la meilleure galère je sais
pas ce que tu me vois sur le stream on
entend on n'a pas de son on l'entend pas
d'accord oui oui parce que j'ai coupé
alors et là on te voit et par contre
j'ai je peux te partager
et ouais si je te partage écran je te
vois plus
c'est pour ça que j'ai fait j'ai fait un
call Skype avec avec Kevin c'était
l'écran sur un autre col en coupant et
tout ok
très bien on sera tous
salut donc tu as vu cette partie de
bague donc ça va faire nuit entre
Jacobson et Ariane tarif il faut que je
te partage le
du coup on va faire ça on regarde je
mets la dernière partie
et je suis tout à toi
et il reste narwitzky face à le blitzer
américain qui est complètement foutu
contre pra et au tout
alors attends je vais créer ta Skype ou
pas
faut que je le retrouve parce que ça
doit faire des années que je peux
utiliser le Skype mais je vais le
retrouver je suis désolé mais le zoom du
coup j'ai pas voulu l'utiliser parce
qu'ils avaient déjà un zoom je peux
utiliser sinon tu peux créer un call
zoom tu peux me l'envoyer par mail ça
peut être ça peut être pas mal pour
capturer l'écran ça va être compliqué
après c'est ça intime
c'est incroyable
je m'inquiète pas
alors qu'est-ce que ça donne chez notre
ami américain
alors il y a très peu de temps en
seconde contre 20 il est au fraise
arrondit de ski c'est cette qui arrive
et non apparemment il y a plus de moi là
il est fort ça est sorti
il a changé effectivement
ouais ok
ok alors normalement j'étais envoyé ça
va faire nul oh ou pas ou pas ou pas ou
pas ça va peut-être pas faire nul ouh là
là ça pourrait être un point hyper
important pour être chaise
dessin qui évidemment je voulais plus
passer lié roi C4 qui va arriver et la
Tour Eiffel sur la Tour Eiffel qui va
être terminé quasiment c'est terminé
pour Naruto de ski il va perdre son pion
en fait depuis on passe lié il peut les
carottes sont cuites
les carottes sont cuites
les carottes sont cuites pour narodite
ski ça c'est une certitude ou pas
l'enfer
mais c'est bon
et là je vais te partager non je vais te
partager une fenêtre
et je vais te partager cette fenêtre
voilà et je pense que tu
te vois oui je me vois c'est un peu
perturbant mais c'est très bien tu me
vois aussi du coup pour se parler c'est
mieux je suis d'accord très bien
donc on va te présenter peut-être aux
gens je sais pas si tu as fait beaucoup
de d'abord on va voir on va voir la fin
de la partie pardon ouais ok là ça va
faire nul facile ouais il sait comment
faire et nul de partout entre dans ce
premier match entre le chessbra et
donc
les Charlots Cobra je vais te changer
ton petit nom parce que c'est plus Kévin
c'est terminé et donc
pendant que je fais ça donc je te
présente donc tu t'appelles Nathan ronce
tu es avant tout genre d'échec
exactement de formation de formation
quel est l'eau
et donc tu t'occupes depuis quelques
années ou un an ou un peu plus
un peu moins depuis ouais depuis le
début de l'été je travaille à chasse.com
donc avec Sami que vous connaissez avec
Kevin Birdy et maintenant avec toi aussi
Laurent d'accord et donc tu es tu es
c'est quoi ton titre
manager French and German en gros mon
gros c'est de coordonner les équipes
francophones et germanophones donc
voilà et donc j'ai été en contact avec
toi assez rapidement et
voilà ça se passe tu m'as tu vas bien
driver hier bon on n'est pas au top sur
le zoom en fait faudra faire un essai
peut-être parce que là je vois pas je
capte pas comment ça marche alors truc
j'ai pas besoin pour avoir Magnus ça va
être facile pour avoir l'autre je suis
encore en train de comprendre mais ça
devrait aller on est en train de
m'expliquer d'accord est-ce qu'on peut
avoir je peux t'envoyer le lien zoom
dans un premier temps et tu pourras
piner son image sur le zoom pour que ça
bouge pas
ça peut être sympa ça
on est content
simplement français Chase 24 fr bon en
faisant en plus de du temps d'antenne
je sais que c'est c'est énormément de
boulot on se rend pas compte mais les
coulisses du truc surtout quand on fait
des choses comme ça un petit peu
corporate c'est-à-dire que il y a
deces.com qui veut organiser un
événement ils veulent que ça soit
couvert dans toutes les langues il file
plutôt les infos en dernière minute et
ça devient tout un tout un truc avec
machin un tel et un tel qu'il faut
contacter alors truc il peut pas parce
qu'il a piscine un truc qui peut pas
parce qu'il a foot truc qui peut pas
parce qu'il a pas envie enfin bon bref
c'est c'est hyper compliqué de gérer
tout le monde avec des
des gens à la technique qui sont
approximatiques aussi
je sais je sais je sais ça le fait ça le
fait tout le temps
ça apporte toujours un petit peu de
challenge
n'importe quoi j'ai fait n'importe quoi
[Musique]
je fais n'importe quoi il me parle dans
les oreilles je ne comprends plus rien
je vais enlever le
je vais enlever ça ah oui je suis là en
fait ok
donc là je suis là et après elle me
parle
j'ai fermé en fait je fais n'importe
quoi
je sais pas encore mais je sais pas
exactement où tu es mais tu verras il y
a une première salle avec des gens de
chasse comme et puis après on va
t'envoyer vers une salle soit de chiasse
bras soit de des adversaires ok je veux
bien
je suis là OK
est-ce qu'elle capte que je suis là
en fait j'ai été redirigé
automatiquement dans le dans le zoom de
chia bras
du coup j'ai je peux te partager mon
écran si tu veux et tu pourrais
partager
il était beau mais tu sais quoi on va
abandonner pour aujourd'hui
toute manière là il est pas là ouais bon
on veut voir c'est bon allez hop quitter
on fera ça demain c'est bon c'est un
premier stream parce qu'il faut savoir
que j'ai fait plein de stream évidemment
avec chaise 24 mais honnêtement là c'est
complètement nouveau
pour moi et donc c'est un peu
c'est le premier jour un peu folklo avec
les gens qui donc j'en ai marre là
franchement honnêtement je suis un peu
je suis un peu au bout du rouleau donc
je laisse tomber
exactement c'est un petit peu bizarre
c'est une dernière fois où les équipes
sont séparées mais en fait l'idée c'est
que une équipe nous dérange pas l'autre
parce que souvent il y a des joueurs qui
ont tendance à faire un peu de bruit
quand il joue et ça comment tu fais
quand tu vas dans le c'est ça moi qui
m'a complètement perturbé c'est à dire
que j'ai l'impression que je pouvais
être dans une seule discussion et pas
dans l'autre mais bon
j'ai le même problème
d'accord et est-ce que là est-ce que tu
peux regarder à Google sheet parce qu'en
fait j'ai pas j'ai pas les joueurs de
bizarrement sur ta Google chic que tu
m'as envoyé j'ai pas les joueurs de
des chaises bras ce qui est un peu
embêtant ok bien sûr et voilà et pour le
reste je pense qu'on après on pourra
parler des chèques avec ce match qui
commence hyper bien de partout c'est
génial on est content on va avoir du
suspense
sur la Google je t'appelle les joueurs
de chiasse bras du tout
ah en fait c'est coupé il faut que tu
recadres je pense c'est un peu plus à
droite non non j'ai déjà essayé
ça ne marche pas
OK
du coup le premier joueur de chiasse
c'est Jennifer
[Musique]
d'accord mais du coup je vois pas les on
voit pas les noms des joueurs sur le sur
le stream ce qui est un peu dommage
où est-ce que je peux te proposer
éventuellement c'est de refaire
c'est vraiment étrange
plein de premiers jours vous inquiétez
pas de toute façon on a les parties de
manuscrit que ça soit le premier jour le
dernier il carbure il met des points de
toute façon donc on va voir des belles
parties trois parties à suivre de Magnus
avec ce diable de ski qui s'en est sorti
donc nul dans cette partie entre
narwitzky que vous voyez à l'écran et
prime tout rasan manuscrit accroche
liangle abattu Jennifer you la logique à
respecter regardez 2643 contre cette
jeune joueuse inférieur attention qui a
été champion des États-Unis 23003
et on a eu aussi le dernier le dernier
résultat c'était une nulle entre Ariane
tari et ce Brandon Jacobson j'ai jamais
vu
j'ai jamais vu pour être honnête
pourtant j'avais vu des joueurs
tu connais pas du tout première fois que
j'entends ce monsieur au début je crois
que tu allais dire Robson ou quelque
chose comme ça parce que ça sonne un peu
pareil à la fin mais en fait
donc compliqué est-ce que tu peux parler
des projets peut-être de chaises comme
fr qu'est-ce qui est prévu de couvrir de
pas couvrir est-ce que comment ça se
passe
en termes d'événements pour l'instant
donc on a la preuve chez League avec
cinq semaines donc jusqu'à deuxième
partie de mars
après on aura les playoffs les derniers
jours de marche je crois le 30 et le 31
mars quelque chose comme ça et donc ce
sont les quarts de finale de
la projeeling donc là on est à 16
équipes et 8 équipes vont se qualifier à
la fin de ce système suisse donc il
termine le rami mars et donc le quart de
finale aura lieu fin mars et la phase
finale aura lieu en mai je crois entre
le 10 et le 14 mai quelque chose comme
ça et là c'est en présentiel et
théoriquement sans présentiel tout n'est
pas encore confirmé mais l'objectif est
que ce soit en présentiel c'est ça et
donc comme vous en doutez entre les deux
et ben il y aura le championnat du monde
entre guillemets
d'accord ok super et est-ce que tu peux
je sais plus évidemment il y a le
champions qui continue
la prochaine étape
je crois que c'est du 3 au 7 avril il me
semble je crois que ça commence enfin ça
finit le jour de la cérémonie
d'ouverture des candidats des candidats
du championnat du monde d'accord ok donc
ça sera beau donc il y aura pas de Ding
ni de dépôt dans ces tournois ok donc ce
prochain site est quand même le gros
tournoi le gros tournoi de cheescom avec
c'est quasiment la dixième édition je
crois peut-être plus quelque chose comme
ça mais ouais c'est ça commence à faire
en tout cas clairement et du coup pour
rebondir oui et du coup on aura midi
donc si tu veux le faire la voix libre
pourtant de ce que j'ai entendu avant ah
je vais peut-être jouer le playing moi
je me chauffe pourquoi pas
non
franchement ça se négocie on peut voir
même si on arrive à éventuellement le
retransmettre si jamais tu veux jouer ce
stream en même temps mais c'est un peu
plus dur
je parle en même temps c'est ça si
jamais ça je faisais ça au Dodge tu vois
sur chaise j'ai quand même remarqué que
c'était un trop grand handicap par
rapport au problème c'est un peu le
souci après
tu vois ouais c'est un peu ouais c'est
un peu le souci et c'est un truc sérieux
quand même ça joue ça joue fort donc des
Torah de Blitz ça limite pourquoi pas
avec plaisir tu vois de streamer des
blits ça j'ai fait 1000 fois mais là
je sais pas tu sais c'est terminé au
bout de trois parties j'aurai 0 sur 3 et
je vais faire un ragequit des familles
donc c'est possible aussi ça se termine
comme ça faut pas s'enflammer non plus
et on m'encourageant
ils vont parler à mes adversaires
je me suis dit enfin une embellie j'ai
pas le savoir tu vois je vais tout
gagner et je vais croire que je joue
bien et non alors une pétrole de la part
de jenniferio face à Naruto évidemment
une nul serait une très très belle
opération
pour pour Jennifer you face à narwitzky
mais c'est une variante un petit peu
inférieure où on donne la paire de fou
donc normalement on est pas ravi et ah
oui la question que je voulais poser
pour la peau de châssis on est d'accord
que les Français évidemment qu'on va
supporter ça rentre l'équipe de
blitstream il rentre jeudi hein il me
semble alors je vais vérifier j'ai le
j'ai le truc c'est bien eux alors
attends vas-y je l'ai je l'ai je l'ai je
l'ai d'accord c'est le jeudi 16h30
on va s'y faire au logo et tout ça vous
inquiétez pas
ça donc ils entrent jeudi et donc soyez
là jeudi dès 16h30 j'ai eu un tweet de
Kevin aujourd'hui qui a dit on va tous
les éclater donc
la mayonnaise bah oui faut pas y aller
en perdant sinon c'est foutu hein c'est
foutu d'avance donc faut de bon ça c'est
une ligne les Indiens je sais pas si tu
as regardé je sais que tu étais
en vadrouille un petit peu aujourd'hui
mais tu as pu regarder un petit peu le
premier match les Indiens ont été très
très impressionnants j'ai regardé de
loin mais c'était enfin j'ai vu les
parties rapidement et franchement
c'était impressionnant c'était vraiment
une boucherie en fait
déjà participé à la PCL oui deux fois
avec les normes et après j'ai été
recruté justement par l'équipe
à l'époque des attends c'était l'équipe
de
des Marseille migraines je crois je joue
avec bakro et compagnie je sais pas si
on jouait Kevin il a eu sa propre
migraine en fait
et après ou avant j'ai joué pour
énormément je sais plus mais bon ça
marchait pas très bien Marseille
migraine ouais c'était marrant
bah alors disons en bas ça doit être
donc y avoir il y a démanté parce qu'il
y a une joie obligatoire et donc il doit
y avoir un joueur de 2300 alors
quelque chose comme ça pour compenser
alors
du coup en dernier élo je crois qu'il y
a le fils d'Étienne Baco
qui pourrait peut-être ouais c'est ça
mais du coup si on a les 2400
[Musique]
depuis le début parce que
j'avais un je te montre j'avais 2500 ici
donc celui-là j'enlève allez hop il
passe à la trappe et en fait celui qu'il
faut voir
c'est celui-là 2550 exactement et voilà
de comporter au moins une femme une
joueuse un plafonnement hello est
appliqué comme suit les joueurs classés
2700 ouais donc ça passe en fait avec
avec deux joueurs à plus de 2700 mais on
peut pas avoir trois par contre si ça
peut pas abuser non plus donc voilà ça
rend le truc plus sympathique alors et
plus ouvert à tous on va voir naroudit
qui s'en sort très bien et la paire de
fou écoutez moi j'ai déjà joué cette
ligne avec le blanc c'est aussi mieux
pour les blancs elle est pas terrible en
chaque on sait pas du tout se fouter 4
jouer kssis sortez vos cavaliers avant
vos fous parce que là on fait on donne
la paire de fou pour et bien attends je
crois rien du tout voilà
petite question par rapport à cette
position toi qui a préparé notamment
Magnus sur des positions de ça ressemble
un peu à une position de Berlin inversée
à une défense de Berlin inversée et donc
ce petit temps de plus fait que les
Blancs ont une partie bien plus facile
qu'avec les noirs ou couleur inversée
c'est ça alors là mais là on a même pas
c'est à dire que dans l'autre on a on a
la paire de fou mais on a quand même une
majorité de pions les blancs une
majorité de pions dans la berlinoise
pour ceux qui voient la finale sinon
vous gobelez la finale de base vous avez
trouvé tout de suite donc on est
majorité de pions en échange de la paire
de fou mais là on a pas du tout de
majorité de pire donc c'est pour ça
quand je dis qu'il y a rien en
contrepartie de la carte de la de la
paire de fou il y a pas d'avantage de
développement on est même plutôt moins
bien développé on n'a pas de meilleure
structure parce que finalement on a
quatre contre quatre donc tout est du
même côté donc en fait on a la paire de
fou pour rien et d'ailleurs un arodinsky
quand même un grand maître expérimenté
qu'est-ce qu'il fait il ouvre la
position pour c'est fou tout de suite et
donc paire de fou pour les blancs aucune
compensation avantage blanc c'est une
poubelle qui a dit ça c'est une mini
poubelle je suis d'accord avec toi
est-ce que Magnus Carlson a commencé oui
il a commencé ma muscarsen et il a les
blancs et regardez F6 KF3 D5 G3 ça a été
préparé par le mal de champion du monde
justement tu en parlais de 2021 et ça a
été joué
par Magnus cars scène face à Yann et
pomyachi dans cette la fameuse
participe la partie la plus longue d'un
champion du monde qui a duré plus de 8
heures consécutives avec 130 coups avec
cette finale tour de pion qui a tenu en
haleine des des centaines de milliers de
passionnés elle a commencé avec ce petit
coup G3 qui est destiné à éviter
des catalanes trop tôt d'ailleurs il y a
des pomiashi des catalan où on fait puis
on prend ses quatre très rapidement par
exemple fougez de fossettes voilà en
fait
on délaye comment on dit en français
retarde le coup C4 pour éviter les
variantes par exemple qui pourraient
arriver comme ça ces quatre six G3 D5
fougères où on se jette sur le pion C4
aussi ça empêche les varante avec fubé 4
échec parce qu'on va pas jouer C4 et
donc 4 aurait beaucoup moins de saveurs
pour les Noirs donc c'est un petit coup
mais bon ça aussi les inconvénients si
je dis pas de métier je crois avoir déjà
vu elle est Raisa justement essayer
d'empêcher ces quatre en jouant un coup
comme cavalier d'essai qui avait les B6
assez rapidement une manœuvre qui est
assez rare d'habitude
ça peut se faire aussi c'était rare au
départ et c'est vrai que c'est devenu un
peu plus
un peu plus
disons populaires qui a eu des 7 kb6
c'est une option ici pour empêcher pour
empêcher ces quatre même si le cavalier
est pas très bien placé ici mais ça se
joue mais il y a toute façon j'ai trois
c'est pas une réussitation de on cherche
pas à gagner dans l'ouverture on cherche
à avoir une position je vois F5 jouer
qui a des coûts principaux ici il y a
plein de coups si c'est 6 G6 tout est
possible 5c4 E6 qui est C3 et H6 joué
par
Jacobson qu'on retienne macro hein j'ai
joué ça au championnat de France et il a
fait il a fait on a eu la même position
il a fait C6 j'ai joué dans MP3
dame
prend à prendre et la petite finale il a
pas complètement égalisé dans cette
petite finale
et mais bon c'est pas non plus perdant
pour pour les Noirs donc c'est aussi une
option mais du coup
il décide de faire H6 assez rapidement
Magnus qui réfléchit plutôt étonnant de
voir réfléchir aussi longtemps la six
minutes
au cinquième coup parce que moi je peux
vous dire que j'ai déjà regardé cette
position et normalement il devrait
il devrait il devrait connaître les
conclusions mais bon parfois
c'est plus compliqué
et je vais te prendre le fou et c'est
toujours ce fou on n'a pas forcément les
joueurs de de cela avec ces il est sorti
de l'étau un petit peu et on a on a
envie de le garder c'est un beau fou
donc on perd un temps à jouer un 6
pour garder ce fou alors l'inconvénient
c'est qu'on a perdu un temps MP3 M6 et
C5 je vais maintenant voilà que ça
retombe dans un petit peu dans la partie
qu'entretienne s'il prend V3 après en V3
alors après il avait joué il avait joué
avec fossette Etienne il avait pas jouer
à 6
merci pour ces précisions je peux
revenir sur la prochaine sleek
rapidement donc pour chercher les
adversaires de notre équipe française
qui seront qui sera une équipe indienne
alors on n'a pas la composition encore
pour jeudi mais en tête en listello
c'est irigasi
un très bon joueur pratique
du monde par équipe
j'ai perdu la première j'ai gagné la
deuxième j'ai perdu le Blitz alors vas-y
ça a laissé des blessures
bye un joueur iranien amine tabataba il
faut s'entraîner pour les enfants très
fort joueur iranien très très fort
jouera bien un joueur qui est qui arrive
ouais mais là il prend pas toujours en
même temps
et après on a Hannibal bouskaran et
bon des joueurs un petit peu moins
connus on connaît harika drone
au monde
parce que ça globalement c'est ça
l'équipe mais ça envoie du lourd au
premier
H4 comme je vous l'avais dit il joue
quelle idée pourquoi c'est très très
simple on veut faire le 4 on veut ouvrir
cette position pour qu'on va ouvrir la
position parce que regarder ses pièces
elles sont pas bien sortis et on a quand
même un bel avantage au centre donc il
faut essayer de faire en sorte les Noirs
perdu du temps en jouant H6 et il faut
essayer de faire en sorte d'ouvrir la
position parce qu'on a un avantage
développement le plus vite possible
voyez même Magnus Carson il applique des
principes finalement simples avantages
développement double centre et on essaie
de faire en sorte qu'il se passe quelque
chose par là
sa chambre alors beaucoup entre
collègues on peut s'embrayer c'est ça
oui c'est on est là pour ça moi je
croyais qu'on a le droit de chambrer que
Kevin Kevin thérieux parce que c'est
quand même très c'est le meilleur client
quand même Kevin
mais il cherche à se faire chambrer
c'est ça
alors comment on fait ici avec les noirs
pas évident
en général c'est ma technique quand j'ai
un Coast Nathan c'est que dès qu'ils
m'ont exposition je refuse le bébé et je
dis que tu ferais toi Nathan là dans
cette position
gagner un peu d'espace à aller le roi
parce que à l'eldom clamant c'est les
blancs et ça paraît difficile de pousser
et en fait c'est aussi très concret
parce que si tu fais faux-5 je fais quel
BD7 et je vais te prendre de fou quoi
qu'il arrive et si tu fais faux 3 bah je
fais que j'ai 4 et je te prends le fou
et donc en fait tu perds entre
guillemets en fait tu es obligé
d'échanger ce foodcas noir et à mon avis
il faut trois est vraiment pas terrible
parce que tu fais ok donc j'ai aussi fou
prendre V8 qui se regarde tu reprends V8
et au catch j'essaie encore une fois de
te prendre de vitesse et d'ouvrir
d'ouvrir tout ça et là et Magnus Magnus
Carlson mesdames et messieurs il joue au
cadre de quoi intermédiaire et oui c'est
lui ça et là comme d'hab ouais ouais
c'est pas mal au cas ça met la pression
alors je sais pas si en tout cas
repartir à pizza ça fait pas plaisir de
comme ça alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait ici
le premier coupon doit regarder c'est ça
il faut 5 kbd7 et comment on fait ici
parce que un truc comme ça ça me semble
un peu
ils ont admettons je joue vraiment je
prends à chaque ça c'est un peu je pense
que les noirs sont assez ok parce que
ils ont ils ont dû contre jeux sur le
pion des 4 on va ok on va jouer le tour
des 8 même peut-être les blancs
possibles que noir soit mieux donc on
peut pas jouer bêtement il faut jouer
plus
[Musique]
à peut-être maintenant faut trois et là
toi du sens et ensuite on prend dans le
cadre
plus très grave parce que un pion étroit
pourrait soutenir le pion des quatre
ouvrir la colonne 9 et les blancs avec
du jeu
grave et puis en plus on a perdu déjà
qu'on a rien de sortir on perd deux
temps pour dans une position ouverte
maintenant attention parce qu'après au 4
c'est pas la même que sans E4 parce
qu'on a on a ouvert la position donc
c'est c'est compliqué
mais non je peux pas je peux pas
j'aimerais bien avoir les noms ça marche
pas décaler le
layoutirer à droite
pourtant on a passé du temps hier tous
les deux à faire ses réglages et tu sais
quand même que ça c'est le faire
je tire mais ça marche pas
il y a un problème
il y a un problème c'est bien dommage
alors est-ce que tu peux m'envoyer de
l'autre score chic peut-être c'est ce
que je me suis dit bien sûr avec les
joueurs du coup
s'il te plaît
comme ça je peux mettre je pourrais
mettre les noms des joueurs avec leur au
moins on saura ce qui se passe alors il
y a un petit spoil
mais bon c'est pas très grave
même si c'est pas si c'est franchement
pas
très très confidentiel mais bon
alors ce que je vais faire on va faire
ça pendant que tu parles de la position
il réfléchit toujours sur ah non il a
joué fogé 6 et fous des 6 est arrivé oh
là là c'est mou tout ça et maintenant on
va reprendre du pion oh là là c'est je
sais pas ce que tu en penses mais je
pense que pour Jacobson là c'est pas
extraordinaire ce qui est en train de se
passer en tout cas je pense qu'il aime
pas trop les cases noires bien dégoûté
mais c'est clair les blancs veulent
pousser le pion et finalement fixer le
fou devant la structure de pion donc on
pourrait penser que c'est le mauvais fou
se fout de cazenas parce qu'il est de la
même couleur que les pions blancs en
Descartes en C5 mais comme il est devant
la chaîne de pur bon en fait il se
protège mutuellement avec les pions et
le faux rayonne contre les deux
diagonales autour du roi
et les Noirs aimeraient bien essayer de
tout liquider comme ils sont en retard
de développement mais c'est pas si
facile parce que après la prise en décis
il y a des petits problèmes sur casemar
je suis toute à toi tu as tout à fait je
suis d'accord en fait avec ce que tu as
dit j'ai l'impression tu as l'impression
que je t'écoute pas mais
quand on prend des 6 effectivement gros
problème sur case noire donc son
adversaire alors même si la jauge voyez
la barre en tout cas la barre
d'évaluation elle est pas hyper inquiète
et bien
ou la question que j'ai fait là moi
aperçu et hop et voilà on est à de
nouveau en direct et on a les joueurs
donc les quatre joueurs avec les
appareils vous allez les résultats qui
vont défiler mais la manuscren qui quand
même très en contrôlé il faut prendre
des Scipion prend pure prend le 4 et H4
petit coup intermédiaire ça c'est pas
mal le roi du coup H5 pas mal s'il faut
prendre allez il se fait plaisir mag new
Sky prend le 4 on gagne du temps tout
pour l'activité ici
c'est vraiment le genre de position
qu'on a vraiment pas envie de jouer
contre le Magnus quoi
ouais mais alors peut-être c'est pas si
clair là je vais être obligé de prendre
du Fou j'ai envie de garder un cavalier
parce que si je fais ça j'ai
l'impression que les Noirs quand même
arrivent à être bien solide
ça va garder la position à peu près
fermée ça devrait tenir quoi
F5 et maintenant est-ce qu'on peut pas
continuer dans la même veine avec ce
dynamisme de Magnus mais pas facile
pas si facile pour Magnus Jacobson
Brandon que je connaissais pas mais qui
est à l'air vraiment pas mauvais
en tout cas pour l'instant c'est quand
même relativement propre on est d'accord
parce que il y a quand même il se prend
une sacrée pression là gros coup de
pression de la part de Magnus mais chaud
chaud
parce que cette position si tu veux d'un
point de vue dynamique c'est ce que tu
as dit
ça a l'air tu vois pour les blancs ça a
l'air génial mais sur le long terme
tu as une poubelle en finale je veux
dire on enlève les dames admettons on
enlève les deux dames
donc il faut faire ça veut dire qu'avec
les blancs il faut il faut absolument
qu'il se passe quelque chose dans les
prochains coups
G2 le KLS c'est trois il pourrait
éventuellement essayer de sauter vers
ses seins il a joué il faut prendre le 4
manus Carlsen et petit roc est-ce qu'il
y a un moyen parce que moi je connais
pas très bien chaise.com et là tu vois
je galère parce qu'il y a des update de
coup est-ce qu'il y a un auto update de
coup tu vois là ça me c'est quoi le truc
est-ce que tu es sur la page événement
ou sur le slash play je suis sur le
je suis sur le pro de chessing Man event
event le premier truc que tu m'as montré
parce que l'autre ça marchait pas du
tout alors ça se peut il se peut que par
moment les cours arrivent en grappe ah
oui c'est ça mais tu es sûr parce que
parfois ils arrivent et en fait je vois
pas qu'il soit arrivé et donc quand ils
arrivent en grappe en fait il faut que
ça soit moi qui update c'est ça c'est
une bonne question je sais pas du tout
d'accord ça peut être aussi ouais
l'actualisation du navigateur peut-être
d'accord c'est bien d'avoir un débutant
il pose des questions c'est comme aux
échecs c'est extraordinaire d'avoir un
débutant parce que du coup il pose des
questions qui paraissent complètement
que personne que personne ne se poser et
finalement on n'a pas toujours la
réponse donc c'est pour ça poser vos
questions dans le chat parce qu'en fait
vous êtes
parce qu'on veut garder le cavalier dans
cette situation petit
et voilà vous voyez c'est un jeu très
dynamique très très actif de la part de
Magnus parce qu'il peut pas se permettre
que le que l'action se refroidisse dame
prend set qui est BSL j'aime pas trop ce
qu'il fait mais Brandon il fait une
sacrée partie attention c'est c'est pas
ça c'est un gros client là dame prend
des 6 peut arriver sur dame français ici
à tour C8 honnêtement je sais pas qui
est mieux
le plan des noirs est clairement plus
clair que le plan développement
c'est la seule case pour pas perdre du
matériel et notamment la dame
et donc dame prend des 6 semble mesdames
prends des six il va se prendre ah oui
dame B8 ah maintenant la petite finale
est pas pareil attention moi je serais
très tenté de faire ça et ça m'étonne
pas
mais vas-y joue
voilà tu fais quoi là tu vas voir Magnus
on est quasiment obligé j'imagine
qu'il peut arriver ou cavaliero 3 je
sais pas j'ai l'impression que ça fait
pas un gros écart qui avait eu trois
jouets et F4 jouer et puis on prend un
jouet c'est le prochain on chauffe là on
fait une équipe ou quoi ouais
7 et regarde ça y est ça joue
et là il est gagnant pourquoi elle
marche pas la jauge parce que là c'est
pas possible la serre-chi gagnant pour
les blancs
[Musique]
jouer par Magnus cars scène et on voit
grosse partie de Magnus mais de son
adversaire aussi
donc
j'ai une question pourquoi est-ce que
Magnus il va pourquoi est-ce qu'il fait
des 5 pourquoi est-ce qu'il veut ouvrir
le centre alors qu'il a un avantage fin
des pièces un peu mieux placées un petit
peu en plus
derrière c'est pas plus compliqué que ça
c'est si tu prends mais du coup je
prends ici je déstabilise ton cavalier
j'ai ma tour qui va jouer j'ai mon tour
qui va jouer en fait il s'ouvre une
colonne pour sa tour donc là c'est pas
un c'est quelque chose de très concret
en fait
un peu plus lent un moment hyper
dynamique ou ouais mais là il continue
parce que en fait il pourrait faire en
fait sur le plan stratégique qui devrait
faire quelque chose de plus lent mais il
se trouve que sur un plan tactique il
est encore beaucoup mieux développé que
son adversaire et il ouvre une corne
ouverte où il a une tour derrière voilà
c'est ce qui propose donc en fait il
propose un échange très malhonnête pour
le coup et donc là c'est pour ça que les
Noirs refusent ils jouent ces 5 et Kay
c'est 4 maintenant ok c'est 4 c'est
encore un coup tactique pour jouer tout
recettes et prends H5 tours 7 jouer
cavalier DF6
mais attention là ça va mal se terminer
pour notre ami en général Magnus il a la
main ferme dans ce genre de situation
qui avait lieu le 5 jouets qui est Prim
F4 et D6 et regardez-moi ça ça joue ça a
redonné des pions mais attention
maintenant ce pion et en prise ce pion
est en prise et surtout on a un pur en
défi qui est très très dangereux et j'ai
6 joué la caisse et 6 typique Magnus la
précision la tactique et regardez puis
on prend on attaque ici en menace Cappe
en débutant on va faire tourner vite ça
joue fort c'est le calcul fort là c'est
tu sais quoi du coup moi ça fait quand
même 10 ans que je suis Magnus c'est un
alors il est plus souvent dans des bons
jours dans des mauvais mais là quand il
combine comme ça la tactique la
stratégie le truc
ça joue tu vois en 10 minutes en plus
c'est qu'il est dans un et dans un grand
jour donc là
les enfants
narditzky et les deux derniers là je
suis inquiet pour eux tu vois je le vois
sur zoom là Magnus il est bien sérieux
bien concentré
beaucoup d'émotions parfois
clairement ça se voit que alors je sais
pas peut-être que il va perdre les deux
prochaines et ça me fera ça me fera
mentir mais
là quand il est comme ça il est
normalement estopable attention on
pourrait faire dame évidemment on
pourrait jeter sur dame attention quand
on voit un bon coup chercher un meilleur
là ça ça pue le meilleur coup ici
dans le genre j'ai raté autour des 8
c'est assez bon pour des 8 il y a quoi
il y a que les Français 7 c'est ça et
ouais
et ça va pas et il a joué quoi un Magnus
Carlson évidemment il va pas tomber dans
ce genre de choses qu'est-ce qu'il a
joué
il a joué C8 dames bon et il a pas il a
retrouvé le mieux apprend et il prend
les pions toi F5 et j'ai 7 ans vas-y je
sens que ce pion il faut juste faire
attention à ce pion qui peut avancer
vite
est-ce qu'il va encaisser ce pion il
faut s'occuper des 6 voilà il revient un
petit peu le cavalier c'est pas mal et
sur H4 il va faire quoi H4 cavalier 4 et
cavalier 6
et oui oui H3 il va y avoir un coup de
kg
comme tu l'as dit tu l'as annoncé Pacman
ouais là ça va faire beaucoup pour notre
ami Jacobson qui va abandonner on va
aller voir peut-être une partie plus
intéressante est-ce qu'on allait des
résultats Ariane tari et oui il y a eu
trois résultats pardon et les
prix là
c'est un peu ouais enfin en tout cas il
mène de deux points c'est pas mal c'est
pas mal ça fait un score de 5 à 3 pour
nos amis des chaises bras
on n'a pas les images si on a les droits
on a les droits mais là c'est trop
compliqué pour t'express il faut qu'on
s'entraîne il faut que Nathan il montre
que qu'on s'entraîne parce que alors là
c'était le je n'ai jamais vu ça des
trucs un call zoom fait comme ça je n'ai
jamais vu ça tout simplement et combien
il y a beaucoup
il y a beaucoup de réglages à faire hier
soir honnêtement ils envoient les c'est
un peu en dernière minute tout ça et
donc on a quand même passé pas mal de
temps et voilà on peut pas on peut pas
être partout donc deux à partir de
demain on aura les images promis
c'est exactement c'est pas évident de
tout setup dès aujourd'hui c'est un
petit peu la dernière minute c'est le la
configuration du zoom est un peu
spéciale mais donc on va privilégier
l'échiquier et les commentaires pour
aujourd'hui parce que on est là pour ça
et dès demain normalement on devrait
avoir les images exactement
note moi je vais faire un petit break
alors je te propose soit tu fais un
break avec moi soit tu restes ici à
parler aux gens n'hésitez pas donc je
rappelle Nathan ronce qui est le manager
français et allemand donc tu parles tes
commandes en allemand
un très bon non en vrai j'ai entre bien
et B2
j'habitais vraiment à côté de la
frontière j'ai un peu jouer aux échecs
en Allemagne parce que c'était à côté
mais pour le coup j'ai quasiment jamais
habité en Allemagne pendant très
longtemps et tout d'un coup à 24 ans
j'ai déménagé à Berlin évidemment Berlin
c'est
une ville où on parle plus anglais
qu'allemand donc au final je suis pas
progresser en allemand
d'accord
ok mais bon là du coup c'est l'occaz
exactement ok donc tu préfères quoi tu
restes et tu parles aux gens ou comment
ça marche
question sur les programmes sur ce que
vous voulez
allez-y sur sur Youtube évidemment
chaise 24 et cheeseccom ça se situe
aussi une des choses qu'on a qu'on a
mise en place tous les deux hier donc
c'est une volonté commune de cheesecom
et enfin de chez scoop
c'est moi qui l'ai proposé du coup de
faire ben voilà de papa de la communauté
de ces 24 fr en gros et donc de la de
l'amener aussi sur cheesecom et donc de
faire profiter tout le monde
de des shows
voilà donc n'hésitez pas évidemment à
terme tu vas me le confirmer après je
vais y aller je te lance sur un sujet
mais à terme je crois que la chaîne
chaise 24 en français disparaîtra
forcément
atteindre probablement disparaîtra je
sais pas ou en tout cas peut-être
qu'elle sera plus vraiment mise à jour
mais je pense que enfin c'est même sûr
que les vidéos les lives etc tout
devrait rester a priori il y a pas de
raison de supprimer autant de contenu on
a regardé hier on avait fait une petite
estimation de
de l'année 2020 justement l'année
covides
mais c'est vrai qu'à un moment c'est
tous les jours et
après avec la moyenne tu vois avec les
autres choses effectivement ouais mais
c'est un plaisir moi c'était mes plus
belles parce que là du coup c'est la
fois où j'ai reçu je remercie il y a
certains qui écoutent ou des messages
vraiment très touchants de gens qui
étaient
s'embêtaient un petit peu chez eux et
voilà ça leur permettait de passer un
bon moment et donc du coup ça ça faisait
vraiment plaisir et l'impression de
d'être utile remboursé par la Sécurité
Sociale moi je te le dis je devrais
j'aurais dû mais bon bref je reviens du
coup
donc oui comme Laurent le mentionnait la
chaîne cheese 24 fr pour vocation de
rester mais de probablement pas être
mise à jour dans le futur et pour
l'instant on est en train on va stream
donc sur twitch sur Youtube de chaise
comme le faire
ah oui merci
c'est ma faute ouais
problème de son oui parce que j'ai
enlevé mes écouteurs du coup en fait on
t'entend pas mes écouteurs
du coup tu es là
pas du tout
est-ce que vous m'entendez dans le chat
est-ce que vous entendez ou pas
on est tous les deux minutes
c'est pas possible
ouh là ouvrez l'utilitaire de résolution
de problème audio
on est pas bien là
on est pas bien
est-ce que vous m'entendez
je pense que vous m'entendez
est-ce que vous m'entendez ou pas
dites-moi
on entend ah vous m'entendez
merci
ouais mais vous entendez plus ah bah
c'est mes écouteurs alors
je sais pas il y a
est-ce que tu m'entends
d'ailleurs
[Musique]
on m'a dit que ton son était plus bas
que le mien et que tu pourrais peut-être
monter un petit peu de ton son à toi
on entend plus Laurent
est-ce que vous entendez Laurent
on me dit que non mais ce que je pense
que le micro c'est pas alors qu'est-ce
que ça pourrait être est-ce que
éventuellement on pourrait remettre une
enfin genre changer la source et la
remettre par exemple si tu prends le
est-ce que tu as un micro sur ton
ordinateur autre que celui-là non
OK
mais c'est juste pour switcher et
revenir parfois ça pourrait
j'espère que ça va marcher à moins que
mon
tu m'entends toi
mais peut-être qu'elle est dans mon
micro il est dans discord
[Musique]
est-ce que je suis pas trop fort ça va
merci en tout cas
décidément alors elle est partie en
repris
et on a pas Magnus Carson allez on va
aller voir
on va aller voir pour l'instant Jacobson
qui n'a pas commencé en alliant
gavendeur contre Ariane tari et prodzu
contre Irina crush et qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire ça Nathan
ah merde
non
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
quoi sur l'appariement ça veut dire
qu'on a manuscrit le scène face à Daniel
naodicski on va se régaler
on va se régaler on va se régaler
personnellement je suis venu ici juste
pour ce match c'est vrai
un petit peu mais ça m'a bien encouragé
ouais mais il se trouve que
je peux pas toucher à mon micro je peux
pas faire moins fort sur mon micro donc
je peux te faire un peu plus fort mais
je peux pas me faire moins fort je suis
désolé ouais non mais ça va je crois
ouais c'est pas mal
et Magnus et Magnus pourquoi c'est il
est pas là parce qu'il est là il va
arriver manuscrit blanc contre Daniel
narwitzky mais franchement ben on voit
les lots de 1618
c'est quand même c'est pas mal d'accord
mais
comme j'ai que quelques points de plus
tu vois je vais pas dire que c'est c'est
moche puis en plus on sait jamais il se
trouve que je pourrais je suis pas sur
une pente ascendant plutôt des clients
donc effectivement on va dire que c'est
même très bien
mais il y a quand même un gros écart et
donc il y a pas de il y a pas un gros
écart quand il joue en match de Bullet
parce que dans spécialement formule est
mais en partie rapide je pense que
Magnus est quand même énorme favoris il
joue des quatre il pense à très au
sérieux il va il va jouer sa prep je
suppose
ou pas de jouer on va voir je crois
qu'il y a un énorme gap entre les
joueurs classés 2618 bah en fait entre
2619 et moins et entre 2119 et plus je
crois qu'il y a un très beau à venir
ouais c'est ça c'est ça c'est
pas je te dirai quand ça change c'est
cette histoire
ça va peut-être changer bientôt tu vois
on sait jamais moi je suis je suis à une
ou deux bulles de passer de passer
derrière le gap quoi tu vois donc on
fera une autre histoire on fera une
autre histoire qui m'arrange un peu
mieux
et une est indienne jouée par Nardo de
ski ok
intéressant qu'est-ce qui va choisir
manuscrit
cavalier F3 ou 2 qui est le plus
classique il y a aussi H3 cavalier F3
qui est intéressant on peut jouer les
quatre pions mais c'est pas lui ça on
peut jouer des semish mais c'est pas
trop lui non plus moi je vois jouer
cavalier F3 et H3 voilà on va voir
comment ça se passe
comme ça la macogonov je crois que c'est
celle là non
[Musique]
je connais je le connais par cœur
avec l'idée
en retard le développement du cavalier
on sait jamais on pourra venir par
exemple sur des plans comme ça on peut
on peut venir on peut faire un petit
coup de G4 et éventuellement plus tard
venir avec le cavalier en E2 le cahier
en G3 et alors bonne chance pour les
noirs pour jouer F5 ce rg3 qui stoppe en
fait finalement le des seuls plans très
dire enfin le plan principal dynamique
pour les noirs qui est de jouer F5
donc c'est à priori et il joue faut
trois T5 ok petite question parce que
souvent donc tu parlais de la
varancimiche tout à l'heure qui est de
commencer par F3 pour mettre le fond en
E3 et faire ce qu'on pourrait faire un
semblant d'attaque anglaise donc F3 ou 3
donne des deux et pourquoi pas même
grand rock c'est ton Gmail et là en
scène il a fait H3 pour faire
c'est quoi la différence de plan
finalement entre faire H3 et F3
alors c'est une bonne question
c'est F3 renforce le centre mais empêche
le cavalier F3 de se développer aussi ça
H3 on va moins souvent jouer j'ai quatre
H4 parce que on a déjà joué H3 donc
c'est plus je dirais que c'est moins
agressif finalement ça c'est très
positionnel de jouer comme ça en fait on
joue vraiment pour empêcher F5 mais on
joue pas du tout pour ma tête est-ce que
dans la semish on va jouer beaucoup plus
pour mater avec des H4 H5 ici c'est
vraiment c'est purement positionnel en
fait c'est pour empêcher ses plans à
base de F5 et c'est ça qui fait damso
et maintenant on va voir je l'ai je l'ai
honnêtement je l'ai déjà regardé ça ce
truc là pour pour Magnus
je sais pas s'il faut que je dise si
Peter Peter heureusement que Peter parle
pas français c'est là où c'est là c'est
là où c'est ma chance sur C6 c'est si
c'est le coup ici c'est parce qu'en fait
F5 fois abandonner il faut faire C6 pour
essayer d'ouvrir
et là
et là on fait on fait normalement quand
où est-ce qu'on fait puis on prend ces 6
non
le problème c'est qu'on va se prendre
des pions
il y a déjà des B5 dans l'air attention
ça peut aller très vite et sur quel il
prend il y a toujours qui prend le 4 on
a ce B4 et ça peut être très chaud ces
histoires
donc
je me rappelle qu'il y avait une vente
marrante je je
sais prendre qui prend ok il m'écoute
pas du tout il y a pas besoin
quand même
alors
la vaisselle alors que mais il sait pas
il sait pas que je la donne en direct
pendant les commentaires de la PC
souvent je me trompe donc parce que
c'est pas mon répertoire avec les Blancs
donc c'est chose que je travaille mais
que je joue pas donc on était moins
impliqué du coup peut-être dans ma 5
aussi intéressant moi j'aime bien les
Noirs ici Damas 5 menace qui prend le 4
on va voir tu aurais foug2 et à ce
moment-là peut-être B5 pour faire bécane
quelque chose comme ça à mon avis à
faire un truc comme ça narodite qui est
en train de choisir entre B5 Damas 5 et
food et 7 et là il va jouer notre truc
foudez 7 aussi pour préparer B5 il a
joué d'un Massac
donc il menace clairement de jouer qui
prend le 4 grand rock maintenant on
n'aime pas trop parce que food et 7
tours C8 cavalier A4 ça vient très vite
ça vient trop vite on n'a pas envie de
faire grand le coup naturel c'est fou G2
mais maintenant il faut garder B5 suite
B4 et ça peut aller extrêmement vite par
exemple si on joue rock
joue B4 qui est de 1 par exemple je fais
x 6
je menace du Fou des trois jeunesse du
Tour C8 je me SB3
ok très intéressant de cette partie
ouais alors oui justement je te flagorde
qui dit on peut pas ok
il y a pas que ici
c'est beaucoup trop je vais montrer un
fou des 7 un tour C8 qui peut-être
cavaler A4 peut-être qu'elle prend un
cadre peut-être B5 B4 ça va beaucoup
trop vite nous on n'est pas on n'est pas
du tout en situation attaquer là-bas
c'est un peu ce qu'on prend plein à
recettes cimetière
c'est l'autre coup ok ça empêche ça
empêche B5 que c'était en prises mais du
coup il en remet une couche dans fous
des 7 il menace maintenant B5 B4
toujours il met un souci peut-être
qu'elle A4 suite
à trois est un coup
à toi est un coup donc pour faire des 4
alors il faut calculer il faut 4 comme
toujours
et il joue il joue ton idée tu sais quoi
il joue ton idée mais en mieux désolé de
te de te le dire c'est que sur X4
maintenant tu fais B3 le four Q et B4
ok c'était l'autre idée sur B4 il y a
dame C7 en profite du clouage de Adam
qui est pas protégé en C2
et il joue Dame des deux aussi bizarre
que ça puisse paraître mais franchement
là les noirs sont très bien on va voir
les valves mais elle met à peu près
égale les Vals normalement elle n'aime
pas du tout les Noirs dans ces Espagnols
et sur quel il prend ses trois là comme
par magie on va jouer évidemment puis on
prend ces trois pour s'ouvrir cette au
moins gagner un temps et pouvoir roquet
assez rapidement mais on a une faiblesse
ici en C3
intéressant position chaque coup est
très cher qui prend ces trois pions
pensé 3 il faut voir dans le genre de
position chaque composition ouverte où
il y a du jeu pour tout le monde où les
enjeux stratégiques sont très compliqués
quel est le plus faible entre le pion
c'est trop et puis en B7 a priori puis
on croit quand même mais en tout cas les
coûts sont chers ça c'est sûr
et joue B6 maroditzkiss casse pas la
tête et il va certainement jouer tour C8
au prochain coup
je sais pas si tu l'as déjà vu faire ses
imitations en arrondiki mais c'est
extrêmement
sur sur Youtube et tu vas voir il fait
il fait un peu tout le monde casse pas
au fil le fait c'est une merveille
B6 donc il joue G5 Magnus
ok cavalier 8 et maintenant c'est 4 ok
comme ça il y a pas de il y a pas
d'embrouille il prend l'espace dame
prend des deux et vous prend des deux à
la petite finale qui est mieux
qui est mieux et pourquoi
on est d'accord
on n'aime pas le cavalier à 8 à moi qui
viennent là
et même le fou des 7 donc qui est pas si
mal finalement il est pas si actif que
ça contrôle des cases mais il a joué F6
et Magnus a répondu H4 F point G5 ça
j'aime pas du tout AG va venir c'est
quasiment certain c'est jouer pour
évidemment qu'on n'aime pas se cavalier
donc on n'a pas envie de lui donner de
l'air et ton F7 maintenant arrive à nous
faire un truc de joueur de stendienne
avec le fou qui vient le 7 peut-être sur
le Calais qui vient en G7 mais c'est en
mode défense ça soit le cavalier qui
vient à 6 suivi de C5
je sais pas un des deux mais c'est pas
mal faute 7 c'est sympa parce que ça
protège ce pion en D6
et ça attaque aussi ça garde un œil sur
ce pion G5
et finalement notre enfin
théoriquement le mauvais fou en F1 qui
protège quand même ces cartes qui est
assez important on aimerait bien faire
fout H3 a priori mais ça
mais comme quoi tu crois c'est truc de
mauvais fou bon fond
en fait j'y crois quand la position est
vraiment bien bien stable mais là le
fait que le pion c'est 4 soit faible
enfin s'il faut disparaît ça ça me
laisse à penser que la position ne passe
est fermée le bon fou mais regarde c'est
ce que tu as dit c'est qu'il a il a pas
beaucoup de cases et donc en fait quand
on a l'avantage d'espace les fous sont
en général tous très bons et joue
cavaliers eux deux Magnus Carson le roi
du remplacement qui est c'est cette
caisse C3 et on veut on veut venir par
là il joue cavaler à 6 lui aussi un
arbre dit ce qui c'est un plan tout à
fait thématique et fou 3 maintenant
jouer est-ce que sur kic-5 il veut
prendre ou pas
j'en sais rien ou alors peut-être qu'il
veut aussi lancer cette attaque
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire ok c'est ça qui
est quand même le coup ou à moins qu'on
commence pas par il a joué kss-5 Naruto
est-ce que est-ce qu'on a pas peur de ça
quand même j'en sais rien j'en sais rien
si on a peur de ça
en tout cas il a pas fait manuscrit
je prends quand je veux ici
il faut vite ça joue très vite des deux
côtés on sent les pourquoi ils ont du
temps il y a une certaine confiance pour
jouer ce début de finale après les coups
sont quand même en replacer les pièces
là voilà on a mis nos pièces on va on va
jouer comme ça avec les noirs on met nos
pièces sur les meilleures cases les
blancs aussi mais la pièce sur la
meilleure case il joue à H3 au final tu
vois il échange son son mauvais fou
entre guillemets
il a attendu que le cavalier vient dans
ses 5 pour obstruire un peu la colonne C
et pour C8 il veut reprendre d'une pièce
pour garder cette faiblesse en C4
ouais on essaie alors tilky j'ai qui
nous dit je suis débutant aux échecs
alors effectivement c'est pas la
meilleure cadence pour les débutants
mais c'est quand même un bon début c'est
pas du Blitz c'est entre le rapide et le
Blitz moi je trouve que pour les
débutants la meilleure cadence c'est
quand même le rapide parce que ça permet
de bien expliquer de passer ennuyer
aussi parce que des parties longues
honnêtement moi quand je commande pas
des parties longues je regarde jamais en
entier ça n'arrive pas quoi ça arrive
plus moi j'écoute souvent un podcast en
fait
c'est à dire que je fais quelque chose
je travaille je fais quelque chose
d'autre et j'écoute les commentaires ça
fait un fond audio et bon
enfin on arrive plus ou moins à suivre à
l'aveugle et puis en écoutant un peu les
bêtises qui sont dites c'est assez sympa
ok intéressant et tour B4 on protège ce
pion et on prépare d'autres choses on va
se faire Naruto
pif tiens il va faire 7 c'est jouer par
nordique qui joue assez vite mais qui a
quand même une minute de moins et
clairement les noirs sont en mode
défense mais en mode très très solide
pas de faiblesse d'ailleurs
il y a des concours pour deviner les
prochains coups qui existent sur
chiasse.com alors je sais pas s'il y a
des prix à gagner ou quoi mais en tout
cas je pense que tu serais très fort
pour deviner les coups de Magnus donc je
connais je connais mon client
ouais et donc comment on fait on met
dans le chat c'est ça comment on fait on
peut mettre dans le chat dans le chat
n'hésitez pas à
mettre beaucoup candidats dans le chat
alors pour l'instant on mettait dans le
chat twitch il faudrait que je cherche
peut-être que pour le prochain le
prochain stream je pourrais trouver
une petite team France et si on deviner
le il a joué il y a eu des coups vous
devez le plan à 4 à 5 c'est une question
posée mais non mais j'y crois pas moi au
plan 4 à 5 mais peut-être parce que
simplement
le silencieuse de la part d'un ski
refuser de manière silencieuse par
Magnus Carlsen en monastère on attaque
le pion ici et le pion ici
on menace pas vraiment
4 donc mais c'est quand même dans l'air
donc ça peut faut faire attention là
faut faire un truc
rebondir sur ce cette question de bon
fous mauvais fou il y a l'idiot dans le
chat 2010 qui nous dit que son
entraîneur donc
Eric priez qui a un grand maître très
connu dans le sud de la France lui
expliquait que un bon fou c'est un fou
qui a des cases
moi j'ai eu j'ai eu avec prier comme
coach des équipes de France quand
j'étais jeune
et donc il y a un petit moment quand
même et donc
voilà ouais très très bon pas connu
alors évidemment parisien de base Clichy
de base et qui maintenant dans le sud
champion de France vétérans maintenant
et oui le temps passe et champion de
France en quelle année toute catégorie
c'est le quiz alors il doit être dans
quelle année je dirais qu'il doit être
né peut-être en 1900
toute catégorie en quelle année
un par toute catégorie je veux dire le
dernier titre du coup son seul titre
comme champion de France le titre qui a
gagné Jul cette année que j'ai gagné
deux fois que Étienne 1987
bravo lilio 2010 bravo qui nous donne
voilà Éric priez ancien champion de
France donc c'est le client à l'époque
où c'était 15 secondes à 5 à tourbé 1
de participer à un championnat de France
de 15 ans
j'ai joué le dernier
j'ai joué le dernier en
98 et on veut pas savoir Robinson qui
dit tu étais né en 95 on peut pas savoir
s'il était né ou pas ça nous intéresse
pas voilà vous savez sport en tout cas
en 95
[Rires]
donc
ouais j'ai joué j'ai joué le dernier à
Méribel 98 mais bon c'est une autre
époque mais en fait ça passait
est-ce que c'était déjà commenté à
l'époque par diagonale TV avec les
fameuses Stéphane Laborde
[Musique]
ses adversaires jouer dans une base de
données je peux te dire que il était bon
il savait s'organiser c'était c'était
ambiance tu te prépares non on marche
avec le début d'ordinateur moi j'avais
un ordinateur j'ai téléchargé les trucs
déjà à l'époque
une habitude que j'ai gardé en fait
pour être très honnête c'est pas mal et
tout hein moi j'ai téléchargé chaque
semaine je regarde des parties qui ont
été jouées tu vois ça me permet de
rester
update
un jour et ça fait depuis 98 que je fais
ça au minimum donc ça fait un petit
moment
c'est vraiment le début mais il y avait
encore des joueurs je pense que la
moitié des joueurs national avaient pas
de il se préparait à l'ancienne Isabelle
boire un coup avec leurs copains et puis
regarder tiens lui il joue là demain il
joue à quoi il fait allez vas-y on
regarde un truc et puis voilà
j'imagine que c'était le début de
l'ordinateur personnel en plus à ce
moment-là donc oui tu avais pas de
logiciel frites que tu matais facilement
n'importe quel joueur de club battait
donc c'était pas intéressant
alors c'est juste pour avoir les infos
avoir les infos c'est important les rois
des trois il se fait visser
la minéraux de ski il est complètement
vissé mais comment on passe avec les
Blancs
il revient pas sûr pas sûr pas sûr parce
que si on faisait ça ou ça ou ça ou ça
ah oui peut-être qu'il pourrait entrer
comme ça possible après il fait quelque
chose est-ce qu'il est pas juste coincé
c'est encore une autre question
pour un musc qui amélioré on voit toutes
ces pièces seront parfaitement placées
maintenant il est c'est le temps de
l'action le roi est centralisé regardez
quelle harmonie a dans ce dans son jeu
on va voir sur foot français 5 comment
on reprend après on reprend quand même
de la tour
parce qu'on va prendre de la Tour a
priori quand même pour se retrouver un
peu quand je crois qu'il va être obligé
un moment ou un autre de prendre je vois
pas mais remarquer ça laisse ce pionger
5 après donc peut-être pas
et on se pose la question je te flagorie
on sait pas et pendant ce temps Brandon
il y a comme ça on a apporté un point
pour Charlotte donc il revient à un
point contre Jennifer you
ouh là ça fait du 5 4 tout ça très très
chaud
ce Brandon
Jennifer
qui prend le temps voilà ici il connaît
un Magnus position critique il va
réfléchir et tenter de trouver la
meilleure façon d'essayer de briser la
résistance de Nord auditski l'ordinateur
qu'est-ce qu'il dit l'ordinateur je vais
regarder les variantes là je triché un
petit peu fous prends ces cinq tours F4
ouais mais c'est hyper il a joué fou
français 5 tours français 5 jouer et là
apparemment il y a F4 qui est très fort
pas du tout je sais pas et pour libérer
ça et surtout reprendre ici ça permet à
tout reprendre c'est ce qui va le voir
ton français ça qu'il a joué F400
il a enfin un pion prend qu'est-ce qu'il
va faire puis on prend on va arriver
c'est obligatoire puis on prend
puis on prend 4 jouets
et là apparemment qu'elle prend des 6 et
c'est le 5 c'est quoi le coup ah parce
que ah oui qui prend des 6 c'est génial
tout reprend des 6 tours H7 et après je
me sens et
5 de gagner à tout incroyable
et surtout ranger 5 c'est 5 tours des 8
si tout A83 F7 et c'est Mato prochain
incroyable oh là là c'était pas facile à
voir franchement
c'est intéressant cette gestion du temps
de Magnus qui a joué très vite le début
de la finale qui a vraiment gardé tout
son temps pour le moment critique ouais
c'est la position qu'elle prend des 6
fous Pranger 5 oh là j'arrive plus à
pardon j'arrive plus à updater là j'ai
un problème
F4 puis on prend ok prends des six fous
Pranger 5 jouer mais E5 arrive menace
cavalier 4
menace peut-être même aussi avec des
matins
quand même la tour va devoir reculer on
va pousser aussi on va tout pousser ton
C8 E6 on peut pas faire tout recettes il
y a cavalier F6
tourger 7 oh là là ça donne envie de on
peut même avancer le roi si on a envie
d'être fans sinon il fait des six G5 au
minimum il y a 7 qui gagne une pièce
ça a l'air pas mal comme minimum ça me
plaît bien
ouais c'est ça je vois permaban zéro qui
dit c'est quoi on voit on voit des
joueurs moi expérimentés dans le chat
c'est bien c'est quoi différents GM et
WGM voilà c'est exactement j'aime mixte
j'aime féminin voilà j'aime féminin doit
avoir un élo 2350 à un moment donné
après on perd pas c'est titre qu'on est
à vie
tandis que le GM masculin doit avoir un
élo de 2500
donc le titre de mettre international
mixte et un tout petit peu plus élevé
que le type de Grand Maître féminin
c'est ça
quand une femme est grand maître féminin
et maître international on met maître
international OK
il va s'amuser à prendre des pions alors
la seule chance de survie pour les Noirs
ici c'est le faible nombre de pions si
on arrive à tout échanger
une femme peut avoir le titre de GM bien
sûr et pas juste WGM évidemment
c'est sûr et je crois que dans le monde
il y en a de plus en plus il y en a 25
30 j'en sais rien très bon exemple Irina
crush chez cru je sais pas comment on
dit dans l'équipe de charlottes
il se prend tous les coups du tennis qui
perd tous les pions c'est terminé il va
perdre face à Magnus Carson qui
permet à son équipe et bien de sauver
l'honneur dans ce match parce qu'il y a
deux et demi un an et demi maintenant on
a un petit spoiler mais bon on sait que
il va la gagner malus il y a pas de
suspense petite spoiler du score mais du
coup ça fait un demi ça nous donne une
dernière ronde assez palpitante
un petit point d'avance pour autre chose
et tout ça
on espère pas si un match à 21h
dans le chat on te demandait tout à
l'heure qu'il était ton pseudo sur
Chess.com
parce que j'avais je m'étais
rétrospectivement je me suis inscrit en
premier surchauffement comme j'ai joué
des à l'époque des titles Tuesday et
j'ai même commenté sur chaise comme en
français avant de commencer sur chaise
24 en français était créé en 2019 donc
j'avais fait quelques commentaires avec
avec Kevin Bordy sur la chaîne Chess.com
des des speechess et
[Musique]
et voilà donc j'ai pas changé de pseudo
c'est vrai que ça faisait un moment que
j'avais pas joué j'ai recommencé à jouer
un petit peu du coup on invite les mêmes
les membres Premium même si vous avez
sur le site chaise 24 vous avez un lien
vers la zone de jeu James COM qui quand
même qui marche mieux que
il faut quand même appeler un chat qui
marche mieux que la zone de jeu Jason 4
qui a jamais vraiment bien marché très
honnêtement je peux le dire maintenant
on va dire ça ça jamais été ça jamais
été le point fort de chaise 24 et
pourtant
je te le dis moi je travaille ah mais
moi j'ai passé des heures les gens
croirait pas je pense en tout cumulé
j'ai passé des journées entières à
tester la zone de jeu à faire des
retours à faire du truc et tout ça mais
bon ça a jamais vraiment aidé les
chances de Paris ce soir c'est pas
terrible
je connais beaucoup de gens qui
rêveraient de se faire embaucher en tant
que testeur de zone de jeu
j'ai reçu le plan d'applications à
chiasse.com de gens qui qui voulaient
faire des crash tests de la plateforme
ok malheureusement on n'a pas besoin de
gens pour de qui font des crashtags de
la personne pour que le site crash donc
ok mais là ça va mieux dans ces derniers
jours ouais d'ailleurs pour rebondir la
suivi ça va un peu mieux et chaque jour
ça va un petit peu mieux en fait et je
pense que ouais d'ici quelques semaines
ce sera vraiment de l'histoire ancienne
ce qui était un petit peu compliqué au
début c'était que bon il fallait acheter
un peu plus de place donc ça ça a été
fait immédiatement mais après il fallait
tout reparamétrer et ça ça pas mal de
temps parce qu'il fallait changer
d'infrastructure pour passer à quelque
chose d'un peu plus évolué en regardant
déjà un peu le futur et maintenant ça a
été bien mis en place et ouais je pense
que dans quelques semaines ça ça devrait
bien aller
d'accord bah tant mieux
c'est après moi je crois je pense la
poisse
ben oui
ça me empêche pas un moment ça me
faisait du souci comme on dit mais
plus maintenant je peux te dire ça
m'empêche pas de dormir
alors pour ma culture j'espère comme une
société allemande ça m'étonner une
société américaine exactement bien bien
américain c'est Chase 24 qui à l'origine
est une société allemande je crois tout
à fait tout à fait très allemand fondé
en bourse
voilà qui après chaise 24 est
indépendant au départ qui a rejoint le
groupe
play Magnus et ensuite le groupe play
Magnus a rejoint le groupe jessiccom
donc voilà ça c'est fait ça c'est fait
en trois ans d'où vient le 24 de chaise
24 et bien c'est le quiz pourquoi
c'est pas vrai mais je me suis je me
suis toujours demandé mais j'en ai
vraiment aucune idée
c'est surtout la raison c'est pas c'est
pas la réponse c'est la raison voilà
donc mais c'est vrai que ça c'est pas
assez simple régulièrement
trop être trop trop bien trop bien
cherché mais une fois que c'est ce point
commun est pris c'est c'est délic à toi
non parce que si ça plaise 24 un truc
comme ça ce serait tout de suite évident
que c'est 24/24 quoi mais avec les
échecs ouais
tout à fait
Esteban à Honda
et salut je vois des nez sur Youtube
n'hésitez pas à aller alors c'est comme
vous voulez si vous préférez twitch
YouTube s'accordent une légère
légère plus qu'on peut pas suivre
tous les peut-être ça aussi on peut le
changer d'ailleurs ouais moi je peux moi
je vois les messages sur Youtube ouais
je vois aussi là mes yeux
tu es dans le stream c'est ça exactement
mais effectivement mais je vois ouais je
vois donc n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à
mettre des petits pouces ça fait
toujours plaisir
abonnez-vous à deux chaînes sur Youtube
sans souci abonnez-vous de chaîne mais
surtout à
ces sympathique mais surtout à cheescom
Fr évidemment c'est là où se passe sera
sur c'est à dire que voilà les choses se
passeront 100% sûr sur le chaise comme
fr sur chaise 24 fr on essaiera de faire
mais on pourra pas le faire non plus
tout le temps et comme j'avais commencé
à l'expliquer mais j'étais vite
interrompu en étant mieux au début de la
pause tu le dis assez poliment c'est
bien
et bien donc la chaîne chaise 24 à faire
évidemment pour l'instant on va rester
je pense pas qu'elle est vocation elle
disparaître comme on disait il y a des
milliers et des milliers d'heures
enregistré dessus donc vous pourrez
toujours trouver le contenu qui est bien
sûr gratuit sur Youtube et mais les
streams seront toujours sur chaise comme
fr peut-être parfois aussi stream sur
chaise 24 fr ça je sais pas comment ça
va évoluer on verra
et pour ce qui est de la zone de jeu
donc nos équipes travaillent pour que
pour que les gens qui avaient un
abonnement 15 24
plus avoir un équivalent à terme sur
chiasse.com et peut-être vice-versa donc
ça c'est encore c'est encore en process
c'est pas la plus grosse priorité ces
derniers temps avec le City crasher mais
on peut dire que c'est le but quoi donc
voilà quand on cherche une solution
bon il y a pas de raison que que des
gens soient aisés donc les gens qui ont
soutenu que ce soit chass 24 ouches.com
ou chessable ou une autre compagnie de
qui fait partie du de ce grand groupe ne
seront pas les ai bien au contraire je
crois que ce sera même une bonne
opération au final
le but d'une fusion en général c'est de
créer des synergies justement créer de
la valeur pour tout le monde
donc on va voir quand on va commencer 7
e partie
entre les chaises où on va avoir Magnus
Carsen face à
qui a tout gagné encore non il a tout
gagné ou pas je crois qu'il y a tout
gagné
notre avion il a battu Jennifer you dans
la première ensuite il a battu
il a énormément il a perdu contre race
van près au tout ah donc il est pas du
tout à 100% Maggie scarsen et donc le
seul joueur à avoir 100%
bien on va voir en tout cas même s'il
aura un cœur de
rapporter encore un point
il est pour l'instant le MVP de sans
surprise de ce match et on voit il a les
Noirs contre
Liang à vendeur
pas de spoiler s'il vous plaît dans le
chat sur le score du foot merci
donc vous explique que c'est un but du
PSG si j'ai bien compris c'est ça pardon
donc ils peuvent décrire que s'il y a un
but du PSG non
ça va pas commencer mais je sais que ça
a pas commencé ça 21h
mais si titulaire
des espaces c'est bon ça
n'est pas dans un alors est-ce que dans
un club non il est pas dans une team il
est pas dans une équipe les autres
équipes jouent tous les jours cette
semaine mardi donc aujourd'hui mercredi
demain 16h30 même heure jusqu'à à peu
près 21h 21h30 mais je dis pareil
vendredi pareil et ensuite la semaine
d'après c'est ça c'est chaque semaine
exactement 5 semaines je me demande s'il
y a pas une petite semaine d'écart au
milieu ou cinq jours je me rappelle il y
avait un tout petit gap
autour du 8 mars ou quelque chose comme
ça
d'accord à vérifier mais globalement
c'est quasiment toutes les semaines quoi
c'est ça
presque 6 ans
on fait des trucs tous les jours mais ça
c'est eux ça tu rigoles mais et on a
cette partie entre Irina crush et
Jennifer you les deux joueuses
américaines et ça sonne à la porte
je sais pas si on entend tu as entendu
ou pas
que la porte reste ouverte ça sonne pas
10 fois tout va bien
ouais dans la team voilà ah ouais très
bien merci Titi Camille la présentation
des équipes de cette prochaine Ligue
avec une très belle équipe française qui
peut viser à Victor finale on a vu une
équipe indienne là dans le premier match
costaud et chessbra bon ben c'est inégal
mais il y a un tel leader que ça peut
faire gagner
ça peut faire gagner avec un minuscal
scène comme aujourd'hui qui en feu 3 sur
3 un point d'avance ça veut dire que
c'est c'est camarades sont dans le nez
sont dans le négatif ils sont dans le
dur c'est camarades mais bon
ça suffit
parce que avec son hello qui est
tellement plus que tout le monde ça
limite les possibilités de l'effectif
j'imagine et pas tant que ça parce qu'il
est redescendu à 2700
c'est le classique il est redescendu à
2700 pour la calculer la moyenne c'est
la règle
j'ai complètement oublié ce détail donc
en fait
tu peux mettre Magnus et oui fan
finalement ça fait un résultat neutre à
la fin
par rapport aux règles
par rapport au 250
donc ça favorise évidemment les très
très fort joueur les joueurs de 1700
sont entre guillemets pas des bonnes
affaires
mais c'est peut-être le changement de
scène qui a fait ça
pardon oui parce que j'avais pas mis
l'autre truc il y a mon il y a mon micro
qui a sur l'autre scène ouais donc ce
qu'on disait c'est que sur le papier
voilà c'était où il fallait je pense
qu'on a compris par rapport à ce que tu
disais non
alors on a comme d'habitude Manu ce qui
commence un dernier on a pour cette
ronde descive un point d'avance pour les
non pour les chaises bras avec Ariane
Tariq elle est blanc ok les Noirs contre
narwinky et il y a comme sonne qui joue
contre prêt au tout ras van mais qui
avait l'air de très très bien se
débrouiller donc chaque nul est bonne à
prendre entre guillemets pour pour les
chaises bras sachant que manuscrite va
commencer sa partie
bonjour stouf qui est dans le chat donc
tout ce qui est un commentateur de notre
chaîne qui me rejoindra je crois jeudi
vendredi c'est ça exactement donc le
programme de cette semaine c'est demain
take fresh OST avec
Kevin perle de nouveau pour les deux
matchs cette fois-ci et puis les deux
dernières rondes textrays os de nouveau
et cette fois ce sera surtout en cause
Kévin ne fait des apéros que le mardi
soir pas le mercredi en fait le mercredi
c'est le seul soir il fait pas d'apéro
donc on peut la voir pour les deux
matchs sinon le les autres jours c'est
pas bon
exactement alors foutez trois bon on a
quelque chose de très très standard donc
une mer en on appelle ça une Merrant
voilà
V3 vous imaginez bien que B3 c'est pas
une tentative de réputation c'est une
tentative de sortir ses pièces gentiment
et fubé 4 qui est un coup intelligent
parce que si on fait fou B2 on se met
dans le clouage donc fout des dents
enlève le clouage mais du coup
maintenant on va pouvoir comme elle l'a
fait dans la partie reculer et ce fou
elle est vraiment envie de venir en B2
pour ça qu'on a joué B3 donc on perd un
temps mais on a on a envoyé ce fou sur
Amazon c'est prendre des 5 c'est un
petit peu surprenant mais l'air de
savoir ce qu'elle fait et Manu ça a
toujours pas commencé
tandis que narodisky a joué son premier
coup contre Ariane tari voilà qu'est-ce
qui se passe qu'est-ce que c'est un bug
ou pas
concentré sur sa partie
peut-être que il y a le décalage
[Musique]
c'est juste on n'a pas on n'a pas les
compétences vu que c'est moi qui produit
donc voilà désolé là il y a eu un petit
il y a eu trop de trucs à gérer
aujourd'hui et c'est vrai que ce zoom ça
m'a vachement surpris on n'avait pas
fait de test il a la configuration du
truc m'a surpris alors il y a plus une
fois que j'ai réussi à cadrer visite il
a bougé de place bon ça m'a ça m'a
carrément énervé
c'est dur de suivre là c'est mal foutu
mais il y a pas vraiment de bonne
solution en fait
dans le zoom et ça change la place de
tout le monde c'est ça donc là en fait
soit faut un producteur soit c'est en
fait c'est quasi impossible de suivre en
même temps je pense je sais pas comment
ils font les autres shows est-ce que en
allemand
en allemand en allemand c'est compliqué
aussi
il y a les mêmes moyens qu'en français
il a pas mis les câbles non plus
impossible d'accord
on a une Razer la classique
Dame des deux fougères
on a deux choix soit on fait F4 sont FF3
F3 prépare évidemment une expansion ici
tandis que F4 évidemment prépare plus 5
plus tard donc c'est un choix bon les
deux lignes se valent à peu près F3 kg 6
rois bien H6 là il fait foncé
G4 H4 donc ça peut pas être un peu
surprenant et pourquoi pas et dames et
cette fou C4 c'est aussi un plan de
mettre de faux en B3 c'est pas payer
c'est un peu tous les planches je sais
pas j'aime pas trop ce qu'il fait avec
les Blancs pour être honnête
je trouve que plutôt j'ai quatre H4 mais
que font les Noirs maintenant est-ce
qu'on fait vraiment petit rock du côté
cimetière
maintenant qu'on a poussé à 6 c'est
compliqué
ça laisse une petite envie de faire
c'est vrai
petit rock fait pas envie peut-être tout
simplement
ça va pour les pour les Noirs je sais
pas est-ce que manus a commencé
et on a une Française chez manuscrit
F6 fou j'ai 5 et puis on prend le 4 il
avait joué à 6 ici un manuscrite
mais cette fois il décide de prendre
quatre qui est 4 qui est BD7 qui est
3 une ligne que j'ai beaucoup joué avec
les blancs très très solide alors si je
me passe un peu de pub pour une série de
choses 24 que j'avais beaucoup aimé il
me semble que Romain Édouard
recommandaille de Caliber des 7 fous et
7 il a fait une vidéo série là dessus
d'accord
[Musique]
jouer une position c'est ça tout à fait
d'accord je trouve qu'il donne la
solution ouais mais tu as eu deux salles
différentes enfin bon on en parlera
mais il y a deux salles différentes
cette fois là
galerie galerie view c'est ça
mais bon après c'est une question
d'habitude aussi alors
non mais c'est un truc nouveau pour moi
aussi tu vois de gérer ce truc des
caméras c'est ce que j'ai dit la
première fois que je vois cette espèce
de zoom c'est pareil en plusieurs pièces
normalement je le fais pas en fait sur
chaise 24 dès qu'on avait des caméras si
on avait un peu beaucoup dans un zoom
comme ça tu vois dans un tournoi nos
tournois on avait un producteur tu vois
parce que les caméras pour les candidats
et tout ça tu vois c'est vachement plus
facile à récupérer tu as juste un lien
tu le mets et puis c'est terminé
donc MLF 3 c'est 5c3 Liang il joue très
très solide contre Magnus mais attention
parce que Magnus il a une belle
technique aussi
donc il peut
il peut
il peut gagner des positions qui
paraissent assez sèches
assez facilement
on va évidemment jeter un œil sur les
autres parties cette fois parce que là
c'est chaud ça compte
et les autres joueurs peuvent regarder
les autres partis aussi donc ça peut
être ça peut donner des décisions
intéressantes
à la partie de Jacobson s'en va alors
qui joue son jeu
écoute
il a bien raison il joue pas pour faire
nulle
c'est normal la couleur des Ch'tis qui
change quand j'analyse on est d'accord
je pense d'accord je pense
donc A4 ouais mais bon en même temps tu
t'es affaibli ici
qu'est-ce que je fais baisser je fais x
2 x 2 tu vois je te pose une question tu
fais B3 ok je prends
je continue
mais oui effectivement je suis d'accord
ça met la pression quand même
le plan des Noirs
oui c'est normal la couleur
il maîtrise un peu plus ça s'en vouloir
être désobligeants avec personne mais on
sent qu'il maîtrise le truc là
et un peu comme moi à l'époque sur
j'avais quand même réponse à beaucoup de
choses pour pour le coup au bout d'un
moment on commence à avoir ouais avec
beaucoup de compteurs notamment on
commence à avoir réponse à pas mal de
trucs parce qu'on a utilisé qui est pas
mal d'ailleurs le logiciel c'est pas
c'était déjà vu ce logiciel de
retransmission pas du tout ouais c'était
pas mal du tout mais bon le truc est
bien là aussi
B3 mais il me fait mentir tiens après on
fou prend moi j'avais dit que c'était
rien
et lui il a peur de penser ça bon
maintenant elle est clairement les Noirs
vont ok qu'il est 7 et on voit gentiment
attaquer par là fu F6 peut-être un coup
de damassette à un moment
potentiellement il y a une grosse
attaque je crois qu'on peut pas se
permettre d'essayer de capitaliser sur
ce en plus je crois qu'il faut essayer
de créer du jeu de balancer là-bas parce
que si on joue lentement on va on va se
faire on va se faire massacrer tu penses
quoi dans le plan comme G5 H4 ouais mais
alors j'ai cinq là quand même tu me tu
me poses une grosse question là quand
même
je crois que je suis obligé de prendre
non justement
je suis pas je suis pas compliqué moi je
prends ici et je joue au prochain coup
et puis je te souhaite bonne chance
mais bon apparemment il a pas l'air il a
pas l'air impressionné peut-être un truc
comme ça
qui fait tourner
c'est chaud c'est une course finalement
et apparemment la jauge j'aime beaucoup
les Noirs ce qui relancerait quand même
ce match très largement on va voir chez
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans le duel
entre les meilleurs joueuses américaines
on peut on peut le dire comme ça elles
font en général quand les
championnats-unis c'est le titre se joue
entre ces deux joueurs
je crois que c'est Jennifer qui a gagné
l'année dernière
et les noirs sont pas mal
les noirs sont pas mal du tout
en situation pour ces derniers matchs
peut-être et que ça donne entre
narrodisky pour l'instant c'est bon pour
les
pour les charlottes
je trouve personne qui s'est plaint mais
c'est bizarre moi non plus je l'ai pas
quand je regarde et là on a une petite
française une petite structure alors
évidemment le but de la française c'est
c'est de si on arrive à sortir s'en fout
tout va bien
et voilà comment ça se passait les
partages c'est du 3 + 2 entre le
quatrième échiquier
pas le premier pas de Magnus
c'est ça
il me semble je pense qu'on a une petite
slide là-dessus qui explique
le départage ça doit être
non ça en anglais
malheureusement on n'a pas le droit de
le faire jouer les Chica
voilà ça se passe comme ça
en général on fait on fait ça et une
fois qu'on a le fond en C6 mais on est
pas mal ah il fait le 5 ambitieux sacré
Magnus
génial parce que tu vois tu vas sortir
ton four en plus tu as pris les cases du
cavalier tu vois ça c'est des coups
multifonctions qui sont rarement mauvais
quand même tu prends des cases tu sors
ton fou tu peux même chatouiller avec
fougères ok effectivement tu as faibli
spion mais bon pour 8 tour 8 va être
gentiment jouer par Magnus Carlsen
je vois pas quoi d'autre franchement
c'est le genre de coup que je pense
l'ordinateur dit souvent que c'est
proche de l'égalité mais c'est beaucoup
plus facile à jouer du côté bien joué
il y a une logique à chaque coup un
cavalier avec un avenir et maintenant
qu'il y a des deux il veut faire
cavalier au 4 Yang qui joue il joue
céréales dans cette partie il est
il est au courant
ouais car ça a gagné un peu la même
poste contre meilleure aux Olympiques je
sais plus trop genre un genre de truc
comme ça
on m'entend plus là si si on monte
on ne bluff pas vite
contre Maya ou c'était nul il y a
toujours beaucoup de mal contre Maya F3
fait mal de jouer toi quand même
ça fait quand même
pour pour
longtemps ce roi Angers qui a déjà plus
trop de pions devant lui
contrairement au roi noir Kanaka
et en plus si on est obligé de pousser
déjà qu'il y a un pion ici ça fait
toujours des dames B6 échec par exemple
sur dame Pro 5 voilà tout de suite
ça me prend B2 et après il reste plus
que des
qu'une ruine de la structure des
structures de pions
blanches comme un temps de loin je vais
me rapprocher du micro là est-ce que les
Blancs seraient pas très contents de
changer les deux cavaliers ici
on serait content chaque échange est bon
quasiment sans renforce le cafard le
fait d'avoir que des fous de case
blanche les faiblesses sur place noires
sera peut-être moins moins gênante on
entend bien mieux Nathan ok je te baisse
ça marche est-ce que c'est mieux comme
ça c'est tout
ok je sais pas pourquoi pourtant
c'est la merde ça m'était jamais arrivé
le micro
il est à fond
c'est aussi simple que ça moi je
t'entends très très bien
[Musique]
c'est assez incroyable
ce qui se passe mais bon je sais pas
si tu vas dans les paramètres de ton
micro là elle est trop petit
du coup je vois pas la fenêtre que tu
viens d'ouvrir mais ce que tu as pas
moyen de mettre un peu plus haut
si jamais
alors
je pense que là c'est mieux déjà
salut je pense que toujours trop fort là
je pense que là c'est bon
je pense
j'espère j'écouterai ensuite ça va pas
mieux aussi peu
on entend bien t'express très bien
parfait c'est toujours abonné mais
t'inquiète pas tu peux toujours garder
les vidéos là merci à toi
ouais c'est marrant c'est fou ce fou à
l'afficheur là
par exemple
[Musique]
5 non si c'est demi
et Magnus Carter en difficulté
dans cette partie apparemment d'après la
jauge oh là là oh là là
sur les autres parties qu'est-ce que
bah du coup on n'a pas de nouvelles de
narodinsky on sait pas du tout ce qui
s'est passé et chez les femmes
à l'échiquier 4
américaine il me semble ré que les noirs
sont un petit peu mieux ouais mais rien
de rien ça peut à tout moment finir en
finale bien nulle et là on a la partie
de Magnus Carson qui joue à 5 les coups
qu'on avait prédim et moi j'aimais pas
du tout qui est dans le 4 mais bon après
peut-être le roi s'en va
trouver mieux ouais c'était ça peut-être
un manque de bon coup évidemment ça lui
plaît pas
voilà il n'y a pas de motos sur twitch
j'ai pas accès sauf si tu es là tu peux
agir s'il te plaît
alors
7 ah moi je suis terrible je suis pas du
tout pour arriver si sur le papier
alors
Adam 4 menace 7 suivi de 6 mais ce qu'on
va faire ou pas bon le premier message
ça allait encore le deuxième
très limite
j'ai pas vu les commentaires sur
évidemment qu'il a joué dans difficulté
2 minutes contre 4,50 c'est très très
dur pour Magnus dans cette situation
très compliqué
et pendant ce temps est-ce qu'il y a eu
d'autres résultats non on sait toujours
pas narodite qui Ariane tari on a aucune
nouvelle
c'est assez c'est assez dingue ce qui se
passe
on est les seuls
et la tour assez vite qui est une gaffe
d'après la jauge pourquoi
pourquoi c'est une gaffe qu'est-ce qu'il
faut jouer on va regarder on va regarder
je je triche je mets la variante damage
7 3 F8 d'un prince 6 et la regarde ça
nathan
est en prise roi des 7 et là ce que je
veux je joue ce que je veux soit ça soit
ça et c'est jouer et c'est jouer
c'est fini pour le Champion du Monde
il était impérial jusque là et là son
équipe va être menée à cause de sa
défaite et peut-être certainement perdre
le match
terrible
à Magnus qui veut tellement faire gagner
ses équipes mais c'est vrai que c'est
dur la Norvège aussi aux Olympiques j'ai
vu ça de mes propres yeux ils ont joué
dans le hall B à un moment et Magnus est
venu quand même bon camarade mais bon le
relevé moi je sais même pas où il était
c'est pour te dire c'est la France on a
même pas tu vois jouer dans le B
du Canada quoi et parfois parfois il
prend trop de risques parfois il prend
trop de risques pour l'équipe quoi qu'il
a bien joué aux Olympiades et là
aujourd'hui ouais ça c'est mal à la
dernière c'est mal passé et elle fait
mal
on peut on peut faire fouter 5 à l'air
d'être le petit coup sûr quand même
si tu vois ce que je veux dire je sais
pas si tu aimes les petits coups sur
mais franchement faut baisser 5 mois
c'est 7 tours bon bon ben on gagne quand
même
des petits coups surprend et si tu fais
tu reprends fou reprends tu as perdu une
tour et si tu fais dame prend j'ai
l'impression j'ai ta meuf 4 et je vais
te ah tu es encore roi des 7 chemises oh
c'est pas si simple ça va si simple je
veux dire c'est pas si mal tout de suite
voilà c'est pas si mal tout de suite on
est d'accord ouais bon au pire on fait
tout reprend on gagne la finale mais bon
je pense qu'il va trouver quelque chose
est-ce que Magnus va la jouer surtout
roi C7 quasiment obligé quoi d'autre
ça doit aller
dur et nul entre
Jennifer you et Erina crush c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a cette partout là au moment où
on parle donc ça va faire 8,7 à la
victoire de Lyon à wander c'est-à-dire
si Ariane tarin ne gagne pas sa partie
contre l'art au ski il n'y a pas de
matchs de partage et on n'a pas d'update
sur la partie derrière ta taille il a
les Noirs contre Naruto on ne sait pas
du tout ce qui se passe on est à
l'aveugle il a joué ces 7 Magnus cars 7
tours 8 ça me prend mes cinq jouets et
là il y a anguille doit chercher la
façon la plus sûre de l'emporter face à
Magnus parce qu'attention
j'arrive à avoir Ariane tari sur la
caméra de derrière il est encore en
train de jouer
ouais mais ce qu'on a sa position donc
pourra pas le montrer mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que je peux dire que
c'est en train de jouer d'accord
le suspense est à son comble il y a
combien pour ceux qui regardent le PSG
là dites-moi j'en peux plus en fait j'ai
envie de savoir
il y a comme il y a le Bayern mais la
pression l'équipe
il y a combien
alors et on revient aux échecs Magnus
Carsen plus qu'en souffrance là pour le
coup
je pensais pas que ça allait dire aussi
longtemps pour être très honnête
je pensais qu'à 21h c'était réglé cette
histoire
qu'est-ce qui va jouer à vendeur en plus
non seulement il a une position gagnante
mais en plus il a du temps de 30
toujours pas de nouvelles de il joue
toujours à ça alors évidemment rien
n'est fini on va revoir Magnus Carson
dans cette compète c'est juste un
premier match mais c'est comme tous les
premiers matchs on préfère les gagner
c'est logique
qu'est-ce qui va jouer Magnus
non avant de y réfléchit
la F4 est sympa bon quel est le plus sûr
alors je vais remettre ça fatigue je
vais remettre la jauge ta F4 3D 7 tours
4 et le mur d'après la jauge ça pas mal
quand même tour des 4 qui arrive mais
bon il y a tellement de possibilités là
pour les blancs il faut choisir une il a
fait ça il a fait dans ma fuite ouh
c'est pas mal ça sur moi c'est ça qui
veut faire encore d'un bref 7
roisser cette jouer dame prime 7 jouer
il a calculé cette finale prend F7 c'est
sûr que ça gagne
ça joue un petit peu petit bras de la
part de
vendeur attention
à la sauver d'autres attention mais si
c'est une menace maintenant parce que
toi aussi sur un robe B7 tu auras 7 sur
un B8 et ensuite on pousse le pion mais
en tout cas c'est clair que le plan des
noirs et tout de suite beaucoup plus
tracé que le plan de blanc ici
oui c'est ça
jouer B6 tour à 7 maintenant il hésite
entre roisset 6 Roissy 5 ou roi B8
[Musique]
quoique attends on va la calculer cette
ligne on va le calculer on va bouger les
pièces un bâtiment
[Musique]
alors est-ce que c'est que ça donne quoi
la course
je fais ça et ouais c'est j'ai fait une
gaffe encore
c'est chaud
qu'est-ce qui a été joué F4 a été joué
B5 a été joué par Magnus j'aime pas trop
baisser mais bon
ok on va voir on va voir tandis que
c'est toujours pas ce qui se passe c'est
rien de tarif extraordinaire ce stream
et je vous la gagne ça veut peut-être
dire que que est pas si gagnant que ça
tourne 8 à 3 et attention la jauge qui
met égal maintenant
Romanus Carsen quel monstre il pourrait
sauver la partie et oui c'est énorme
c'est énorme Magnus car c'est en train
de sauver sa partie j'ai si ça deux
Tourer roi C6 et attention attention
l'appétit vient de se mangeant surtout
pour quelqu'un comme Magnus Carlson
est-ce qu'il va pas essayer de la gagner
celle-là roisset 5
d'abord il veut faire passer le roi
maintenant
comment on fait maintenant je sais pas
tu peux la perdre facilement roi des 5
il va faire roisser 4 et il va faire
trois voilà
une espèce de technique comme dans la
position devant Cora ou tu fais échec
sur la première la deuxième la troisième
et 4 je sais pas et ça c'est perdant
maintenant c'est perdant mais quel
magicien c'est incroyable ce qui lui
fait vous pensez quatre et maintenant P4
better on lui avait dit ça pouvait
tourner c'est incroyable ce qui s'est
passé dans cette partie sacré Magnus qui
retourne une situation où il était 20
ans en matant 3 en gros c'est incroyable
incroyable B3 B2 il a complètement
paniqué avant d'arriver à ça vouloir
d'absurer chèque oh là là là c'est la
cata
et victoire de Magnus Carlsen mais qui
est héroïque Mbappe qui marque son 4e
but 4 sur 4 qui donne peut-être la
victoire de chessbra maintenant il peut
faire nul s'il fait nul il gagne
le clutch et ouais matelas tout à fait
raison bravo Magnus le club c'est lui
Magnus c'est
c'est trop fort il fallait pas rentrer
dans cette finale alors c'est facile moi
je je serai certainement entrée dans la
finale vous voyez mais là clairement le
roi est au centre quand on y réfléchit
un petit peu on se dit ça c'est quand
même c'est quand même pas mal ce truc de
faire tour des quatre parce que un coup
comme toi je suis 3g1 MC5 tour des 4 et
on est complètement gagnant
Laurent j'ai le lien de la partie de ta
vie si tu veux en le suivant
j'espère je suis pas en train de montrer
tes messages
on va faire coller
de quel jingle parles-tu
il y a plus de jingle j'avais des jingle
moi je jouais avec des jingles
les commentateurs disaient je vais bien
je m'étais non mais non j'ai pas
alors on va je vois ça marche pas ton
lien
est-ce que tu veux que je te partage mon
écran ça ajoute des complications
et leur dit donne proche de l'égalité et
patienter la connexion prend plus de
temps que d'habitude
pour Poupion contre de même couleur puis
on contre plongée ça va
comme par hasard on arrive quand
l'annuler donc c'est une victoire des
de l'équipe de Magnus Carlson des
chaises bras face à Charlotte sur le
gong grasse
4 sur 4 il a moitié il a marqué
simplement un peu moins de la moitié
mais vraiment un tout petit peu moins un
peu moins de la moitié des points de son
équipe 4 sur 8 et demi
il est incroyable il a retourné cette
situation plus que compromise contre
contre
Yang
vendeur bon qu'est-ce qu'on veut
quand il fait ça bah ouais c'est alors
évidemment il le fait pas c'est pas vrai
tu vois il marque moins moins moins de
moins de la moitié mais il fait quand
même il gagne
voilà qui est une recrue de choix 4 sur
4 8 et demi pour les chaises bras qui
devront pour les prochains matchs quand
même les autres joueurs devront hausser
leur niveau de jeu mais porter par
Magnus ils peuvent aller très loin
Nathan
les deux derniers étaient quand même
clairement enfin en tout cas les lots
plus faibles que chez que chez les
Charlotte Cobra notamment Jennifer you
qui a quand même 100 bons points de
moins que que Irina crush est un titre
de j'aime en moi
et pareil j'aime Brandon Jacobson semble
quand même un peu au dessus
ouais
ils ont eu un bon joueur là 500 à 2525
ou 2520 mais lui il est il est chaud il
est dangereux ça se voit et donc on a
une victoire dans le premier match après
la partie de ce choix on a une victoire
de comment s'appelle-t-il notre ami ah
oui ainsi je change de scène on va plus
longtemps notre ami les Indiens amenés
par visite équipe très impression à
utiliser le micro et demi il y a pas eu
besoin de jouer le
dernier les dernières parties écoute mon
cher attends je crois qu'il est temps
que je te remercie
merci à toi merci pour ton aide
précieuse pour préparer ce stream même
si c'était je m'en excuse auprès de vous
c'était un peu chaotique je crois qu'on
avait on a eu des beaux échecs on a vu
on n'a pas eu les caméras mais ça on va
on va régler peut-être au niveau du son
aussi il y a eu un léger souci je sais
pas ce qui s'est passé le son c'est
assez mystérieux comme truc en général
il faut redémarrer quoi en gros c'est ça
c'est ça la solution donc merci beaucoup
pour sa t'aide pendant le stream et
avant le stream merci beaucoup ah Kevin
thérieux que je retrouverai dès demain à
partir de 16h15 venez les premières
matches à 16h30 merci à vous tous de
nous avoir suivis sur ce show que vous
soyez où vous soyez sur cheesecom twitch
sur chaise com YouTube sur chess com sur
chess 24 en français sur Youtube demain
rebelote on prend les mêmes et on
recommence je vous souhaite à tous et à
toutes évidemment une excellente soirée
ciao ciao